[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour continuer à suivre
l'examen du projet de loi immigration
ici au Sénat toutes nos équipes sont
mobilisées pour vous faire vivre les
vêtements cet après-midi et ce soir et
notre journaliste Steve jourain est dans
l'hémicycle en tribune de presse bonjour
Steve bonjour Alex alors Steve on va
d'abord parler de ce qui s'est passé
hier soir puisque les sénateurs de la
majorité sénateurs de droite et du
centre se sont mis d'accord pour durcir
les conditions de régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tenstion oui c'est en quelque
sorte l'épilogue de ce psychodrame
autour de l'article 3 de ce texte
immigration Alex on va peut-être
rappeler encore une fois ce qu'est cet
article 3 il prévoyait la régularisation
quasi automatique des sans papiers dans
les métier en tension dans les métiers
qui connaissent une pénurie de main
d'œuvre la droite ici n'en voulait pas
du coup cet article a été supprimé hier
à la faveur d'une coalition entre les LR
et l'Union centriste finalement la
majorité sénatoriale il a été remplacé
par un nouvel article l'article 4 bis
qui prévoit et bien de durcir les
conditions de régularisation de ces sans
papier cette régularisation se fera au
cas par cas après l'aval du préfet le
préfet devra et bien contrôler que
certains critères sont bel et bien
respectés certains critères qui ont été
ajoutés comme on retrouve la bonne
intégration dans laass française de du
sanspier en question encore le respect
des valeurs républicaines en résumé ces
nouvelles régularisations se feront au
cas par cas et non de façon quasi
automatique comme le voulait le
gouvernement c'est peut-être un détail
pour vous Alex mais pour Bruno ratillo
ça veut dire beaucoup on va écouter le
patron du groupe LR ici au Sénat alors
c'est extraordinaire monsieur le
ministre vous manquez pas d'air je sais
qu'en politique le culot c'est souvent
une qualité je le reconnais et vous
voulez faire croire que le dispositif
proposé par la majorité sénatoriale
c'est l'équivalent finalement de du
dispositif que vous proposiez mais
queeneni ou alors les groupes de gauche
se trompent pourquoi est-ce que tous les
groupes de gauche montent au créneau
parce que eux voient bien la comparaison
et ils savent bien que la proposition
qu'on fait c'est pas du tout la
proposition initiale qui était le sommet
le paroxisme de la macronie en même
temps pourquoi on s'opposait et pourquoi
c'est beaucoup plus restrictif parce que
vous l'article 3 notamment c'est c'est
un droit automatique vous fraudez et
plus longtemps vous fraudez plus la
fraude est dissimulée et plus ça vous
génère et plus la fraude est créatrice
de droit d'un droit opposable d'un droit
automatique que même l'administration ne
pourra pas stopper bah nous on voulait
pas et c'est pour ça qu'on va le
supprimer voilà donc le le Sénat qui a
durci ce volet du texte immigration et
maintenant et maintenant que va-t-il se
passer c'est toute la question ce matin
dans les pages du Figaro sachaoulier le
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale a affirmé que bien
bien quand le texte reviendra à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés
rétabliront le texte initial celui du
gouvernement autant dire au sénateurs
bah vous travaillez vous bosser un peu
pour rien ça n'a pas du tout du tout plu
ici dans l'hémicycle beaucoup d'enjeux
autour de ce texte vous l'auriez compris
Alexandre la droite qui va et bien
tenter de continuer d'imprimer sa marque
au texte immigration cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle effectivement Steve les
sénateurs qui vont examiner cet
après-midi le volet fermeté de ce projet
de loi immigration avec not des mesures
de renforcement d'expulsion des
étrangers délinquants et criminels allez
tout de suite on va prendre la direction
de l'hémicycle du Sénat pour la suite
des débats au Sénat sur ce projet de loi
immigration alors petit problème
technique on va en attendant de résoudre
ce ce problème on va voir ce que pense
la partie centriste du Sénat justement
sur cet accord important hier soir au
sein de la majorité Sénat atorial alors
le problème est résolu direction la
séance ce que je souhaiterais
effectivement c'est aller plus loin et
qu'aujourd'hui on le fasse soit dans le
cadre de la navette soit dans le cadre
d'un texte à ce moment-là que Monsieur
le Ministre peut-être vous nous donnerez
la date parce que ça ne règle pas le
problème de fond donc il faut aller au
bout du raisonnement et si le
responsable c'est-à-dire le le procureur
le souhaite le demande parce que c'est
lui qui est responsable de l'état civil
demande un mariage il faudrait à mon
avis
qu'il procède au mariage oou qu'on
trouve une formule qui fasse en sorte
que le maire ne soit pas mis au milieu
de cette espèce de conflit d'intérêt de
de position extrêmement délicate où le
maire est obligé de procéder à un
mariage sous contraintte en fait parce
que les documents qu'il a en sa
possession ou l'entretien qu'il a fait
ne correspondent pas à ce qu'il
considère comme quelque chose qui lui
permett de procéder à un mariage donc
aujourd'hui cet amendement je voudrais
c'est qu'on aille dans le sens de la
protection des maires aujourd'hui et de
la responsabilité des procureurs merci
il faut conclure avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
ce cet amendement a été rédigé
activement mais non sans réflexion et il
fait semble-t-il avancer avancer le
débat sur le sujet qui a étit soulevé
par de nombreux collègues y compris par
Monsieur le Ministre hier hier en séance
nous nous rappelons tout de même que
lorsque les maires officil ici pour le
compte de l'État donc il faut bien
évidemment que ce soit l'état qui prenne
ses responsabilités c'est une façon de
permettre à l'État de prendre ses
responsabilités c'est une façon qui
pourra sans doute être améliorée mais en
l'état nous donnons un avis favorable
pour faire progresser le débat merci
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
évidemment j'ai pas eu le temps puisque
je découvre le sousamendement madame
Boyer mais on en avait parlé hier de
consulter la Chancellerie puisquil
s'agit évidment des compétences du
ministre de la justice mais je vais
donner un avis je vais donner un avis
favorable à sous amendement de Madame
Boyet donc au à l'amendement global qui
sera ainsi modifié avec les de mois si
j'ai bien compris la réflexion d'hier en
faisant comme Madame la rapporteur en
promettant peut-être avec vous madame la
sénatrice d'y travailler pour
l'Assemblée nationale et peut-être de
monter une réunion avec les services du
du garde des sauts mais je pense que ça
va dans le bon sens puisque vous avez
précisé ce qu'on a essayé de dire tous
ensemble hier merci Madame
ashliman merci Monsieur le président
juste un mot je souhaitais m'inscrire
dans cette discussion puisque j'ai eu la
même la même réflexion que notre
collègue Valérie Boyet euh j'ai entendu
les débats hier soir parce que je
n'étais pas là physiquement mais j'étais
connecté et j'ai entendu je voulais
d'ailleurs à ce titre remercier à
Monsieur le Ministre pour le propos
qu'il a eu parce qu'il a su faire la
part des choses entre l'intérêt des
mares à vouloir faire prévaloir leur bah
leur leur volonté de ce que des des
mariages non souhaités ne soi pas
célébrer et que la législation ne soit
pas détournée mais en même temps vous
avez vous avez monsieur le ministre pris
en compte aussi une certaine réalité
factuelle qui est aussi la difficulté
que les procureurs que les parquets ont
à faire face à un certain nombre de
demandes qui doivent être de plus en
plus nombreuses nonobstant le fait que
il y a des équipes qui a des substitut
ce n'est sans doute pas évident de
donner suite aux demandes des maires
donc j'avais voulu j'ai déposé un
amendement hier qui était le 492
rectifié bis et qui allait dans le même
sens que celui de Valérie Boyet et je
suis très attentive comme tous les
maires du département des Hautes scènes
mais de façon générale tous nos maires
qui sont soucieux de ce que la
réglementation et la législation soit
bien respecté à ce que dans le cadre de
la navette comme monsieur le ministre
nous l'a proposé très aimablement et
bien cette cette attention cette
préoccupation des premiers magistrats de
de nos communes soit bien prise en
compte merci merci Madame ashliman la
parole est au président monsieur
retaillot oui nous nous étions quittés
hier soir en formulant un vœu c'est
qu'on puisse trouver enfin sur cet
amendement sur cette idée de protection
des Maes vis-à-vis de ces mariages sur
une rédaction qui soit robuste je
voudrais vraiment saluer la commission
saluer le ministre qui s'y était engagé
et rendre à César ce qui est à César je
voudrais vraiment remercier Valérie
Boyet et marido haschliman qui ont
convergé sur cette idée je pense que
nous sommes la chambre des territoires
et l'importance que nous accordons
notamment à la fonction des maires de
ces édil qui sont souvent mis sous
pression y compris dans ce genre de
circonstances elle est fondamentale donc
bien sûr on votera avec une grande joie
cet amendement rectifié merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur hou
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre quand le bébé est beau il
manque pas de paèire hein donc on va
revendiquer aussi une forme de paternité
si vous le permettez sur cette question
en remerciant à mon tour la la
Commission le ministre madame voy et je
pense que bien évidemment c'est pas une
révolution hein mais le fait de de de de
passer de un mois à 2 mois permet au
maire d'avoir un peu plus de temps sur
une question éminemment complexe parce
que juger du bien fondé d'un
mariage c'est une question pour y avoir
été parfois confronté qu'il est
difficile et on n'est jamais totalement
sûr de de son jugement donc c'est une
avancée et encore merci et je pense que
ça va être apprécié et c'est bien que ce
soit ici effectivement dans la chambre
des territoires comme vient de le dire
le Président retaillot je vous remercie
merci Monsieur ho la parole est
maintenant à Madame Nara cigan
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais quand même rappeler que les
maires sont des officiers d'état civil
qui ont donc le devoir d'appliquer la
loi et de célébrer les mariages quel que
soit leurs opinion politique que par
ailleurs dans la législation il existe
déjà suffisamment de disposition qui
interdisent les mariages blancs et les
mariages forcés bien évidemment et que
donc la question n'est pas de changer la
loi mais
vraiment
de d'avoir les moyens nécessaires pour
le faire pour la faire appliquer au-delà
de ça je voudrais moi dénoncer un
mariage blanc qui a eu lieu hier dans
cet
hémicycle qui a été célébré par la les
votes de suppression des articles 3 et 4
et l'adoption de l'article 4
B et euh et qui et qui donc permet qui
donc permet ce mariage de papier à
Monsieur reetaillot et son groupe de
crier victoire et à Monsieur le Ministre
Darmanin de garantir un vote par le
Sénat de ce projet de loi mardi prochain
se pose maintenant la question dans la
navette de l'avenir de ce de ce cette
transaction matrimoniale est-ce que on
va vers une annulation avec les annonces
du président de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée nationale de revenir au
texte initial ce qui donnera l'excuse
attendue par le groupe de derxioti de
déposer une motion de censure du
gouvernement qui peut-être donnera lieu
à de nouveaux types de mariage blanc ou
est-ce que on va vers la consommation de
ce mariage monsieur Darmanin avec un un
nouveau un nouvel accord politique avec
le groupe LR et
une partie du groupe
Renaissance monsieur le
ministre non je je ne répondrai pas aux
provocations juste peutre dire vous
eximer après madame la mesam les
sénatrices qui avent demandé la parole
vous allez vous exprimer à nouveau je
répondrai pas aux provocation évidment
la satrice juste vous dire que je pense
que ce serait bien que vous soyez maire
pour que vous puissiez voir comment ça
se passe dans le monde réel
voilà merci
alors merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
Boyer merci monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai que quand on était sénateur maire
peut-être que les choses étaient plus
facile on voudrait peut-être revenir
là-dessus monsieur le ministre je
voudrais simplement brièvement remercier
la commission remercier mes collègues
pour du groupe centriste comme marieash
liiman Monsieur ho qui avait posé une
question au gouvernement hier et le
président rotaillot pour avancer sur ce
texte et vous faire une petite remarque
ces amendements moi je les avais défendu
en 2018 lors de la loi colon ils avaient
été rejetés d'un revers de main avec
beaucoup de mépris et pourtant la
situation à laquelle sont exposés nos
mères est toujours difficile vous l'avez
dit ils sont sous pression pour ces
affaires de
mariage et il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire donc je je prends note de ce que
vous avez dit et j'espère qu'on pourra
travailler un texte beaucoup plus étaufé
beaucoup plus sérieux là c'est un
premier pas mais il convient vraiment
d'aller beaucoup plus loin euh dans le
dans le couple que fait enfin dans la
subordination du maire au procureur en
tant qu'officier d'état civil pour qu'on
puisse avancer et ne pas laisser les
maires encore une fois avec des
injonctions contradictoires et c'est
très bien que ça se passe ici au Sénat
donc je vous remercie merci Madame Boyer
alors avant de vous donner la parole
madame de La Gonterie un petit élément
de procédure lorsque Monsieur le
Ministre demande la parole il a priorité
sur tout le monde voilà à vous c'est
comme ça c'est ça le
problème c'est que le M d'ailleurs crois
que c'est toujours nous vous écoutons
quand il veut euh alors premièrement je
suis désolé parce que c'était pas
l'objet mais euh je je pense que c'est
sans doute la fatigue hein parce que
incontestablement vous menez ce débat
avec beaucoup
de d'engagement
et un certain talent pour autant je ne
suis pas totalement sûr que lorsque
Madame naraassigin souligne le fait
qu'il y a eu un mariage arrangé entre LR
et les centristes sur le sujet vous
deviez lui répondre totalement à côté
mais ça fait toujours plaisir parce
qu'une femme c'est quand même d'abord
quelqu'un d'incompétent de dire ah mais
si vous étiez maire vous sariez de qu'on
parle j'indique que nous avons tous ici
célébrer des mariages nous avons tous
ici eu à connaître ou non de ce type de
difficulté donc je vous épargne je pense
ce type de remarque d'autant que toutes
ces dispositions permettent à Madame
Boyer mais je la reconnais là et à la
droite de voilà de de de de de montrer
que il est très exigeante et C mais on
sait que ça ne passera pas le cap de la
Constitution donc c'est un petit peu en
terme de de d'efficience législative
monsieur ho fronce le sourcil droit
article 45 de la Constitution le Code
civil n'est absolument pas concerné par
le projet de loi donc le Conseil
constitutionnel censurera donc tout ce
que nous sommes en train de dire et sera
nul et non avenu mais cela vous permet
de dire un certain qu'est-ce qui est
insupportable la Constitution B changez
là madame
Boyer on ne s'interpelle pas alors nous
allons mettre au voix je vais mettre au
voix la l'amendement 61 rectifi qui a
reçu un double avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est
adopté amendement 59 rectifié madame
Boyet alleors nous vous
écoutons
vous retrouvez l'exposé des
motifs défendu avis de la
commission même avis je mets au
voix avis favorable défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté amendement 57
rectifié fend
défendu défavorable avis du
gouvernement s'il vous plaît je mets au
voix qui est pour qui est
contre qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 56 rectifie
bis
retirer
alors après l'article 7 5 amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune l'amendement 153 rectifié de
Monsieur
Durin merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous
déclariez à l'Assemblée en septembre
2022 il y a plein de gens qui méritent
sans doute des régularisations et qui ne
les ont pas aujourd'hui et je vais vous
présenter là un cas très concret de
régularisation que nous serions bien
d'inspirer de concrétiser euh vous vous
souvenez que le groupe socialiste avait
porté ici dans cette hémicycle une
proposition de loi l travaclet pour
mémoire quand un certain nombre de
jeunes arrivent sur le sol français les
mineurs étrangers sont pris en charge
par l'État via les départements qui ont
pour mission de s'occuper de
l'enfanceans danger euh ils sont
hébergés ils sont encadrés par des
travailleurs sociaux ils sont formés
pour la plupart en apprentissage et
c'est un dispositif qui coûte cher 4 500
€ par mois par enfant comme le prévoit
la loi à leur 18 ans ils doivent quitter
le territoire national c'est un immense
gâie humain économique ces apprentis
travaillent surtout dans des secteurs
d'activité qui manquent de bras comme
l'hôtellerie restauration le BTP le
bâtiments et les travaux publics et les
métiers de bouche comme la boulangerie
ou comme cuisinier ils sont formés
l'État a dépensé de l'argent pour eux le
coup national est évalué à 2 milliards
pour les 40000 étrangers mineurs chaque
année et les artisans et j'espère qu'on
aura autant de d'empathie pour les
artisans qu'on en a eu à l'instant pour
les maires les artisans les chefs
d'entreprise ont besoin de ces salariés
compétents nous nous proposons de de
mettre fin à cette aberration alors à
l'époque quand j'avais défendu ce texte
au nom de mon groupe on nous avait
expliquer que les cas étaient réglés par
les préfets alors oui parfois ils sont
réglés par les préfets mais souvent il
nous a fait objection que il y a une
forme d'arbitraire qui qui règne et on a
beaucoup d'exemples de dossiers qui sont
écartés donc ce que nous souhaitons nous
c'est donner droit aux demandes qui sont
formulées dans nos permanences dans
toutes nos permanences à droite à gauche
par des patrons qui veulent garder leur
salariés et puis qu'on puisse mettre fin
à ce gâi à ce gâi humain ce gâi
économique et faire profiter à la France
et à son secteur économique des
richesses que ces enfants peuvent nous
apporter monsieur Durin amendement 308
rectifié monsieur
och merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui va dans dans le même sens
que celui que vient de présenter Jérôme
Durin puisqu'il a pour objet de proposer
la délivrance d'une carte pluriannuelle
de séjours mention vie privée et
familiale au mineurs étrangers isolés
confiés à laaz est devenu majeur cette
carte aurait une durée de validité de 4
ans le défenseur des droits dans son
rapport a reconnu l'admission au séjour
de plein droit des mineurs non
accompagnés leur majorité quel que soit
d'ailleurs en plus leur lien avec leur
famille dans le pays d'origine un grand
nombre de jeunes majeurs anciennement
mineurs isolés se retrouve à la rue sans
soutien familial ni ressources pour
Claire Eton la délivrance facilitée de
titre de séjour portant la mention vie
privé et familial tel que recommandé
permettrait aux mineurs non accompagnés
de terminer leur cursus de formation et
d'acquérir l'autonomie nécessaire à leur
future vie d'adulte afin de mieux
assurer la continuité des droits des
mineurs non accompagnés lors du passage
à la majorité et d'éviter les ruptures
et de mieux garantir l'accès à
l'autonomie le présent amendement
propose donc la délivrance d'un carart
de séjour pluriannuel d'une durée de 4
ans sans condition de la nature des
liens de l'étranger avec sa famille
rester dans son pays d'origine ni de l'
vie de la structure d'accueil qui
accompagne le mineur merci Monsieur
bénaroche amendement 41 rectifié par
Monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le monsieur le min dans le même
sens que que mes deux collègues notre
amendement propose de mettre fin au
caractère exceptionnel de la délivrance
d'un d'un titre de séjour aux jeunes qui
ont été suivis par la protection de
l'enfance et qui bénéficie d'un contrat
jeune majeur les mobilisations
citoyennes récentes comme celle autour
de la situation par exemple de Lailler
Faudé trauré boulanger à Besançon ont
montré le large soutien de la population
à la régularisation de ces jeunes ce
sont des jeunes qui ont été bénéficiés
d'un accompagnement par la puissance
publique ils ont bénéficié d'une
formation et certains malheureusement
sont contraints de quitter le territoire
il s'agit d'un d'un grand gâi et de
situation ubesque auquel il conviendrait
de mettre fin c'est le sens de de notre
amendement merci Monsieur bénaroche pour
le 307 rectifié toujours dans la même
vine les les mineurs non accompagnés
confiés à laazux ont deux possibilités
aujourd'hui de régularisation principale
à leur majorité soit la demande d' titre
de séjour vie privée et familiale pour
se confier à l'AZ avant 16 ans et
l'admission et la demande d'une
admission exceptionnelle au séjour
mention salariés ou travailleurs
temporair pour ceux confiés à Lazur
entre 16 et 18 ans dans les deux cas
certains critères sans lien avec leur
intégration en France sont attachés à la
délivrance du titre de séjour et de ce
fait trop souvent des jeunes pris en
charge depuis plusieurs années intégré
socialement et professionnellement se
voit donc délivrer une TF ces situations
mobilisent non seulement les
associations qui ont suivi ces jeunes au
sein de la protection de l'offense mais
également les enseignants et les
employeurs qui s investissent dans leur
formation outre le gachi que représente
une qtf après des années de prise en
charge les mobilisations citoyennes
autour de cas comme ceux de l'il Faudé
Traoré à Besançon ou d'Armando courourri
meilleur apprenti de France en 2015 ont
démontré le soutien à la régularisation
de ces jeunes travailleurs il
conviendrait donc de sécuriser leur
accès au séjours à leur majorité en
garantissant la délivrance d'un titre de
séjour salarié aux jeunes majeurs prix
en charge par la ze entre 16 et 18 ans
sur la base des seuls critères du suivi
d'une formation et de l'avis de la
structure l'accompagnant vers son
insertion dans la société française le
caractère exceptionnel de la délivrance
de ce titre doit être supprimé cet
amendement propose de supprimer ce
caractère exceptionnel euh et de de
telle façon à lui à ce que ce ce ce
jeune qui qui arrive à 18 ans puisse
intégrer et poursuivre le le le métier
ou la formation qu'il est en train de
suivre au moment de ses 18 ans il
propose également de supprimer le CR
visant les liens avec la famille restée
dans le pays d'origine pour l'octroit
des titres de séjour salariés
travailleurs temporaires et vie et vie
privée familial je précise que cet
amendement a été travaillé en
concertation avec France Terre d'Asile
avec la Fédération des acteurs et de la
solidarité et avec forum Réfugiés merci
Monsieur bénaroche l'amendement 360
rectifié
bis par Madame stage
brug madame merci Monsieur le président
donc le présent amendement modifie les
critères d'attribution d'un titre de
séjour pour les jeunes majeurs qui ont
été pris en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance avant l'âge de 16 ans il
s'inspire d'une disposition déjà
proposée dans plusieurs textes dont la
proposition loi pour reprendre le
contrôle de la politique d'immigration
d'asile et d'intégration les intéressés
ne devraient donc présenter aucun lien
avec leur pays d'origine pour se voir
délivrer automatiquement un titre de
séjour à leur accession à la majorité la
rédaction actuelle nous semble en effet
trop permissive et ambigu en ce qu'elle
prévoit uniquement une appréciation
subjective de la nature des liens avec
la famille rester dans le pays
d'origine merci Madame estage brigot
avis de la commission sur ces différents
amendements merci monsieur le Président
avis tout d'abord sur l'amendement qui a
été défendu par Monsieur Durin dont il a
effectivement expliqué qu'il l'avait
déjà présenté au Sénat et je lui ferai
la même réponse qui avait été faite à
l'époque pour ces ces jeunes majeurs qui
sont pris en charge par la ze après
l'âge de 16 ans il bénéficie c'est un
des cas dans lesquels on peut bénéficier
de l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
et on peut le comprendre vous avez cité
l'exemple d'un jeune boulanger qui
avaitmu la France entière je le crois
volontiers mais l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour permet de
régler 90 % des cas qui se présentent
les 10 % restants sont précisément les
10 % de cas dans lesquels le préfet
estime que la présence des mineurs
devenus majeurs ne se justifie pas sur
notre territoire
il me paraît nous avons longuement
échangé sur ce point que il faut
conserver la capacité des préfets à
donner un avis discrétionnairement sur
la situation de chaque majeur donc c'est
une un avis défavorable sur l'amendement
308 du groupe écologiste euh qui euh
souhaite tout simplement une carte de
séjour de 4 ans pour les MNA prise en
charge avant l'âge de 16 ans euh tout en
supprimant les conditions liées à la
nature des liens avec la famille resté
dans son pays et bien cela riendrait
admettre au séjour pour une longue durée
des jeunes qui peuvent tout à fait
rejoindre leur famille sans jamais
s'assurer d'ailleurs de leur capacité
d'assertion au sein euh de notre
territoire et de notre de notre pays
c'est donc vous l'aurez compris un avis
défavorable pour les amendements 41 307
des groupes communistes et écologistes
et bien euh qui souhaiterait que nous
ayons des des conditions identiques pour
les jeunes arrivés avant 16 ans et et et
ceux qui sont pris en charge après 16 an
il n'y a pas de motif objectif d'autant
plus que euh les capacités d'insertion
ne sont pas acceptés de la même manière
et je répète que aujourd'hui l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour règle 90 % des
cas il règle 100 % des cas à vrai dire
avec une marge de 10 % de de personnes
qui n'ont pas vocation à rester sur le
territoire c'est aussi c'est aussi
possible et enfin je mettrai en revanche
un avis favorable à l'amendement qui a
été présenté par Madame Jacqueline stage
brigot qui effectivement substitue un
critère un peu ambigu et sans doute un
peu trop vague un critère qui est plus
précis et qui paraît vraiment de nature
à apprécier les liens du mineur avec son
pays d'origine qu'il a après tout sans
doute vocation à retrouver voilà la vie
de la commission monsieur le Président
merci Madame la rapporteur maintenant
monsieur le ministre pour le
gouvernement défavorable à l'ensemble
des
amendement d'accord et monsieur groval a
demandé la parole je vous la donne oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je ne suis pas sûr qu'il a
fallu être maire pour pouvoir parler des
mariages en tout cas moi qui ai exercé
la fonction de président de département
pendant de nombreuses années je puis
vous dire que et confirmer que c'est un
véritable gâi et que les préfets madame
la rapporteur peuvent agir différemment
selon les territoires mais ils peuvent
agir d'ailleurs différemment dans un
même département moi qui ai eu à
connaître quatre ou cinq préfets il
n'avait pas la même façon les uns ou les
autres de tresser ces dossiers qui
d'ailleurs le plus souvent étaiit
accompagné et par l'ensemble de nos
travailleurs sociaux qui accompagnaient
ces jeunes et par l'ensemble de des
organismes de formation et par
l'ensemble des employeurs y compris la
chambre des métiers qui au travers de
ces formations soutenaient notre action
et nous devions développer une énergie
folle pour défendre les dossiers au cas
par cas alors que nous avions investi
parfois 3 ans 5 ans en terme de
formation en terme de denier public pour
accompagner ces jeunes comme d'ailleurs
la loi nous y contraint et parfois bien
seul parce que dans mon propre
département à une époque où mes voisins
avaient contesté mon cher Bruno avait
contesté la directive tobira et où nous
nous retrouvions bien seul pour assumer
non seulement les mineurs non
accompagnés de notre département mais de
ceux aussi qui venaient des départements
voisins et don nous avions la charge
donc je vous appelle au bon sens et non
pas au dogmatisme pour dire que la
réalité sur le terrain l'expérience que
nous avons montre à l'évidence que ces
jeunes gens apportent beaucoup à notre
pays et qu'il mérite de s'y intégrer
pleinement après que nous ayons fait des
efforts considérables considérable
certains d'ailleurs sur les bancs de cet
hémicycle pensent que c'est beaucoup
trop mais des efforts financiers
considérables pour accompagner ces
jeunes
merci merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Durin
oui je je je vaux reprendre un papier
que j'ai lu cette semaine euh le
ministre rencontre marieeline Poulin qui
vient d'être
nommé préfette à l'égalité des chances
il lui demande qu'est-ce qui va pas sur
les travailleurs sans papier elle répond
l'appréciation discrétionnaire des
préfets voilà tout est dit cet
arbitraire qui vient d'être illustré de
manière très claire par mon collègue
devrait pas laisser insensible la droite
je vous ai vu tout à l'heure et c'est
bien légitime et c'est bien normal très
embêté par la situation qui est faite au
maire mais entend tous ces patrons alors
on nous dit on règle 90 % des cas bah si
on est qu'à 10 % prêt allons jusqu'au
bout et puis est-ce qu'on les règle
vraiment non les règles pas parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous avez un
patron qui ramote le banc et
l'arrièrebanc qui mobilise autour de lui
et c'est juste autour de la situation
d'un mineur tout le monde mon au créneau
y compris nous les parlementaires y
compris vous les parlementaires qui
écriz des courrier au préfet pour leur
dire quand même Monsieur le Préfet c'est
un peu insupportable cette situation
c'est n'importe quoi c'est du gâachi
donc ça ne peut pas aller on vous dit
régularisation vous parlez d'appel d'air
B j'aurais bien aimé qu'on qu'on
qualifie cet appel d'air on vous dit
régularisation vous dites circulaire
mais la circulaire c'est pas une bonne
solution ça n'est pas une bonne solution
ça organise la concurrence entre les
territoires et ça maintient des gens
dans des situations de nomadance
juridique parce que il y a il y a le cas
de ces gamins qui sont passés par laazu
mais combien de personnes on a on a à
traiter des situations dans nos
départements moi j'ai trois dossiers là
g il y en a un qui travaille dans un
garage il a pas de situation la patronne
elle dit qu'est-ce qui va se passer moi
j'ai besoin de lui il y en a un autre il
est dans une entreprise la gérante dit
la même chose et qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
ces gens c'est notre intérêt il y a une
question d'humanité il y a une question
d'économie parlez-en autour de vous donc
vous avez su entendre les maires mais
entendez aussi les patrons les artisans
je vous assure ça va pas générer d'appel
d'air ça va faire du bien à notre
économie ça va faire baisser la pression
et ça rendra service à tout le monde
merci Monsieur Durin la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur
jade merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues on
a évoqué le cas de laifod des Traoré qui
avait fait parler effectivement y
compris dans la presse nationale de ces
mineurs sans papierers prise en charge
par la ze moi je voudrais évoquer un
autre cas celui de Ronaldo
Mumba même situation il était
en apprentissage dans un épad à
oriaac ceux qui ont porté à votre
connaissance monsieur le ministre son
cas parce qu'il avait reçu une TF c'est
Vincent desqueur député LR et le
sénateur
satarel donc voilà dans la situation
dans laquelle on est que vient de
rappeler notre collègue c'està dire
qu'en fait ici il y a beaucoup de
postures mais dans la réalité y compris
parce que évidemment vous êtes aussi
humain que nous le sommes et ben ces
situations là vous les trouvez tout
aussi insupportables donc sortons des
situations insupportable et adoptons les
les amendements tels qu'ils ont été
proposés merci Monsieur jade la parole
est à Monsieur
ravier merci monsieur le Président de me
permettre d' d'essayer en tout cas d'
avec cette fable des mineurs non
accompagnés qui on le sait et cela a été
dit dans cette émissique il y a déjà
plusieurs mois voir plusieurs années
donc le un
chiffre qui a dû évoluer depuis la
réalité c'est que 60 % au moins de ces
mineurs non accompagnés sont des majeurs
très accompagnés voire accompagnés en
tout la conséquence de tout ça c'est que
le fait de prendre pour argent comptant
si j'ose dire les déclarations de ces
jeunes gens c'est que cela constitue
désormais une filière d'immigration
clandestine en 2015 le département des
bougirones enregistré 200 prétendus
mineurs non accompagnés aujourd'hui
c'est 2000 pour 80 millions d'euros de
coût du pour le contribuable alors je
cherche où est la richesse euh affirmé
par la gauche une richesse économique
c'est un coûp c'est 2 milliards 2
milliards d'euros 2 milliards d'euros
par an puisqu'il y a une 40000 prétendus
mineurs très accompagnés à 50000 € par
mineur si on se rapporte à ce à ce
chiffre de 70 % qui serait en réalité
majeur l'on pourrait économiser 1
milillard 200 million d'euros et vous
osez nous dire que cela nous rapporte
donc moi je crois et je suis même
persuadé qu'il va bien falloir prendre
une mesure la mesure nécessaire pour
combattre cette filière d'immigration
clandestine en obligeant ces jeunes à
accepter le test haseux qui nous qui
n'est ni douloureux ni intrusif et qui
nous permettra de savoir si oui ou non
ils sont majeurs s ils sont ou s'ils
sont mineurs et s'ils sont mineurs et
bien ils seront traités sur un temps
plus ou moins court je l'espère par les
départements et s'ils sont majeurs et
bien ils doivent être expulsé c'est ça
la réalité de ces prétendus mineurs non
accompagnés merci Madame Ross
les mas C objet de fantasme quand on
parle de la protection de l'enfance
enfin de laaz des difficultés de laaz
qui sont réelles parce que les familles
française dysfonctionne de plus en plus
parce que la pauvreté affecte de plus en
plus de familles parce que les violences
existent et que les départements ont des
difficultés ah c'est de la photoema on
parle de d'immigration ah tout de suite
on on prend les MNA euh je pense que
d'abord je ne sais pas d'où madame
Jourda sort son chiffre de de 90 % sur
la base de quel euh volume 90 % de quoi
des des des des demandes 90 % c'est un
chiffre totalement improbable et auquel
euh je sais pas d'où il sort et et
personne ne arrive à comprendre
d'ailleurs d'où il sort des demandes
vous pouz dire que 4 que 90 % des
demandes de régularisation qui sont
faites pour les mineurs accompagné
aboutissent plus toutes celles qui ne
sont pas faites d'ailleurs parce que
tout le monde hésite à aller devant les
service de préfecture je pense que
l'amendement de Jérôme Durin est un
amendement raisonnable ça fait des
années que cette discussion dure je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce qui a été dit sur
l'investissement que c'est P de
collectivité si vous allez rencontrer
les services de protection de l'enfance
les les personnels des mex vous verrez
que la quasi totalité des MNA pris en
charge sont des jeunes gens sérieux le
problème c'est les MNA non prise en
charge en réalité c'est ceux qu'on
narrive pas à attraper c'est ceux
qu'adoreraiit monsieur ravier ceux qui
ne coûte rien au pays parce que de toute
façon on n'arrive pas les tenir dans les
structures on n'arrive pas à les tenir
dans les dans les dispositifs on ne les
tient dans rien oui nous avons un
problème avec ces gamins là avec ces
très jeunes enfants d'ailleurs ils ont
c'est des mineurs de 13 14 ans le plus
souvent donc je souhaiterais qu'un
jour je souhaiterais qu'un jour si on
les voit alors je vais vous dire où on
les voit arriver on les voit arriver
dans les services d'urgence
psychiatrique soit parce que les soit
parce qu'ils sont prostitués soit parce
qu'ils sont en de suicide et Monsieur
ravier quand il y a des MNA prostitués
ils sont certes
étranger vous allez laisserame AZ la
parole vous me laissez 15 secondes de
plus monsieur le Président merci vous
avez quelques secondes de plus et je
voulais dire à Monsieur ravier qui est
en train de s'exciter sur les très
jeunes mineurs non accompagnés qui
effectivement sont sont des victimes des
réseaux de traite et de prostitution que
s'ils sont tous étrangers en en revanche
tous les clients de ces mineurs
prostitués sont français donc ce serait
bien qu'on regarde un peu on déplace un
petit peu l'angle de vue de temps en
temps tout ça pour dire que tout ça pour
dire que les chiffres ne sont pas bons
cette affaire dure depuis des années et
ce n'est pas possible de laisser ça au
préfet je proposerai donc peut-être pour
rassurer monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur un petit sous-amendement il
faut laisser au au préfet la possibilité
de refuser parce que il ce mineur serait
fiché s parce qu'il serait connu
est- d'accur
ministreinteurasion nous aurons
l'occasion de de parler de Monsieur gar
je crois qu'il voulez prendre la parole
ah Monsieur le Ministre attendez
monsieur gar monsieur le ministre il la
priorité allez-y monsieur le ministre ah
bon vous allez-y monsieur
Gard je voudrais pas griller la priorité
au
ministre merci merci monsieur le
Président non moi je voulais juste aller
dans dans le sens en fait de de ce qui a
été dit mais plus sur sur le concret de
ce qu'on vit tous les jours vous dites
que 90 % des dossiers sont traités qu'il
n'y a pas de souci moi ce que je peux
voir tous les jours dans nos permanences
mes collègues parlementaires et et
beaucoup d'ailleurs parlementaire de
droite puisqu'on est même amené souvent
à signer des courriers avec nos
collègues pour justement demander et
faire en sorte que ces jeunes puissent à
la fois suivre leur cursus que suivre
leur apprentissage et ensuite trouver la
place dans l'entreprise dans lequelle
ils ont ils ont ils ont fait cet cet
apprentissage donc ça c'est une vraie
réalité l'autre réalité c'est que
suivant les préfet qui passe on a des
résultats complètement différents donc
on est complètement dans le suivant
suivant la personne suivant la
mobilisation aussi qui peut y avoir
suivant l'influence de
l'entrepreneur et bien on va avoir une
régularisation n on aura pas donc on
peut pas rester dans ce système- là il
me semble que l'amendement 307 de mon
collègue gub benaroche justement permet
dans encadrer sans aller trop loin
puisque vous avez toujours peur de ce
fameux appel d'air et de ce fantasme de
l'appel d'air mais en tout cas permet
d'encadrer mais il y a une vraie
nécessité pour sortir de cette de cette
absurdité quand même on prend en charge
des mineurs et c'est évidemment qu'
qu'il faut le qu'il faut le faire c'est
même indispensable c'est même nos devoir
d'humanité et de fraternité euh on met
de l'argent public pour les former euh
pour les accompagner pour leur permettre
un cursus d'apprentissage et puis arrive
à 18 ans on va dire stop au qtf c'est
terminé quel quel intérêt quel sens il y
a là-dedans alors là pour le coup je
fais appel à votre pragmatisme on a mis
de l'argent on a permis à ces jeunes de
pouvoir se former souvent de manière
excellente he que ça soit dans les
métiers de la cuisine que ça soit dans
les métiers de la plomberie que ça soit
dans tous les métiers et avec des
entrepreneurs derrière qui ne demandent
qu'une chose continuer à pouvoir
travailler avec ces jeunes parce qu'il y
a une vraie question d'humanité aussi
merci merci merci chers collègu monsieur
le
ministre bien monsieur le Président j'ai
pas pas prévu de prendre la parole
puisque je crois qu'on a 286 amendements
que la volonté du Sénat était de
conclure vendredi mais on peut
effectivement continuer à discuter de
sujets qui ne sont pas en lien direct
avec le texte puisque vous parliez de
cavalier législatif madame de La
contrise tout à l'heure il est évident
que c'est le cas également ici il n y'y
avait pas de disposition mineur dans le
texte que j'ai déposé au sur le bureau
de la la commission des lois du du Sénat
pour des raisons assez diverses d'une
part c'est qu'il faut sans doute un
texte dédié pour les mineurs dit isolés
parce que c'est le lien direct en effet
avec l'aide sociale à l'enfance mais
aussi parce que vous le savez tant
qu'ils sont mineurs ce n'est pas les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
les gèrent mais que c'est l'autorité
judiciaire et qu'à ce titre là aussi
vous débattez deux sujets qui seront
sans doute censurés par le Conseil
constitutionnel non obstant le fait que
nous aurons un débat sans doute déjà
assez vif avec Monsieur ravier que que
que que je constate mais vous imaginez
ce qui va se passer donc donc à
l'Assemblée nationale mais je crois que
c'est aussi fait exprès peut-être pas
pour résoudre vraiment le problème mais
pour embêter la discussion autour du
gouvernement ce ceci étant dit je suis
donc pas favorable à un sousamendement
la difficulté des mineurs dit isolés
c'est bien une question qui consiste à
voir qu'il y en a de plus en plus malgré
tout sur le sol européen et
singulièrement en France qu'il est
difficile de distinguer mineurs et
majeur à quelques exceptions près et
qu'enfin il y a déjà une instruction de
ma part de septembre 200 20 qui prévoit
de regarder la régularité du séjour bien
en amont du passage à 18 ans et en effet
madame la rapporteur a raison peut-être
même à un détail supplémentaire 93 % des
titres demandés sont validés et les 7 %
qui restent c'est pour motif de fraude
documentaire et lorsque vous intervenez
je dis à Monsieur jade mais à d'autres
auprès du ministre de l'Intérieur
puisque j'ai à connaître ses
interventions si les préfets l'ont
refusé non pas parce que ils ont changé
selon une orientation politique cette
attaque contre les préfets de la
République me paraît un peu euh déplacés
sur question pas la p détendre je
pourrais vous dire que les présidents de
département monsieur président
département ont des visions extrêmement
différents de l'enfance les uns des
autres extrêmement différents et tous
les présidents du département mettent
pas en place ce que le gouvernement a
demandé qui notamment le fichier AEM
peut-être que ça explique une partie des
difficultés que vous évoquez mais
évidemment j'imagine que votre
opposition départementale a dû vous le
dire aussi ce qui était évident c'est
que ces 7 % sont des fraudes
documentaires et donc oui les préfet ne
régularise pas des gens qui ont triché
pour donner pour donner une
justification de de civil il se peut que
malgré cela malgré cela on puisse ici ou
là régulariser quand même pour plein de
raisons qui effectivement relève de la
dignité humaine et pas du tout à la
demande des patrons les patrons ils ont
bonau monsieur Durin lorsque vous les
défendez ici évidemment C j'imagine une
un argument pour le que vous pensez
efficace pour pour la droite de cet
hémicycle mais les 93 % à qui nous
donnons des titres de séjour les 7 % qui
reste c'est parce qu'il y a une fraude
documentaire donc on pourrait légaliser
la fraude documentaire mais dans ces
cas-là on fait autre chose que me semble
semble-il ce qui est bon pour pour pour
la République donc il faut que nous
ayons un texte séparé qui parle des
mineurs incontestablement parce que le
sujet n'est pas tant leur régularité au
en tant que titre de séjour et de ce
point de vue ce que propose madame
brigot peut peut s'entendre mais je
pense que c'est pas dans ce texte qu'on
doit le mettre moi je le dis très
franchement à la sénatrice que là encore
c'est une question d'autorité judiciaire
puisque vous savez bien que ce sont les
magistrats qui décident de renvoyer ou
pas dans leur pays des mineurs et non
pas les préfets voilà et troisièmement
la question n'est pas de savoir si les
mineurs isolés sont ou pas accompagnés
par les entreprises bien sûr que la
plupart du temps ils le sont dans un
souci d'apprentissage c'est que les
départements manifestement ne peuvent
pas faire face à la fois à une aide
sociale à l'enfance où il y a des
personnes françaises ou étrangères
d'ailleurs qui ont besoin de protection
et puis évidemment des mineurs isolés
qui ne sont pas tous mineurs et donc
prennent la place à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance de gens qui étranger ou pas
mériteraiit le protection de de la
République dans mon département où
j'étais conseil départemental c'était
c'est évidemment le cas il y a des
enfants qu'on narrive pas à placer qui
soi étranger ou français évidemment la
protection deenfance n'emporte qu'on
narrive pas à placer dans des structure
d'accueil parce que des mineurs qui ne
sont pas mineurs sont mis en place dans
ces structures d'accueil c'est un fait
et personne ne peut le personne ne peut
le contester donc soit c'est une réponse
de moyens soit c'est une réponse de
séjour soit c'est une réponse de
minorité en tout cas c'est pas une
réponse d'un texte immigration qui
modifie de ces AAT donc c'est un avis
défavorable à tout y compris au CE
amendement qui viendrai être
écrit merci monsieur le ministre je vais
donc mettre au voix successivement ces
amendements le premier le 153 rectifié
qui avait reçu un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
308 rectifié même
vote il n'est pas adopté le 41 rectifié
ainsi que le 307 rectifié qui sont
absolument identiques avec un double
avis défavorable de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
360 rectifié bis qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté pardon
après l'article 7 un amendement 238
madame de La Gonterie
ou madame
naren qui c'est qui le
défend monsieur Durin
oui monsieur le Président les auteurs de
cet amendement sonit consacré dans les
dans la loi les dispositions de la
circulaire Vals relative à la délivrance
de la carte de séjour vie privée et
familiale pour les étrangers sans titre
par an d'enfants scolarisés reprenant
les critères fixés dans cette circulaire
un étranger sans titre qui justifie
d'une résidence ininterrompue d'au moins
5 années en France et qui est parent
d'un enfant mineur scolarisé depuis au
moins 3 ans se verra délivrer de plein
droit une carte de séjour temporaire
d'une durée d'un an conformément au
droit en vigueur ces dispositions ne
sont pas applicables si la présence de
l'étranger en France constitue une
menace pour l'ordre public ou s'il vite
en France en état de
polygamie merci avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
le droit à la régularisation n'existe
pas je le rappelle il n'est pas la norme
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour et
même totalement l'inverse donc il
convien de laisser le droit en l'état de
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui avis
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
même avis
défavorable monsieur le Président
bas je vous remercie de me donner la
parole je voudrais juste dire que le
gouvernement fait des émules jusqu'au
sein du groupe
socialiste car l'expression se verra
délivré de plein droit c'est exactement
celle de feu l'article 3 du projet
gouvernemental et voilà parquoi on a
commencé dans ce débat et parquoi on le
prolonge se verra de plein droit on veut
créer un droit à la régularisation pour
tous et c'est ce à quoi nous nous
opposons merci merci Monsieur bas je
vais mettre au voix l'amendement 238 qui
a reçu un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre et qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté après l'article 7
l'amendement 4 408 rectifié madame
Vogel merci Monsieur le présid président
alors c'est un amendement pour être
gentil avec les très très gentils donc
je pense que ça va vous plaire c'est
assez simple vous savez qu'en 2001 on a
mis en place au niveau européen cette
directive sur la protection temporaire
qui a été utilisé pour la première fois
en 2022 au moment de la guerre en
Ukraine et de l'afflux de réfugiés
ukrainiennes et ukrainien en France et
cette directive elle prévoit que l'on
puisse autoriser à les personnes
qui bénéficient de cette protection
temporaire il se trouve que la France
l'a transposé d'une manière peu sûr nous
avons certes donné des autorisations de
travail aux réfugiés ukrainiennes et
ukrainiens mais nous n'avons pas dans
notre dans notre loi le fait que c'est
automatique et donc cet amendement il
est assez simple il permet simplement
d'assurer que ce ne soit pas le cas
échéant comme c'est actuellement écrit
dans la loi mais que automatiquement les
personnes qui bénéficie d'une protection
temporaire donc on parle bien ici de
réfugiés dans le cas d'un conflit auquel
on a décidé d'attribuer une protection
temporaire on prévoit simplement de
rendre automatique le fait que ces
personnes puissent avoir une
autorisation de travail ce que nous
avons fait dans le cas de la crise
ukrainienne mais que notre droit ne ne
prévoit pas de manière systématique je
vous
remercie merci euh avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
je crois que tout le monde partage au
moins sur l'idée euh ce qui vient d'être
indiqué par notre collègue madame Vogel
mais il me semble que c'est euh
satisfait puisque même s'il s'agit de la
partie réglementaire du czda le czda
prévoit bien que l'autorisation
provisoire de séjour ouvre ouvre ce
droit à l'activité professionnelle et
donc ça serait une demande de retrait ou
un avis défavorable sauf euh si euh
monsieur le ministre avait une analyse
différente de cette de cette
disposition avis du gouvernement c'est
déjà en effet le cas du droit actuel
retrait donc je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 408 rectifié avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et une
demande de retrait de la part du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre
qui
s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro
rectifié monsieur
bénaroche dans la même logique précédent
amendement déposé par Monique dearco
applicable au fonctionnaire le présent
amendement vise à étendre le droit au
conget pour engagement associatif prévu
pour les salariés à l'article L euh 31
42 54-1 du Code du travail pour les
salariés exerçant une activité bénévole
auprès d'une association régie par la
loi du 1er juillet 1901 sétant donné
pour mission d'accompagner juridiquement
ou socialement ou de former
linguistiquement les personnes étrangère
sur le sol français concernant les
fonctionnaires engagés dans ces
activités associatives l'amendement a
été déclaré irrecevable pas celui-ci
leur activité bénévole comme celle
d'étudiant et de retraité permet
aujourd'hui de palier les lacunes de la
politique française d'accueil il importe
de reconnaître l'importance de leur
engagement au bénéfice de toute la
société française c'est pourquoi cet
amendement vise à créer un régime de
congé de droit pour les bénévoles
s'engageant de la sorte le droit en
vigueur prévoit déjà un droit au congé
de 3 jours pour les dirigeants de
structures associatives nous proposons
donc d'étendre ce droit aux salariés des
associations dédié à l'accueil des
personnes étrangères cette
différenciation est justifiée par le
fait que de telles associations
remplissent en réalité une mission de
service public qui devrait être prise en
charge par
l'État merci Monsieur bénaroche avis de
Madame la rapporteur de la commission
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur bénaroche
j'entends bien ce que ce que vous
indiquer qui est pétrie de bons
sentiments et vous indiquez
qu'effectivement cette mission de
service public devait être sans doute
prise en charge par l'État mais en
l'occurrence c'est aux employeurs que le
fait de prendre en charge par ces 6
jours ouvrables tout de même de congés
que vous proposez de donner ça ne
m'aapît pas correspondre tout à fait
même à l'objet de ce que vous défendez
avis défavorable donc avis défavorable
monsieur le
ministre même
avis je mets au voix l'amendement 577
rectifié avec un double avis défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté
je article
8 prier amendement
565 il a deux amendements
identiques qui c'est qui le défend je
vous en
prie alors monsieur le présidentur
ministre amendement a pour objet de
rétablir dans une rédaction différente
les dispositions relatives à la création
d'une amende administrative sanctionnant
les employeurs d'étrangers ne détenant
pas un titre les autorisant à
travailler concrètement nous proposons
de remplacer la contribution spéciale
prévue par le Code du travail par une
amendement administratif une amende
administrative dont le montant pourrait
être modulé dans un souci de
simplification nous proposons également
la suppression de la la contribution
forfataire de l'employeur et a occupé un
étranger en situation irrégulière par
ailleurs nous proposons qu'en cas de
cumule de l'amende administrative et de
l'amende pénale le montant global des
amendes prononcées ne dépasse pas le
maximum légal le plus élevé des
sanctions
encourues l'adoption de notre amendement
est d'autant plus nécessaire que
l'infraction d'emploi d'un intranger non
autorisé à travailler constitue la
deuxème infraction de travail illégal le
plus élevé par l'ensemble des corps de
contrôle de contrôle la création d'une
amend
administrative permettrait de
sanctionner plus rapidement les auteurs
de cette infraction voilà merci monsieur
le sénateur et 1000 excuses pour votre
nom que je n'ai pas correctement
prononcé amendement 5 8 présenté par
monsieur le ministre au nom du
[Musique]
gouvernement bien merci monsieur le
Président là aussi c'est un amendement
qui vise à rétablir l'article proposé
par le par le gouvernement qui a été
supprimé par la commission des lois
alors soit la commission des lois l'a
supprimé pour des raisons juridiques et
techniques il est vrai que la rédaction
du gouvernement prévoyait notamment le
le fait qu'une sanction est été
cumulative avec une autre sanction et
qu'ainsi selon le droit peut pas
condamner de fois une personne pour le
même type de sanction et vous
remarquerez madame la rapporteur que
l'amendement gouvernemental est
désormais différent il prend bien en
compte qu'il n'y a pas double sanction
pour la même faute celle d'employer des
personnes irrégulières soit et donc je
pense que nous pouvons nous entendre
soit le le le la commission des lois a
souhaité ne pas retenir cet article de
façon plus plus idéologique c'est-à-dire
de ne pas sanctionner les employeurs
quel qu'il soit parce que ils embauchent
des personnes sans papier je n'imagine
pas à ce instant que ce soit votre
philosophie aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui un étranger irrégulier
qui est employé par non seulement une
entreprise mais aussi un particulier
c'est tout à fait le cas euh il a des
possibilités de sanction de faible
amende mais surtout des incriminations
pénales qui sont en fait très peu
respecté malgré les procédures très
nombreuses que lanceinpection du travail
et que lance le ministère de l'intérieur
par l'intermédiaire des des préfets
moins de 500 condamnations
alors même que les fraudes aux
cotisations sociales du fait du travail
irrégulier représentent jusqu'à 6,6
milliards d'euros pour notamment pour la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance chômage
évidemment C des gains importants qui
sont qui sont perdus et pourtant
pourtant il y a un travail très
important fait en fait en Codaf avec les
préfets l'ensemble des services de
l'État pour traquer ces entreprises dont
une partie en effet sont dirigé par des
individus qui sont eux-mêmes étrangers à
peu près la moitié l'autre moitié
évidemment par des individus ou des
structures qui sont parfaitement
françaises je voudrais d'ailleurs dire
qu'à ce titre l'Office centrale de lutte
contre le travail illégal que nous avons
lancé qu'on appelle
l'octi montre en effet le travail
illégal immigration irrégulière qui sont
souvent extrêmement connexe et que les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
lorsqu'ils travaillent sont fréquemment
victimes de travail dissimulé d'emploi
d'étrangers sans titre voire de
situation d'exploitation par le travail
plus grave c'est vrai d'entreprise c'est
vrai de particulier c'est vrai aussi
d'association je prends l'exemple
l'association vie de Paris créée en 2011
par exemple qui compte plus de 10000
adhérents dont l'objet est normalement
de soutenir les personnes en situation
irrégulière qui est mis en cause avec
une enquête ouverte pour travail
dissimulé pour emploi de d'étrangers
sans tit et traite d'êtres humains cont
pour des faits allégant 44 victimes
étranges situations irrégulières qui ont
été identifiées c'est
évidemment ce genre de de choses que
nous devons regarder l'affaire a été
jugée par le tribunal correctionnel de
Paris mais mais après énormément de
travail que nous avons pu faire au sein
du service du ministère de l'Intérieur
il nous semble donc que si la sanction
pénale est poss possible la sanction
administrative l'appréciation du préfet
l'appréciation du préfet puisse être
évidemment beaucoup plus efficace
complémentaire et donc nous proposons
non seulement de doubler les amendes
pénales puisqu'elles sont quand même
très basses aujourd'hui dans le code et
pas très dissuasif par rapport au
travail irrégulier et ce qu'il rapporte
mais également des sanctions
administratives plus forte qui nous
permet de vraiment dire à quelqu'un que
s'il embauche un étranger irrégulier de
façon évidente alors il ne peut pas
attendre autre chose que la force de
l'État pour couper la filière
d'immigration irrégulière voilà en
quelques mots ce qu'est l'article 8
c'est donc le complément dans
l'écosystème d'immigration irrégulière
que nous essayons de casser on l'a vu
avec les auto-entrepreneurs on l'a vu
évidemment avec l'employeur l'employé on
le verra peut-être aussi dans les heures
qui viennent sur les marchands de
sommeil il y a un écosystème de travail
irrégulier dont l'entreprise est parfois
ou parfois le particulier le responsable
il ne s'agit pas là de sanctionner des
personnes qui tomberaient dans
l'irrégularité du fait de l'action de la
préfecture on l'a dit répondre à
d'autres situations il s'agit là de
personnes dont on sait qu' utilisent
siement une manœuvre de sans papier et
qui en plus le les conduit de manière
dégradante comme on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure il me semble de bonne à loi de
rétablir pour la dignité des personnes
et pour la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière l'amendement 565 ou 588
porté par le
gouvernement merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons examiner maintenant un
sous-amendement à l'amendement 588 du
gouvernement qui est présenté par
Monsieur brossa ou madame cuckerman
monsieur
brossa merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'article 8 du
projet de loi prévoyait une nouvelle
sanction administrative venant s'ajouter
aux sanctions administratives ou pénales
existantes en cas d'infraction à
l'interdit interdiction d'employer un
étranger non autorisé à travailler il
s'agissait plus exactement d'une 3oisème
amende administrative pécunière dont le
montant serait fixé par l'autorité
administrative mais dans la limite d'un
plafond de 4000 € doublé en cas de
récidive l'amendement présenté par par
le gouvernement fusionne quant à lui les
deux amendes administratives existantes
la contribution spéciale et la
contribution forfaitaire en une amende
administrative unique dont le champ
d'application serait élargi notamment en
cas de de recours siamment opéré par
l'employeur d'un étranger non autorisé à
travailler de même le fait déclencheur
de la procédure sera élargi au rapport
établis par les agents de contrôle et
non plus seulement les procès verbaux et
la possibilité de modulation du montant
de l'amand aux circonstances sera
amélioré aussi parce que le montant de
l'amende pénale sera rhaussé nous
considérons que cet amendement va dans
le bon sens et nous proposons par cet
amendement de reéhausser encore le
montant de cette nouvelle demande
administr tive et de rendre cette
augmentation systématique en cas de
réitération c'est le sens de ce que nous
proposons merci monsieur le sénateur
avis de la commission sur le
sous-amendement madame la rapporteur
sous-amendement
merci le le sur le le sous-amendement l'
viis est défavorable monsieur le
Président
défavorable et sur l'amendement
excusez-moi monsieur le président je
suis troublé eu l'avis défavorable je
vous ai expliquer pourquoi je crois que
nous n'avons pas
véritablement de difficultés de fond et
de désaccord de fond bien évidemment
mais on a déjà l'occasion de le dire
depuis le le début de ce débat tout le
monde ici je crois est d'accord pour
dire que un employeur qui siamment
emploie quelqu'un qui est en situation
irrégulière et parfois évidemment dans
des conditions qui sont indigne doit
être sanctionné là-dessus il n'y a pas
de difficulté sur l'accord que nous
pouvons tous trouver bien évidemment des
sanctions doivent être prononcées ces
sanctions elles existent elles sont déjà
relativement nombreuses nous avons des
des des sanctions pénales je je ne veux
pas me tromper alors je me réfère au
texte ces sanctions pénales prévoient
des peines pour les personnes physiques
qui vont de 5 à 10 ans de prison elles
ne sont pas dérisoires elle prévoi des
peines que vous trouvez un peu faibles
des peines d'Amand monsieur le ministre
mais qui vont quand même de 15000 à
100000 € par personne par étranger
illégalement employé ça ne me paraît pas
non plus dérisoire il y a aussi des
sanctions administratives alors avant
même ces sanctions administratives il y
a des sanctions pénal mais ce sont les
mêmes qui sont la fermeture de
l'établissement qui peut-être définitive
en tant que sanction pénale pour une
personne physique il y a l'exclusion de
participer à des marchés publics ça sont
des sanctions pénales nous avons en
miroir les mêmes sanctions
administratives mais temporaires
fermeture administrative de
l'établissement interdiction de
participer aussi à des des marchés
publics et puis deux contributions
administratives contribution spéciale
qui va de 1000 à
55000 € par salarié illégalement employé
et contribution forfaitaire qui a pour
but en fait de de permettre de
racheminer l'étranger dans son pays
d'origine et ses fonctions du pays
d'origine de cet étranger voilà quelles
sont les sanctions qui existent elles ne
sont tout de même pas minces nous avions
refusé effectivement un premier
amendement vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur
le Ministre c'était pour des raisons
juridiques de rédaction bon parce que
nous estimions qu' qu'il qu'il fixait
une amende qui existait déjà bon dontact
vous avez compris que ça n'était pas un
des acccord de fond ce qui nous dérange
dans cet amendement ce n'est pas
l'élargissement ce qui nous dérange
c'est que la contribution spéciale est
supprimée au profit d'une autre amende
administrative et cette contribution
spéciale sert à financer l'OFI à hauteur
pour la dernière R si je puis dire de
cette amende de 31 millions d'euros
l'OFI doit tout de même être préservé le
budget de l'OFI doit être préservé et
c'est en réalité cette difficulté qui
nous fait repousser cet amendement car
nous ne finançons plus correctement
l'OFI si nous nous privons de cette
contribution spécial voilà quelle est la
raison de la vie défvorables qui n'est
pas de fond mais qui tient véritablement
à cette difficulté merci Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre l'avis
votre avis l'avis du Gouvernement sur le
sous-amendement oui alors je merci
monsieur le Président un avis
défavorable à Monsieur brossa mais c'est
vraiment pas idéologique ce n'est pas
constitutionnel à notre avis puisque
nous doublons déjà les amendes et vous
voyez déjà déjà la résistance de la
rapporteur si en plus on double le
doublement je crois que ce ne sera pas
proportionnel et donc ce sera censuré et
donc vous et moi on sera sans doute déçu
de pas punir ces filières d'immigration
irrégulière qui exploitent les personnes
donc voilà c'est vraiment sur le fond
parfaitement d'accord je pense que ce
serait déjà pas mal qu'on avance àessus
bon madame la
rapporteur je crois d'ailleurs monsieur
le Président je l'ai pas entendu dire
que le groupe rdpays si je peux me
permettre à demander un SCR public sur
cet amendement de rétablissement là là
je crois que il faut qu'on qu'on qu'on
s'entende si vous pensez que il faut ici
ou là modifier des choses que navez-vous
sousamendé et en commission et en séance
par ailleurs le sujet sur le fice c'est
justement le fait que il y avait des
difficultés juridiques puisque la
taxation qui permettait de faire cette
taxe à 31 million d'euros qui n'est pas
versé à l' fi qui est versé au budget de
l'État donc quoi qu'il arrive l' fi aura
son versement c'est c'est c'est un
pisallé c'est évidemment une taxe qui va
dans le budget de l'État et qu'on
renverse à le fi donc évidemment je bien
sûr je garantis que le fi va continuer à
fonctionner puisqu'on lui augmente ses
moyens très très considérablement vous
n'avez pas sousamandé la vérité c'est
que justement nous rentrons parfaitement
dans la logique me semble- de la
majorité sénatoriale nous donnons au
préfet
l'appréciation de prendre des sanctions
contre des entreprises qui manifestement
embauchent des personnes irrégulières ça
va de per très bien avec les articles
précédents et je veux bien qu'on se
retourne en disant le code pénal est
très dur il y a eu moins de 500
procédures et je n'ai pas eu je n'ai pas
obtenu de la part de la Chancellerie
c'estd je le regrette pour pouvoir dire
présentation les vraies condamnations
bon elles sont pas très élevées pour les
quelques cas que j'ai eu à connaître
dans mon département donc la question
qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'on veut
sanctionner les patrons voillou qui
siamment siamment voilà utiliseent une
manœuvre irrégulière et et et donc
est-ce qu'on veut donner au préfet les
moyens d'aller vite pour les sanctionner
en augmentant leurs sanctions
administratives ce qui ne retirent pas
le code pénal je pense que c'est c'est
frappé du coin du bon sens pour lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière si cet
amendement est une nouvelle fois mal
rédigé sousamendons-le ce n'est pas une
question dessous puisqueencore une fois
comme je vous l'ai dit l'OFI a sa
garantie vous devriez être plutôt
content qu'on retire une taxe puisque
c'est moins de charge pour les
entreprises donc je comprends pas très
très bien votre raisonnement je pense
que là si on veut être cohérent qu les f
d'immigration irrégulière et même si
j'imagine que ça gêne un peu quelques
fédérations d'employeur c'est peut-être
possible c'est peut-être la raison
exprès d'une résistance parce que voilà
je pense qu'on ferait mieux d'adopter
cet amendement c'est un très bon signal
contre l'immigration irrégulière et on
le corrigera à l'Assemblée nationale si
vraiment on trouve un loup voilà sinon
je trouve effectivement que c'est pas
très cohérent dans la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois François Noël buffet
allez-y président euh la discussion
n'est pas éclaire sur le fond il reste
une problème de méthode est-ce que vous
pouvez accorder 3 minutes de suspension
pour qu'on puisse essayer de voir si on
peut trouver euh l'accord qui va bien si
je puis dire bien volontiers donc 3
minutes de suspension de façon à
régler pendu pendant 3 minutes et euh tu
me proposesmi un son
et voilà une suspension suspension de
séance dans cet examen au Sénat du
projet de loi immigration alors que les
sénateurs débattent actuellement des
sanctions contre les employeurs qui
emploieraient des travailleurs sans
papier le projet de loi qui est porté
par le ministre de l'Intérieur géralde
Darmanin et bien il prévoit d'augmenter
les sanctions financières et les
sanctions administratives contre ce type
d'employeur et il se trouve trouve que
la commission des Lois du Sénat a décidé
de supprimer ces mesures alors il y a
pour l'instant un désaccord entre le
Gouvernement et la commission des Lois
du Sénat des accords sur la forme pour
des raisons juridiques le
ministreintérieur a espéré en tout cas
que ce n'était pas un désaccord pour des
raisons idéologiques et que il ne
s'agissait pas de la part de la
commission des lois et bien de protéger
ces employeurs qui emploient des
travailles d'illeurs sonans papier je
vous propose et bien de retrouver Steve
jourain Steve Jourdin dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve qui
a suivi et
bien voilà donc Steve Steve n'est pas
ouais oui donc Steve un débat qui a
porté sur ces employeurs qui emploi les
travailleurs sans papierers et voilà
pour l'instant il y a toujours pas
d'accord entre géralde Darmanin et la
droite non non pas d'accord vous le
voyez peut-être derrière moi Alex la
commission des lois qui est en plein en
pleine réunion notamment avec le
ministre pour débattre avec on voit
notamment Bruno rotaillot le patron du
groupe LR en plein conciliabu pour
discuter comment bien quelle suite
donner et bien à cette proposition du
gouvernement cette proposition qui a
donc avait qui avait été supprimé en
commission des lois peut-être en
quelques mots Alex pour dire où on en
est on est un peu dans le ventreemou de
ce texte immigration on est entre et
bien le volet intégration par le travail
on y est encore c'est ce qui est en
train d'être encore discuté derrière moi
et le volet fermeté le volet fermeté
donc de l'article 9 et 10 de ce texte de
loi qui promet et bien d'être très
discuté dans l'hémicycle voilà pour
l'instant on est dans ce ventreemou du
texte immigration et dans quelques
instants on va passer et bien au volet
fermeté et notamment à cette question
comment expulser davantage les étrangers
qui menacent l'ordre public en France on
y revient dans quelques instants voilà
cette réunion qui devrait se terminer
dans quelques instants maintenant
Alexandre effectivement Steve et puis
cet après-midi les sénateurs ont débattu
d'un sujet intéressant des mineurs non
accompagnés ces mineurs étrangers qui
sont pris en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance financé par les départements
et une fois qu'ils deviennent majeur et
il est question ou pas de leur offrir un
titre de séjour et dans ce débat et bien
les sénateurs de gauche ont proposé de
créer un droit à la régularisation de
ces jeunes majeurs qui ont été pris en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance ce
qu' a refusé la droite ce qui a refusé
le gouvernement et ça n'a pas plu au
sénateur socialiste Jérôme Durin écoutez
on vous dit régularisation vous parlez
d'appel d'air j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
qu'on qualifie cet appel d'ire on vous
dit régularisation vous dites circulaire
mais la circulaire c'est pas une bonne
solution ça n'est pas une bonne solution
ça organise la concurrence entre les
territoires et ça maintient des gens
dans des situations de Nomad juridique
combien de personnes on on a à traiter
des situations dans nos départements moi
j'ai trois dossiers là des gens il y en
a un qui travaille dans un garage il a
pas de situation la patronne elle dit
qu'estce qu'est-ce qui va se passer moi
j'ai besoin de lui il y en a un autre il
est dans une entreprise la gérante dit
la même chose et qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
ces gens c'est notre intérêt il y a une
question d'humanité il y a une question
d'économie parlez-en autour de vous donc
vous avez su entendre les maires mais
entendez aussi les patrons les artisans
je vous assure ça va pas générer d'appel
d'air ça va faire du bien à notre
économie ça va faire baisser la pression
et ça rendra service à tout le monde
voilà pour cette intervention de Jérôme
Durin le sénateur socialiste qui a
défendu une mesure facilitant la
régularisation de ces jeunes majeurs
étrangers qui ont été pris en charge pas
pendant des années par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et qui sont souvent apprentis
dans des entreprises donc qui ont besoin
besoin d'être régularisé on va écouter
et bien on va reprendre la direction de
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour continuer à
évoquer ces employeurs qui emploierai
des travailleurs sans papier faut-il les
sanctionner davantage écoutez ce qui se
dit après cette suspension de séance
c'est que évidemment je veux redire ici
pour que soit contre-rendu dans de du du
du Sénat que ces amendes que
administratives qui j'espère seront en
augmentation parcequelles sonont plus
efficaces qui viennent abonder le budget
de l'État qui aujourd'hui viennent
abonderer le budget de l'OFI qui quoi
qu'il arrive ses amendes sont
inférieurses à ce que nous versons à
l'OFI bon bah ces amendes soient
évidemment versé à l'OFI c'est 31
millions d'euros aujourd'hui on augmenté
de 45 % le budget de l'OFI en Kena bon
et il continue à augmenter et même s'il
y avait une augmentation de toute façon
vu les engagements qu'on a pris depuis
début de ce texte notamment les cours
gratuits notamment avec une construction
communiste gouvernement ce sera très
largement inférieur faudra beaucoup trop
d'amende et ça correspondra pas
évidemment à la réalité donc je prends
l'engagement solennel effectivement que
le produit de ces amendes
administratives viennent soutenir le
budget de l'OFI
intégralement VI de soutenir le budget
deofi intégralement et donc ainsi je
pense tout le monde est rassuré on passe
pour que les gens comprennent pour ceux
qui nous regardent une contribution
administrative lorsqu'on a quelqu'un qui
a des S papiers etune sorte de
correction de pas l'avoir embauché
indépendamment des questions pénales
hein dont on a évoqué tout à l'heure à
une sanction administrative plus rapide
à la main du préfet et qui viendra
abonder le budget de l'État qui abondera
intégralement le budget de l'OFI voilà
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame la
rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président vous avez
compris que il y avait quelques
inquiétudes que Monsieur le Ministre
élève nous lui faisons confiance et nous
voterons cette cet amendement merci
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois voulait s'exprimer monsieur
buffet vous
vouliez monsieur KCI je vous en
prie monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre comme je
suis représentant du Sénat au conseil
d'administration de l'OFI je voudrais
remercier de cet accord qui me va bien
et en passant monsieur le ministre
d'abord effectivement le budget de
l'offi é augmenté de 45 % 5 ans mais
reconnaissez aussi que le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile le nombre de sujets à
traiter a considérablement augmenté donc
si vous pouviez faire même un geste
supplémentaire pour 2024 je vous en
serai doublement reconnaissant merci
merci Monsieur carucci pour votre humour
Monsieur B
monsieur comme je suis l'ancien
président du conseil d'administration de
l'OFI je voudrais m'associer à la fois
au remerciement et à la demande de mon
collègue
kucci monsieur
wiil
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je n'ai jamais
eu de de fonction à l'OFI mais mais
néanmoins mais néanmoins nous venons au
soutien
de de cet amendement parce qu'il y a
aussi une actualité qui est terrible et
je veux la rappeler quand même en
septembre dernier un N d'enquêtes ont
été ouvertes je donne deux exemples
amourmelon le petit 160 vendangeurs de
nationalité ukrainienne étaient hébergés
dans des conditions lament able à nel le
repon où était logé dans des conditions
également indignes 52 travailleurs
d'origine malienne mauritanienne et
sénégalaise les arrêtés préfectoraux
révèl la présence de litri de fortune
l'état de véuseté le délabrement
l'insalubrité l'absence de nettoyage et
de désinfection l'état répugnant des
toilettes je cite les arrêtés
préfectoraux ainsi que les nombreux
risques incendies et donc évidemment
nous serons au rendez-vous nous
socialises de de de cet amendement et de
la nécessité de pénaliser plus fortement
ceux qui abusent de la faiblesse des uns
et des autres merci monsieur le sénateur
la parole est à présent à madame la
Présidente Cécile cuckerman oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord et nous l'avons dit depuis lundi
et l'ouverture de notre de nos débats
nous serons très attentifs au devenir de
cet article 8
initial non pas pour sanctionner pour
sanctionner mais parce que nous pensons
tout d'abord et
inévitablement que cela nous plaise ou
non qu'il y a aujourd'hui des employeurs
qui embauche siamment
consciemment des travailleurs sans
papier et que donc si nous voulons
appliquer les règles de la République
nous devons de les sanctionner et de de
les sanctionner très
fortement j'ai vu j'ai observé comme
tout un chacun ici je ne sais pas
plusieurs danses peuvent être évoquées
une forme de tango une forme de Vals à
je ne sais d'ailleurs combien de temps
en tout cas euh ce que je veux dire ici
c'est que nous nous félicitons tout
d'abord que nous puissions avancer sur
ce sujet-là et je l'ai dit depuis lundi
soir la question euh n'est pas de
renvoyer tout le monde dans le même camp
mais oui aujourd'hui s'il y a des
travailleurs sans papier c'est parce que
il y a des chefs d'entreprise qui les
e et donc nous avons deux jambes je le
dirai ainsi sur lesquelles nous devons
nous appuyer la première je ne réouvre
pas le débat des derniers jours je vous
rassure mes chers collègues qui est de
régulariser celles et ceux qui de fait
sont aujourd'hui employés travaillent
dans notre pays et sont une force active
de la production des richesses de notre
pays et la deuxième qui est en tout cas
d'aller sur de la sanction à l'égard de
chefs d'entreprise qui ne joue pas le
jeu qu'il faut y compris baisser le coup
de la main d'œuvre et qui utilise par
l'embauche de travailleurs sans papier
finalement l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme et donc en l'état nous avançons
avec vous monsieur le ministre dans ce
sens merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
bénaroche Merci monsieur le Président
bien entendu notre groupe s'associe et à
l'esprit et à la lettre de cet article
et donc de cet amendement que nous
voterons euh je voudrais préciser juste
une petite chose en fait euh
c'est bien parce qu'il y a des
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
déjà depuis longtemps et qui devrai être
régularisé qu' a des patrons voyou qui
embuchent ses travailleurs sans papier
et qui les gardent c'est pas l'inverse
voilà c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
patrons voyou qui a des travailleurs
sans papier c'est bien parce qu'il y a
des travailleurs sans papier qui a des
patron voyou dans la
réalité merci monsieur benénaroche je
vais donc mettre au voix h je vous en
prie Monsieur savolelli oui excusez-moi
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues pour ma part moi je suis très
favorable à que à ce que l'Office
français de l'immigration et
l'intégration et les moyens de de de son
action et on l'a prouvé nous par nos
votes quand la question est posée telle
que après je le dis avec tout le respect
que je leur dois et la solennité à mes
deux collègues monsieur bas et monsieur
kucci qui ont fait état de leur service
au sein de l'OFI j'irais vous dire mes
chers collègues le Bristol est un peu
entaché parce que j'ai pas oublié que
vous avez voté il y a quelques heures la
disparition de la me de 6 mois à 5 ans
pour les allocations familiales et de 3
mois à 5 ans pour la compensation
handicap donc la carte de visite est un
peu
entachée merci Monsieur sal madame la la
parole est maintenant à madame la
Présidente carère merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre nous
étions déjà favorabl à cet amendement n
nous le sonons doublement avec cette
engagement de Monsieur le Ministre de
mettre ses financements sur
fonctionnement de l'OFI qui est
essentiel bien sûr à au fonctionnement
et aujourd'hui à l'accueil de nos
réfugiés je vous remercie merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur
bas je voudrais signaler à notre
collègue qui s'est très justement
exprimer un instant pour nous faire part
de ces préoccupations d'ordre social que
c'est précisément Lofi par un excellent
rapport que je vous recommande qui
l'année dernière a mis le doigt sur la
dérive non pas de la me mais des visas
pour motif de santé qui coûteent à la
France plus d'un milliard d'euros et
donc cette institution a bien fait de se
préoccuper de l'abus de nos services
sociaux par les étrangers quand ils n'y
ont pas droit si Monsieur monsieur bu
monsieur le sénateur vous avez la parole
et vous êtes le seul à avoir la parole
je vous
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vu la belle unanimité qu'il y a pour cet
amendement je demande plus le scrutin
public alors vous ne demandez plus le
scrutin public sur les deux amendements
mais nous allons d'abord voter
pour savoir ce que vous pensez du
sous-amendement à l'article numéro 588
qui avait reçu un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est
contre qui est contre le sousamendement
levez bien les
mains qui
s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté donc la demande de s'il vous
plaît la demande de scrutin public ne
tenant pas je vais mettre au
voie les deux amendements identiques
56 5 et
588 qui ont reçu de la part de la
Commission désormais un avis favorable
avec les engagement de Monsieur le
Ministre et bien évidemment un avis
heureusement qu'ils sont d'accord avec
eux-mêmees du favorable du Gouvernement
bien sûr
d'évidence c'est pas toujours
facile qui est
pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient les amendements sont adoptés
et l'article 8 est ainsi
rétabli donc les amendements 130 et 466
de fait
tombe après l'article
8 nous avons l'amendement numéro
177 madame de La Gonterie ou madame Nar
CIN ou ousieur
allez-y je vous en prie monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le Président
pardon Bernard monsieur le ministre euh
nous souhaitons proposer que la durée du
droit commun de la carte de séjour
pluriannuel de 4 ans puisse s'appliquer
à des cartes qui sont soumises à l'heure
actuelle à un régime dérogatoire la loi
cas9 de 2016 relative au droit des
étrangers à généraliser la carte de
séjour pluriannuelle d'une durée de 4
ans mais malheureusement cette mesure
positive pour faciliter sécuriser le
parcours des étrangers connaît un
certain nombre de dérogations euh pour
avoir sur des des durées inférieures à à
4 ans c'est le cas pour au moins trois
catégories d'étrangers les étrangers
mariés à un Français les Parents
étrangers d'un enfant français mineur
résidant en France ou les étrangers dans
les liens personnels et familiaux en
France sont tel qu'un refus de titre
porterait une atteinte disproportionnée
au droit et au respect de la vie privée
et familiale pour ces catégories
d'étrangers en effet la durée de la
carte de séjour prannuelle n'est pas de
4 ans mais de 2 ans et cette durée
dérogatoire n'a aucune raison d'être
d'abord parce qu'elle maintient
puisqu'on parle de projet de loit
immigration et intégration ses étrangers
dans une situation de précarité
administrative maiselle la lourdit aussi
le travail des préfectures parce
qu'elles doivent instruire tous les 2
ans des demandes de renouvellement alors
qu'elle pourra le faire que tous les 4
ans sachant que des vérifications
peuvent être faites régulièrement et à
tout moment nous proposons donc la
suppression de ce régime dérogatoire un
alignement sur 4 ans je vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur le Président
je rappellerai le principe du du cza qui
est un principe auquel la commission
adhérer nous commençons toujours par un
titre de séjour d'une durée plus réduite
pour ensuite si inégration est acquise
poursuivre sur un durée une durée de
séjour qui est généralement plus longue
avec un titre qui permet de rester plus
longtemps sur le territoire nous
proposons d'en rester là avis
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
même avis défavorable donc je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement numéro 177
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est qui
s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté après l'article 8 amendement
numéro
178 madame con mourit je vous en prie je
vous remerci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à étendre la
délivrance du visa long séjour au
conjoint de français dont le mariage a
été célébré à l'étranger à condition
qu'il a été transcrit préalablement sur
les registres de l'état civil français
il s'agit de corriger une différence de
traitement manifestement injustifiée en
effet le cadre juridique actuel actuelle
réserve le droit de solliciter un visa
long séjour aux étrangers dont le
mariage avec un français a été célébré
en France et exclu ce dont le mariage
avec un français a été célébré à
l'étranger dans le cadre de la lutte
contre les mariages de complaisance qui
constitue une préoccupation constante
des pouvoirs publics les conditions
d'accès et de séjour en France ont été
considérablement durcies par le
législateur ainsi les unions entre un
ressortissant français étranger et en
lieu à l'étranger font l'objet de
contrôle strict et rigoureux tout autant
que ceux qui entourent les unions ayant
lieu en France pour me rendre
régulièrement dans ma circonscription et
passer beaucoup de temps dans les logau
les locaux consulaires je puis témoigner
de la minutie avec laquelle les demandes
de mariage sont traités par nos agents
consulaires formés à cet effet qui analy
les dossiers convoque et auditionne les
prétendants au mariage il suffit
d'analyser les statistiques de lutte
contre la fraude pour vous rassurer
c'est amendement se veut également un
signal pour les personnels qui font leur
travail honnêtement et la mesure de
cohérence que nous vous proposons n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'un gage de confiance
à l'égard de leur travail qu'ils
effectuent avec le même sérieux que les
agents d'état civil en France je vous
remercie merci madame la sénatrice avis
de la
commission madame la
rapporteur merci Monsieur Président
c'est un avis défavorable al
l'argumentation est assez technique je
je la résumerai assez rapidement c'est
que je pense que la rédaction de cet
article ne vise pas son objet car vous
souhaitiez étendre des conditions de
délivrance du visa et en fait vous avez
rédigé l'article de façon à ce que cela
vise une dispense or nous ne souhaitons
pas une dispense de visa et et nous nous
avait semblé opportun de manière une
différence de traitement entre un
étranger qui s'est marie à l'étranger un
étranger qui se marie en France avis
défavorable merci avis du gouvernement
même avis je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 178 avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté article 77 rectifieré terre
monsieur
Paco merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame monsieur les
rapporteurs par cet amendement je
souhaitais initialement proposer la la
création d'une médaille de l'intégr mais
les conseils avisés et la sagesse du
président de la commission des finances
Claude renal afin d'éviter les fourches
Codine et cruelle de l'article 40 m'ont
conduit à
métamorphoser cette médaille en un plus
simple diplôme alors pourquoi donc créer
un diplôme de l'intégration que le
gouvernement pourra éventuellement
transformer en en médaille certains
verront peut-être dans cette mesure
quelque chose d'anecdotique ou de
cosmétique ou même d'inutile mais ce se
serait faire fi à mon himble avis des
vertus de l'exemplarité du symbole et je
dirais même de la
méritocratie réussir l'intégration c'est
ou améliorer l'intégration c'est
vraiment aussi distinguer ses
réussites alors en mettant à l'honneur
ou en valeur donc des modèle
d'intégration et bien on envoie un
message fort aussi sur notre conception
de
l'immigration c'est-à-dire que on la
considère pas comme un réservoir de
façon caricaturale de main d'œuvre bon
marché mais qu'au contraire on sait se
féliciter lorsqu'elle incarne une
plusvalue sociale et donc si
concrètement il faut jamais nier les
problèmes au contraire il faut savoir
mettre en lumière celles et ceux qui se
comportent bien et on en connaît tous
énormément autour de nous des immigrés
ou des Français fraîchement naturalisés
qui au sein d'association
sont admirablement dévoués ou qui
professionnellement sont irréprochables
alors ces gens-là qui donnent le
meilleur de même qui apporte à la
République
sachons les ériger en modèle et les
récompenser merci monsieur le sénateur
avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
j'avoue mon cher collègue que mes chers
collègu que la Commission était assez
partagée sur ce point d'une part parce
qu'effectivement on a souvent l'occasion
de parler de d'une façon assez négative
et que ça ne ça n'est pas
effectivement la vision intégrale de
l'immigration en France et c'était une
occasion de le rappeler comme vous
l'avez indiqué en contrepartie de quoi
une autre partie de la commission
s'interrogeait sur le fait qu'on puisse
remettre un diplôme à quelqu'un qui
finalement se comporte normalement
puisque l'intégration est le principe du
comportement de l'étranger en France
c'est pourquoi quoi afin de ne pas
sombrer dans la schizophrénie nous avons
rendu un avis de
sagesse monsieur le ministre je suis
parfaitement favorable à l'amendement de
votre collègue Paco
d'accord monsieur ou a demandé la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues monsieur le
sénateur Paco vous êtes quand même
gonflé vous êtes quand même gonflé parce
que
vous proposez des
médailles aux étrangers alors que
depuis 3 jours maintenant vous ne faites
que leur retrancher des droits parce que
honnêtement si on si on regarde ce que
fait ce texte depuis 3 jours il
s'attaque à tous les compartiments de la
vie des étrangers qu'il soi en situation
irrégulière attaque contre laame qu'il
soit en situation régulière on complique
l'accès à la famille sur le territoire
national on est éigne la possibilité de
recourir aux aides pour le logement
madame Boyer nous explique que il faut
contrôler jusque dans les mariage la
manière dont les familles se constituent
et et là vous venez en nous disant bah
pour pour boire cette potion àère on va
leur proposer des médailles et ben non
monsieur Paco ils ne veulent pas des
médailles ils veulent des droits ils
veulent des droits et c'est tout à fait
différent et j'ajoute un deuxième point
un deuxième point parce que dans votre
amendement vous précisez que ce sont des
Français et là des Français par
acquisition en l'occurrence qui peuvent
être visé par votre processus de
médaille mais vous savez qu'il y a des
médailles dans la République pour tout
le monde pour tout le monde que vous
soyez français par acquisition ou
Français de naissance et donc moi je
trouve ça assez incroyable de se dire
que ils auraient leur médaille quelque
part de second rang voilà la médaille de
ceux qui sont venus de loin plutôt que
bah la Légion d'Honneur la médaille du
mérite et toutes les médailles parce que
notre République n'est pas dépourvue de
médaille parce qu'elle aime ce genre de
breloc voilà Monsieur Paco je pense que
vraiment cet amendement a quelque chose
d'indécent vu les heures de débat que
nous venons d'avoir je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur sotarel monsieur le sénateur à
vous oui merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voulais soutenir bien évidemment
l'amendement de mon collègue Olivier
Pacot que j'ai Cigné qui est le signe le
message d'une
reconnaissance d'une intégration et de
l'examen d'une situation au cas par cas
surtout je je voulais profiter de cet
instant
pour répondre je crois à mon collègue
Jad qui qui qui m'a interpellé ou en
tout cas qui m'a cité tout à l'heure
alors que j'étais en audition et ne
pouvais être avec vous pour indiquer
qu'effectivement comme vous tous comme
beaucoup nous sommes tous sensibles à
des situations individuelles et nous
souhaitons tous accompagner ceux qui se
montrent exemplaires et souhaitent
s'intégrer dans notre pays c'est
l'illustration même de ce que nous
portons dans ce texte avec la réécriture
que nous avons apporté et les examens
des situations au cas par cas voilà je
voulais simplement rappeler cet
engagement qui est très humain et je
pense que nous avons tous cette envie
d'accompagner et de valoriser ce qui se
montre exemplaire dans notre pays quel
que soit leur origine merci merci
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
Président carucci je crois qu' avait
demandé à prendre la parole
oui je je monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je suis consignataire de cet
amendement alors j'entends bien les les
propos de notre collègue wiouisy
mais la vérité c'est que l'acquisition
de la nationalité française est un
événement difficile lourd et tous ceux
qui ici ont participé dans des mairies à
aux cérémonies d'entrer dans la
nationalité des gens qui y entrent
voient l'émotion et la force de ces
cérémonies et ben moi je considère que
la symbolique lorsque on reconnaît les
mérites et bien c'est peut-être la
méritocratie c'est aussi l'exemple et
l'exemplarité et je considère que dans
une société comme la nôtre si on ne
souhaite pas évidemment euh que tout
soit permis tout soit possible et c'est
pour ça qu'un certain nombre de mesures
sont prises mais par rapport à cela
lorsque des gens acquierent la
nationalité lorsqu'ils sont dans
vraiment le mérite le sacrifice
l'implication de soi et bien c'est
normal alors sera pas une médaille parce
qu'on a compris que l'article 40 c'était
non mais un diplôme reconnaissant une
intégration réussi et ben c'est très
bien merci Monsieur le à vous monsieur
Paco
je ne suis pas convaincu que je
convaincrai mes collègues d'en face mais
je sais pas si je suis gonflé je sais
pas si vous êtes cohérent parce que
depuis 3 jours vous nous accusez de
d'être particulièrement cruel envers les
immigrés puis là il y a une mesure qui
est peut-être un petit peu moins
méchante entre guillemets si je prends
votre raisonnement et là vous êtes
contre alors voilà gardez votre
cohérence maintenant pour revenir à
l'analyse de
la rapporteur effectivement peut-être
que il y a pu avoir un doute au sein de
la commission faut-il dire merci à
quelqu'un qui se comporte bien c'est en
gros ce que vous voulez me dire le but
de ce diplôme c'est de dire bravo à ceux
qui se comportent très bien c'est pas
exactement ça bravo à ceux qui se
comportent très bien ensuite les
médailles oui monsieur wiy pour une fois
il a raison il existe différents types
de médailles et tout le monde peut y
prétendre sauf qu'il existe différents
types de médailles les palmes académique
les arts et lettres Lord du Mérite
agricole qui
correspondent à des parcours très précis
et bien dans le cas présent ce diplôme
correspond à un parcours très précis qui
peut s'adresser au français fraîchement
naturalisé mais aussi monsieur wi il
fallait le lire mon article mon
amendement mais aussi aux immigrés non
naturalisé merci monsieur le sénateur la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
Paco j'ai j'ai lu aussi avec attention
votre amendement oui vous pouvez faire
un signe c'est marqué il est créé un
diplôme de l'intégration pour distinguer
les citoyens ayant acquis la nationalité
française donc je
respecte non mais attendez je respecte
ce que vous avez
mis voilà donc donct et là je vous
demander deé
à peut-être retirer votre amendement
puisqueaprès à juste titre à juste titre
dans l'objet vous avez fait une petite
concession vous mettez ah bah il y a il
existe sans doute autant de façons
différentes de s'intégrer qu'il y a de
français naturalisé certains critères
peuvent aider objectivement une
intégration réussie moi je le dis très
tranquillement l'intégration c'est pas
mécaniquement la
naturalisation voilà première chose et
deuxième chose pourquoi notre collègue a
eu raison de parler un peu d'indécence
c'est pas si vulgaire que ça
c'est
franchement diplôme
médaille quand vous êtes incapable de
donner la médaille du travail au
travailleurs sans papier qui travaill
vous la donnerez cette médaille du
travail vous la donnerez cette médaille
du travail
merci la parole est à maintenant et
maintenant à Monsieur
bénaroche très prolix merci je voulais
demander une précision une petite
précision aux auteurs de l'amendement ça
va un peu dans le sens de ce que vient
de demander monsieur salvoldelli j'ai
bien compris qu'on pouvait donner ce
diplôme à à à des gens qui avaient
acquis franchement la nationalité
française je comprends de vos
explications qu'on pourra délivrer aussi
à des personnes qui n'ont pas la
nationalité française donc à des
migrants qui gardent leur nationalité
donc ma question il existe on a quelques
exemples chacun en
tête des étranger en situation
irrégulière en France qui en fait
pourrait correspondre au critères pour
lequel il pourrait obtenir ce diplôme
donc est-ce qu'on peut aussi donner ce
diplôme à un certain nombre d'étrangers
en situation irrégulière en France qui
remplirait les critères que vous
précisez il y en a
quelques-uns merci Monsieur Boch donc je
vais mettre au voix l'amendement 77
rectifié TER qui a reçu un avis de
sagesse de la Commission et un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
manifestez-le en levant clairement le
qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté monsieur le ministre je vous
demande quelques instants de suspension
de séance s'il vous plaît la séance est
suspendu pour 5
minutes voilà pour ces débats au Sénat
sur le projet de loi immigration alors
que le Sénat vient de voter un
amendement qui crée un diplôme
d'intégration un diplôme à destination
des Français fraîchement naturalisés ou
alors de certains étrangers qui ont fait
preuve d'un parcours méritant
d'intégration que ce soit dans
l'insertion professionnelle dans
l'engagement associatif ou pour faire
valoir la culture et le patrimoine
français c'était un amendement du
sénateur les républicains Olivier Pacot
qui a été et bien salué par le ministre
de l'Intérieur Géral de Darmanin d'une
manière générale par la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat mais qui
n'a pas plu à la gauche à la gauche du
Sénat que ce soit les socialistes et les
communistes qui estiment que les
étrangers n'ont pas besoin de médaill de
diplôm mais ils ont besoin de droit et
même si c'est une mesure positive en
faveur de de certains étrangers et bien
la gauche sénatoriale n'oublie pas que
la majorité de droite et du centre du
Sénat a voté hier et bien le
durcissement des conditions de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension donc
il y a eu un débat intéressant autour de
ce diplôme d'intégration qui vient
d'être voté par le Sénat et après cet
amendement on va on va passer à une
partie importante de ce projet de loi
immigration qui concerne le volet
fermeté les mesures d'éloignement des
étrangers qui ont commis des crimes et
des délits justement pour en reparler on
va retrouver Steve Jourdain qui suit les
débats dans la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve ça y est on
attaque le volet fermeté du texte oui on
entre en quelque sorte dans le dur Alex
la séance a repris à 14h30 il est un peu
plus de de 16h maintenant on va parler
de ces articles 9 et 10 qui prévoit et
bien de la fermeté de la fermeté et
encore de la fermeté Alex oui vous
l'avez dit et bien il s'agit de voir
comment les sénateurs vont débattre de
savoir et bien comment expulser plus
facilement les étrangers qui représente
une menace pour l'ordre publi il sera
notamment question et bien des individus
fichés S pour islamisme il y a beaucoup
d'abonnements qui ont été déposés he
donc la séance les échanges promettent
d'être longs il promettent également
d'être d'être musclé le gouvernement
propose et bien de faire sauter les
protections qui existent autour de
certains étrangers en raison et bien de
leur statut personnel on va voir comment
la droite et bien va réagir à cette
proposition la droite qui propose de
rétablir en quelque sorte la double
peine la double peine Alexandre vous
savez c'est ce dispositif qui prévoit
qui permet et bien d'expulser les
étrangers qui ont été condamnés pour une
infraction pénale la double peine qui
existe encore dans notre droit
aujourd'hui mais qui a été
considérablement allégé ces dernières
décennies ces dernières années notamment
par Nicolas Sarkozi en 2000 2003 Nicolas
Sarkozi ministre de l'Intérieur du
gouvernement rfarin les LR vont donc
revenir à la charge et tenter de mettre
le gouvernement en difficulté sur cette
question merci beaucoup Steve et
j'accueille sur ce plateau le sénateur
àarenté les républicains Olivier Pacot
bonjour Olivier Pacot bonjour on va
revenir sur votre amendement qui vient
d'être voté à l'instant et qui crée un
diplôme d'intégration pour les Français
fraîchement naturalisés et certains
étrangers qui a eu un qui ont eu un
parcours méritant j'ai envie de vous
poser la question est-ce que c'est pas
un peu osé de voter cette sorte de
médaille alors que la droite sénatoriale
a voté des durcissements quand même des
droits des étrangers dans ce texte ces
derniers jours non c'est pas oser ou
gonfler comme l'a dit un de mes
collègues socialistes non c'est
simplement reconnaître
effectivement les parcours méritants
améliorer l'intégration c'est aussi
distinguer sa réussite et il y a des des
réussites et en fait le but mon but à
travers la création de au début ça
devait être une médaille ça deviendra
peut-être une médaille he de de
l'intégration c'était vraiment alors
qu'on parle le plus souvent des parcours
qui posent problème de mettre en valeur
de mettre en lumière ce qui au contraire
sont méritants parce que moi je crois
aux vertus de l'exemplarité de la
méritocratie de très nombreux élus sont
assaillis de demandes de soutien de
parrainage de défense de de médailles
que ce soit des légions d'honneur des
Ordres nationaux du mérite et cetera les
récipients d'air des médailles sont
toujours très fier de les obtenir et je
pense que ce sera le cas pour ce diplôme
de l'intégration pardonnez-moi Olivier
Pacot mais vous parliez des étrangers
notamment qui ont été méritants et
pourtant des travailleurs sans papi qui
parfois travaillent depuis des années et
bien vous avez durci leurs conditions de
régularisation c'est c'est pas cohérent
alors le fait qu'il soit sans papier
quand on est l llur on ne décemment non
mais c'est en fait le fondement même de
la notion de la législation on ne peut
pas consacrer l'irrégularité de la
législation par une loi dire des gens
qui ont fraudé on peut pas donner un
passeport pour la fraude après le but de
notre des différentes mesures qu'on a
pris c'est effectivement de réguler
l'immigration de stopper des flux trop
importants disons les choses clairement
une immigration choisie plutôt qu'une
immigration subie donc selon vous parce
que là on est sur question du Mérite he
notamment vis-à-vis de ces étrangers et
bien le mérite de de ces travailleurs
sans papier n'est pas prioritaire par
rapport à la question de la régulation
de l'immigration je serai incohérent de
le dire je seraiis
incohérent merci beaucoup Olivier Pacot
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et en
attendant que la sénatrice socialiste
Hélène conou Mouret s'installe sur ce
plateau on va écouter le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui s'est
exprimé cet après-midi sur la
régularisation des jeunes majeurs
étrangers qui ont été pris en charge
pendant des années par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance en tant que mineur non
accompagné la gauche demandé de
faciliter leur obtention d'un titre de
séjour la droite et le gouvernement ont
refusé d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur s'en est expliqué regardez
ces amendes que administratives qui
j'espère seront en augmentation
parcequelles sont plus efficace qui
viennent abonder le budget de l'État qui
aujourd'hui viennent abonder le Budet de
l'OFI qui quoi qu'il arrive ses amendes
sont inférieurs à ce que nous versons à
l'OFI bon ben ces amendes soient
évidemment versé à l'OFI c'est 31
millions d'euros aujourd'hui on augmenté
de 45 % le budget de l'OFI en Kena bon
et il continue à augmenter et même s'il
y avait une augmentation de toute façon
vu les engagement qu'on a pris depuis
début de ce texte notamment les cours
gratuits notamment avec une
coconstruction communiste gouvernement
ce sera très largement inférieur faudra
beaucoup trop d'amende et ça
correspondra pas évidemment à la réalité
donc je prends l'engagement solennel
effectivement que le produit de ces
amendes administratives vientnent
soutenir le budget de l'OFI
intégralement vient de soutenir le
budget deofi intégralement et donc ainsi
je pense tout le monde est rassuré on
passe pour que les gens comprennent pour
ceux qui nous regardent une contribution
administrative lorsqu'on a quelqu'un qui
a des sans papiers et une sorte de
correction de pas l'avoir embauché
indépendamment des questions pénales
hein dont on a évoqué tout à l'heure à
une sanction administrative plus rapide
à la main du préfet et qui viendra
abonder le budget de l'État qui abondera
intégralement le budget de l'OFI voilà
voilà pour cette intervention de géralde
Darmanin à propos je le reprécise des
employeurs qui emploient des personnes
étrangères sans autorisation de travail
et le Sénat a rétabli la mesure du
gouvernement dans ce projet de loi qui
prévoit de durcir les sanctions
administratives et financières contre
ces employeurs qui emploient des
travailleurs sans autorisation de
travail j'accueille sur ce plateau hlen
conou Mouret bonjourour vous êtes
sénatrice
socialiste des Français établis en
defense et on va parler avec vous d'un
aspect de ce projet de loi qui concerne
l'immigration étudiante il y a certaines
mesures dans le texte qui sont aussi
souhaitées par la majorité de droite et
du centre au Sénat qui finalement vont
durcir les conditions d'arrivée
d'étudiants étrangers en France vous le
regrettez absolument et je dois vous
dire que les réactions sont vraiment
très très négative nous envoyons des
signaux à l'extérieur de nos frontières
qui aujourd'hui sont analysés et
pris de de enfin pleine face d'exclusion
on parle d'intégration en fait c'est un
texte sur l'immigration et l'exclusion
pour nous c'est-à-dire que ce que nous
faisons nous demandons aux étudiants
étrangers déjà de remplir des dossiers
importants ce qui est normal d'avoir une
place réservée à l'université d'avoir un
logement d'ouvrir un compte en banque et
puis aujourd'hui nous rajoutons des
mesures qui vont encore durcir et rendre
encore plus complexe leur arrivée en
France et quand ils sont en France on
leur signale que et bien il va falloir
qu'il paye une caution qu'au bout de la
première année si l'analyse de leurs
études n'est pas enfin les études n'ont
pas été poursuivi sérieusement ils
n'auront pas une prolongation de leur
titre de séjour donc même quand ils sont
arrivés en France nous ça nous leur
présentons une liste de mesures pour
leur dire vous avez réussi à venir mais
on va tout faire pour que vous ne
restiez pas et c'est vraiment compris
comme cela alors que nous sommes
aujourd'hui euh dans une course euh au
niveau international pour l'enseignement
supérieur de pouvoir créer euh et et de
former des élites avec lesquelles
ensuite nous pouvons avoir une relation
bilatérale apaisée parce que il faut
savoir que 90 % de ces étudiants
rentrent dans leur pays d'origine à la
fin de leurs études et bien ceuxlà euh
demain feront leurs études ailleurs
c'est ce qui commence à se passer et
certaines familles m'ont contacté déjà
en me disant mais nos enfants sont dans
les lycées français nous consentons à
d'énores sacrifices financiers pour
qu'ils poursuivent leurs études dans un
lycée français parce qu'ils en
connaissent la qualité mais il est hors
de question que demain ils aillent en
France quand on voit tout ce que vous
mettez en place pour vous assurer qu'ils
ne viennent pas ou qu'ils ne restent pas
s'ils ont été admis con Moret les
sénateurs vont aborder dans quelques
minutes et bien le volet fermeté du
texte notamment le R forcement de
certaines mesures d'éloignement les
fameuses ocutf les obligations de
quitter le territoire français je
voudrais vous poser une question
notamment sur l'aspect international car
il y a dans le texte une mesure du
projet de loi qui est porté par le
gouvernement défendu également par la
droite sénatoriale qui prévoit pour
l'État français de pouvoir moduler
l'aide au développement ou les
attributions de visa aux ressortissants
de certains pays d'origine qui
n'accepteraiit pas et bien leur
ressortissant expulsés par la France
finalement euh cet échange de aide au
développement contre ressortissants
expulsés qu'en pensent les socialistes
écoutez c'est assez étonnant qu'après
avoir euh pendant 1 an imposer un quota
où un Algérien un Tunisien et un
marocain sur deux ne pouvait pas venir
en France si vous vous souvenez c'était
en rétorsion contre le manque de laisser
passer que nous demandons à ces pays
d'octroyer à certains ressortissants de
ces pays-là que nous ne souhaitons plus
avoir en France bien mais au lieu de
passer par le biais diplomatique parce
que c'est un élément de tension
continuelle et avec une autre casquette
il y a une dizaine d'années je me
souviens très bien d'avoir négocié avec
certains ministres de ces pays pendant
des mois pour arriver à un compromis et
un accord qui faisait que nous n'avions
pas besoin d'utiliser des mesures de
rétorsion parce que c'est cela ce qui
veut dire que sur le plan diplomatique
nous avons failli nous savons que nous
avons des tensions très sérieuse
notamment avec le Maroc au niveau
politique et donc nous rentrons dans un
bras de fer à chaque fois et là nous
allons en rajouter une couche en disant
et bien on va couper l'aide publique au
développement mais pourquoi ne pas
négocier le retour de ce que nous ne
voulons plus plutôt que de nous attaquer
aux populations les plus privilégz la
voie diplomatique mais bien sûr et puis
et puis et puis nous ciblons les les les
mauvaises
populations nous ciblons les
francophones et les francophiles qui
restent encore dans ces pays et avec le
temps je peux vous dire qu'il y en a de
moins en moins merci beaucoup Hélène con
mour d'être venue sur le plateau de
Public Sénat on va tout de suite revenir
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat car ça y est
les sénateurs vont entamer le débat sur
l'article 9 du texte qui concerne le
renforcement des mesures d'éloignement
notamment pour des étrangers qui
représenteraient une menace pour l'ordre
public de la France le critère de la
peine encouru de délit Passi d'une peine
de 5 ans en lieu et place de peine
prononcé et disproportionné au regard
des conséquences qu'une décision
d'expulsion aura sur ses droits
fondamentaux et sur les personnes qui on
font l'objet élément membr de leur
famille je merci monsieur le sénateur
madame à monsieur le
rapporteur c'est vous qui prenez la
parole pour
donner l'avis de la
commission excusez-moi défavorable mais
je pensais le prendre sur l'ensemble des
amendements de ce type pardon
défavorable je pensais le prendre sur
non il n'est pas en discussion commune
donc il faut que vous donniez votre avis
sur cet amendement déforable défavorable
monsieur le ministre oui quelques mots
très rapides monsieur président juste à
la fois pour répondre à Monsieur
benaroch et la question de la
constitutionnalité ou de la
conventionnalité de la mesure et de
manière générale sur ce que l'on veut
faire dans le 9 10 puis 13 mais d'abord
le 9 le 9 c'est l'arrêté ministériel
d'expulsion donc qui concerne expulsion
d'étranger irrégulier irrégulier donc
c'est un arrêté que peut prendre le
préfet et plus souvent le ministre de
l'Intérieur il y a très peu de mesures
par an moins d'un millier on veut
évidemment l'tend vous avez compris j'ai
compris que vous n'étiez pas d'accord
sur ce point en levant les protections
qui empêchent le minintérieur de prendre
end ces arrêtés ministériel d'expulsion
qui certes permettent une expulsion plus
rapide mais Don aussi des garanties plus
fortes à la personne que l'on veut
expulser notamment une commission de
magistrat et cetera et cetera je veux
dire à Monsieur benaroch pour répondre
parfaitement à sa question que il n'y a
pas le Conseil d'État d'ailleurs l'a dit
dans son avis il n'y a pas
de de texte dans notre bloc de
constitutionnalité ou dans la cdH qui
empêche de revenir sur les protections
qui avaient été décidé par le
législateur sur proposition d'ailleurs
du ministre Sarkozi en 2003 nous sommes
le seul pays à avoir mis ces protections
là dans toute l'Union européenne et donc
c'est vraiment du pur droit législatif
alors évidemment il y a une disposition
surquelle nous proposons pas de revenir
d'illeurs personne ici à l'actuel des
amendements ce sont les mineurs qui
commettent des actes graves pendant
qu'ils sont mineurs mais ça on est
d'accord c'est la Convention européenne
des Droits de l'enfant notamment que
nous avons signé mais toutes les autres
sont levées alors on verra qu'il y a
plusieurs types de rédaction possibl et
ça ne veut pas dire monsieur benaroche
et là peut-être arrive le débat
constitutionnel bien sûr ou d'autres
débats qui vous concernent qu'il n'y a
pas de juge pour regarder ce que nous
faisons nous prenons arrêté ministériel
d'expulsion et après le juge constate si
la vie privée est familiale l'emporte
sur le trouble grave à l'ordre public ou
si le trouble l'emporte sur la vie
privée et familiale pour la nation c'est
le même principe qu'on a qu'on a mis en
place pour l'intérêt fondamental de la
Nation pour ce qui touche le terrorisme
donc il y a évidemment euh pardon de
dire comme ça euh discussion chez le
chez le juge bien sûr mais aujourd'hui
discussion chez le juge n'est même pas
possible pour le ministre de l'Intérieur
les protections fait que si quelqu'un
est dans le cadre des protections votées
par le législateur il y a 25 ans je ne
peux même pas prendre d'arrêter
ministriel d'expulsion et donc je ne
peux même pas aller devant le juge donc
un c'est l'expulsion on verra après
qu'il y a l'éloignement de ce n'est
c'est constitutionnel et conventionnel 3
il y a évidemment un équilibre mais le
ministre d'intérieur doit faire son
travail de ministre d'intérieur et le
juge fera son travail de juge
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur
bénaroche monsieur le ministre bien
entendu s'il y a protection importante
c'est que à un moment donné nous avons
jugé le législateur a jugé le ministre
de l'époque a jugé qu'il fallait
protéger et nous ce que nous disons avec
le défenseur de droit d'ailleurs c'est
qu'en fait c'est le curseur que vous
déplacez et que le déplacement de ce
curseur est particulièrement inquiétant
non seulement car la référence à la
peine encourue plutôt que prononcée va à
l'encontre du principe
d'individualisation de la peine
mais également car dans les faits les
peines encourues sont très supérieures
aux peines prononcées si bien que la
levée il nous l' ça nous a été expliqué
hier par Monsieur spitler car dans les
faits si bien que la levée des
protections contre l'expulsion
concernera de fait un champ beaucoup
plus large et très très large de
personnes pour lesquelles la gravité de
la menace représenté sera loin d'être
établie c'est là où nous bougeons le
curseur et c'est le fait de Bouget qui
nous paraît préoccupant le risque
d'attête sera d'autant plus important
que le recours contre l'expulsion n'est
pas en principe
suspensif par ailleurs en visant les
parents d'enfants français et les
personnes mariées avec des conjoints
français les dispositions de l'article 9
génère aussi un déséquilibre entre
l'objectif de saugarde de l'ordre public
par des mesures de police administrativ
et les exigences du droit de mener une
vie humaine familiale protégée par
l'article 8 de la Convention européenne
de sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamental ainsi que par
les articles 3 et 9 de la CIDE pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons monsieur le
ministre je réitère que notre groupe
demande la suppression de cet
article merci Monsieur le
Ministre avec une notion de la rapidité
qui nous rapprochera vous et moi je pas
allonger le débat mais c'est vraiment un
article très important qui sera
d'ailleurs scruté par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc je vais vraiment le
redire ici et après on ira peut-être un
peu plus vite dans les amendements mais
pour dire à Monsieur benroch que son
explication et je comprends sa position
évidemment elle est elle est respectable
bien évidemment elle est pas celle du
gouvernement qui a besoin évidemment
d'élargir les champs parce que vous avez
tout à fait compris la mesure monsieur
le sénateur c'est effectivement d'ouvrir
la possibilité de plus de personnes qui
mériteraient l'expulsion du point de vue
du ministère de de l'Intérieur
aujourd'hui pour faire très vite
expulsion éloignement il y a 2500
étrangers délinquants que je je j'arrive
à faire
expulser in concretto et 4000 par an à
peu près c'est à a toujours le même le
même sujet que je n'arrive pas à
expulser non pas parce que j'ai pas les
laissé passer consulaires non pas parce
que le juge m'empêche de le faire mais
parce que ils font partie de ces
réserves d'ailleurs nous avons si vous
le souhaitez pour ceux que ça intéresse
tout un tas d'exemples extrêmement
préoccupants par exemple un ressenti un
ressortissant d'un pays je va pas le
citer entré en France en décembre 2001 à
l'âge 8 ans l'intéressé n'est pas marié
n'a pas d'enfant sur le territoire
national et ne présente aucun
justificatif d'insertion professionnelle
il ne justifie d'aucun titre de séjour
il présente 12 condamnations je parle
pas d'accusation de la part de la police
12 condamnations au casier en 9 ans dans
la dernière avec 18 mois de prison ferme
conduite sans permis avec récidive usage
stupéfiant vol aggravé en récidive il
est entré en France avant l'âge de 13
ans il n donc pas possible de expulsé le
même ressortissant d'un pays différent
avec à peu près le même le même profil à
part que lui il a été condamné seulement
à seette condamnation comme il est
arrivé à l'âge de 13 ans et demi je peux
l'expulser voilà je pense qu'il y a
aucune
à à tout cela cette personne n'a pas de
lien avec notre pays il n'a pas d'enfant
il n'est pas marié il n'a pas d'ination
professionnelle combi il en aurait
d'ailleurs on pourrait quand même
proposer l'expulsion mais sous prétexte
qui est arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans je
ne peux pas procéder à son expulsion en
tout cas je ne peux même pas aller
devant le juge alors qu'il n'a pas de
lien avec notre pays bon voilà il
commettent en général ses méfit un peu
plus après 18 ans le fait d'ê rester
quelques années sur notre territoire ne
ne justifie pas de pouvoir garder des
des des personnes quiettent des crimes
de façon récidiv
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre voix donc l'amendement 315
rectifié avec un double avis défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 348 rectifié par
Monsieur le Président
retaillot bien l'article 9 l'article 10
sont très importants ça vient d'être dit
dans dans le débat qui qui a commencé le
13 octobre compatriotes les Français ont
été doublement sidérés une première fois
sidérés parce qu'ils ont appris à
nouveau qu'un professeur de la
République venait d'être assassiné une
seconde fois sidéré lorsque ils ont
appris que cet
individu aurait pu faire l'objet
d'expulsion mais qui n'a pas été expulsé
pourquoi parce qu'il était arrivé sur le
territoire français avant l'âge de 13
ans et les
Français totalement sidérés ont vu que
nous avions on une règle l'expulsion
pour des individus dangereux étrangers
mais que cette règle était tellement
trouée qu'elle avait été en quelque
sorte tué par les exceptions les
exceptions ont tué la règle et ces
exceptions menacent désormais les
Français
progressivement nous avons abandonné les
instruments juridiques de régulation de
l'immigration progressivement nous avons
organisé parfois nous-même comme vient
de le dire le ministre il y a quelques
instants notre propre impuissance
comment voulez-vous les Français
comprennent que ce sont des individus
étrangers très dangereux qui parfois ont
été condamné très sévèrement y compris
par des crimes de sang pour des crimes
de sang comment voulez-vous que les
Français nos compatriotes comprennent
que on protège ces individus et qu'on
laisse exposer à leur menaces à leur
violence à leur barbarie les Français
honnêtes paisible je sais qu'il va
mettre tout à l'heure opposé
l'inconstitutionnalité l'INC
conventionnalité chers collègues nous
sommes des législateurs nous sommes là
pour exprimer la volonté générale et je
pense que ce débat doit avoir lieu mon
amendement ne concerne pas les mineurs
de moins de 18 ans mon amendement ne
surtranspose pas et ne ne devivont pas
surtransposer les règles de la CEDH
c'est au juges pour l'ITF ou à
l'administration pour l'arrêté
d'expulsion de mettre le curseur sous le
regard bien sûr des tribunaux sous le
regard des tribunaux mais de grâce de
surtransposition et et donnons aux
Français le gage d'une vraie protection
merci monsieur le Président avis avis de
la
commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
Président sera un avis de
sagesse vous y voyez immédiatement
l'attention le témoignage de l'attention
qui est porté à la fois votre amendement
monsieur retillot mais au-delà de de
votre
aventement à votre expression et à
l'ampleur du le sujet pour nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens on bien sûr
été sidérés par les drames auxquels vous
avez fait référence ils ont été sidéré
de comprendre ou de mesurer les
conséquences de ces protections monsieur
le ministre an a parler dans son propos
introductif lundi la levée des
protections absolues et relatives et le
sujet qui est en est pas il y a deux
manières d'aborder ce
sujet et je vais vous présenter monsieur
le Président finalement les différents
amendements une première manière qui
consiste à dire on lève toutes les
protections il n'y a plus aucune
protection ou de
dire on lève les protections dans toute
une série de situations et de mesurer
ensemble si le champ des possible répond
à la préoccupation de nos cons citoyen
et à la préoccupation que vous avez
exprimé monsieur retaillon et donc je
vais aller directement à la conclusion
après je vais essayer de vous la
justifier
effectivement la question que vous posez
est une anticipation du débat que vous
avez prévu ça fera de ma part le 13
décembre le sujet constitutionnel dont
on comprend parfaitement la la teneur et
dont vous nous avez fixé quelque part le
le cadre le cadre intellectuel et
parallèlement jeose plus dire en même
temps nous allons essayer de regarder
ensemble tout ce qui peut être fait et
chers collègues vous allez être étonné
par l'ampleur non seulement de ce qui
peut être fait mais de ce que vous avez
prévu les uns et les autres dans vos
amendements parce que entre les
amendements rapporteurs l'amendement de
Monsieur carucci l'amendement de
madameidman l'amendement du
Gouvernement je pense que le tour est
possible est réellement considérable et
va répondre me semble-t-il de manière
assez satisfaisante aux préoccupations
vous avez exprimé monsieur reetillot
encore une fois pas à titre personnel
mais au nom de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens alors
pourquoi nous ne pouvons nous avons une
difficulté sur la levée sur la
suppression sèche des euh des
protections c'est pas un sujet
conventionnel pour une fois c'est
vraiment un sujet purement
constitutionnel tout simplement parce
que le Conseil constitutionnel nous
impose alors je cite une décision 2005
d'assurer une conciliation équilibrée
entre la sauvegarde de l'ordre publici
et le droit de mener une vie familiale
normale nous sommes là dans ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel tire du 10e
alignéat du prédembule de la
Constitution de 1946 qui vous savez tous
a été intégré dans bloc de
constitutionnalité et dans ce cadre
effectivement le Conseil constitutionnel
estime qu'il y a un droit à la vie
privée familiale sur ce point et je ne
serai pas plus long il y a comme souvent
en matière constitutionnelle une
conciliation équilibrer une tension à
mettre en place entre deux principes
vous n'allez pas être surpris chers
collègues c'est quand même sont des
sujets classique pour chacun d'entre
vous la protection de l'ordre public la
sauvegarde de l'ordre publicque et de
l'autre côté la protection de la vie
privée familiale le législateur peut
très bien dans cet exercice de curseur
mettre l'accent sur la sauvegarde de
l'ordre public et vous en avez la
possibilité là où on sait par avance que
le Conseil constitutionnel va nous
répondre non c'est que ça ne peut pas
être un 100 % en ordre public et un 0 %
vie privée familiale ce qui serait le
cas si on supprimait complètement les
protections qu'ell soi absolu et
relatives si maintenant on regarde tout
ce que l'on peut faire vous allez avoir
les amendements rapporteur qui prévoit
premièrement une baisse des seuils pour
la levée nous
passons à nous proposant de passer à 5
ans pour les protections absolues et 3
ans pour les protections relatives pour
répondre à Monsieur Baroche il est exact
que dans ce cadre nous souhaitons
abaisser fortement le niveau et 5 ans
c'est un vol avec une circonstance
aggravante 3 ans un vol simple donc ces
deux exemples vous montrent qu'on
descend bas le niveau de protection nous
ne pensons pas qu'on puiss se permettre
d'aller au-delà puisque immédiatement on
va avoir les problèmes constitutionnels
et je ne vous cache pas quen vous
proposant cela nous testons nous-mêmes
les limites de la des positions du
Conseil constitutionnel qui n'ont pas eu
sur le principe je vous l'ai présenté
sur le niveau ça ne peut pas donner
d'élément puisque cette législation sur
les prot il faudrait faudrait conclure
allez-y allez-y alors je termine je vais
avec les ce que l'on peut vous proposer
vous avez un abandement sur
l'abaissement des seuils
de permettant la convention 5 ans et 3
ans vous avez ensuite les violences
intrafamiliales que nous introduisons
avec avec plus les violences sur les
ascendants nous vous introduisons nous
vous proposons de prononcer une ITF la
possibilité pour les jeux prononcés
unitf à partir de 3 ans d'emprisonnement
nous vous présent nous vous proposerons
un avis favorable sur l'amendement de
monsieur carucci qui écarte toute
protection absolue ou relative lorsque
l'étranger est en situation irrégulière
nous vous proposerons un avis favorable
sur le 583 de madame esliman qui
supprime toute protection en cas de
violence sur les élus et les agents
publics et nous vous proposerons un
amendement favorable sur le 611 du
gouvernement qui supprime également
toutes les protections en cas d'atteinte
au valeur de la République il nous
semble que dans l'ensemble des possibles
que nous ouvrons nous apportons une une
solution non pas 100 % mais très
largement euh dans le sens de ce que le
président reetaillot a exprimé me
semble-t-il au nom d'une très large
partie de nos consitoyens j'attire enfin
votre attention sur un dernier un
dernier élément sans vouloir de près ou
de loin anticiper sur votre votre vote
si vous adoptez l'amendement du
président retaillot par conséquent nous
faisons tomber tous les amendements
subséquent imaginons que la force de
conviction du président reetaillot la
force de conviction
qu'il exprime et que peuvent exprimer
d'autres conduisent à voir ceci dans le
texte qui sera issu des débats devant
l'ensemble du Parlement j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que la censure du
Conseil constitutionnel je vais être
prudent je vais dire est probable et que
nous n'avons plus rien derrière
c'est-à-dire que l'ensemble des
possibles que je vous ai définis nous ne
l'UR nous ne l'aurons plus dans le texte
nous on perdu nous ne pouvons pas le
sauvegarder je vous demande excusez-moi
je vous demande simplement d'avoir ceci
à votre esprit au moment où vous
prendrez chers collègues la décision
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur nous
avons compris que vous aviez déjà que
vous êtes exprimé déjà sur des
amendements à venir voilà donc vous n
dispenserez de de de longs propos
explicatifs ensuite sur les amendements
à venir monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président peut-être rien que
la mesure proposée par le gouver
gouvernement qu'elle soit ou pas modifié
par les quelques amendements de des
rapporteurs c'est jusqu'à 4000 mesures
aujourd'hui par an alors qu'on est
plutôt à autour de 400 500 aujourd'hui
par an donc la disposition
indépendamment de votre amendement
monsieur le Président c'est déjà une
grosse une très grosse disposition
évidemment je rappelle que l'arrivée
avant l'âge de 13 ans sur le territoire
national c'est 69 % des cas où
l'expulsion n'est pas possible ensuite
vienent la protection des conjoints
français qui en 2e position 22 % et et
donc évidemment on voit bien qu'on est
sur le ne gordien de ce qui nous arrive
sur les étrangers délinquants donc je
voudrais ici dire que l'article 9
prévoit bien des personnes qui ont été
condamnées définitivement à de la prison
je pense que pour nos débats c'est
important définitivement à de la prison
et et on avait imaginé dans le texte du
Gouvernement 10 ans ou 5 ans récidives
la commission des lois qu'on va suivre a
évoqué 5 ans voilà je pense que c'est
évidemment déjà important de le dire
c'est des gens qui sont condamnés à plus
de 5 ans de prison ferme de façon
définitive après tout à appppelle donc
il s'agit bien de délinquants ou de
criminels évidemment notoire avec
évidemment des des des difficultés à
comprendre pour les Français moi je
rejoin ce que dit le Président rotaillot
je prends l'exemple de deux frères qui
sont nés en 91 et un autre en 95 qui
sont nationalité étrangère qui sont
arrivés en France en 2003 qui ont
toujours été en situation régulière l'un
a été condamné à 10 ans d'emprisonnement
pour viol sur personnes vulnérables
l'autre a été Condé à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement pour proxiliitisme
aggravé son minur de moins de 15 ans et
les deux frères bénéficient de la
protection de la parce qu'il sot arrivé
avant l'âge de 13 ans et que chacun peut
se prévaloir de son lien familial avec
l'autre sur le territoire national bon
là faut avouer que il y a un certain
nombre de dispositions je pense que
législateur pourrait s'en convaincre qui
sont évidemment absurdes alors monsieur
le Président rotalot je comprends tout à
fait la philosophie de la présentation
de votre amendement je ne peux y
souscrire et je ne peux donner qu'un
avis défavorable non pas pour vous être
désagréable mais parce que je tiens
comme très bien dit rapporteur à
l'avancée de ce texte et notamment qu'au
Conseil constitutionnel on est la valid
validité de ce texte parce estce que je
peux pas ne pas me passer de des 3600
ame supplémentaires que je pourrais
obtenir par l'intermédiaire de ceex ce
qui est à mon avis bien plus important
que les autres dispositions qu'on a
évoqué pendant des heures et des heures
donc qu'est-ce qui est constitutionnel
et qu'est-ce qui n'est pas c'est la
seule question qu'on doit border je
comprends bien que la politique doit
pousser un certain nombre de de cas je
pense que nous le poussons je pense que
ce que nous faisons est constitutionnel
je rappelle d'ailleurs l'avis du Conseil
d'État pour la clarté de nos débats qui
expricite clairement que le Conseil
d'État considère que le fait d'excepter
des protection l'étranger qui
continueent de menacer gravement l'ordre
public ne Sete à aucun obstacle d'ordre
constitutionnel ou conventionnel dès
lors que les décisions d'explusion sont
soumises au principe de nécessité de
proportionnalité et de l'article 8 de la
CEDH donc nous pensons que notre
dispositif puisque le Conseil d'État l'a
validé il faut le souligner est positif
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça monsieur
le Président retagot vous allez plus
loin d'ailleurs que la levée des
protections vous le savez bien dans
votre amendement puisque non seulement
vous levez toutes les protections alors
que nous les levons évidemment mais pour
ceux qui sont condamnés à à plus de 50
prisons ferme mais en plus vous mettez
des dispositions de peine automatique
pour les retours les retours la
condation retour donc vous vous engager
le juge à avoir une peine automatique ce
qui est clairement vous le savez bien
contraire à la Constitution à la libre
individualisation de de la peine par les
magistrat et par ailleurs vous a
augmenté les peines encourues de manière
à notre avis disproportionnelle ce qui
peut s'entendre évidemment politiquement
et qui ne peut pas exister en dehors
d'une réforme constitutionnelle et même
celle-ci d'ailleurs ne permettrait pas
une garantie mais on aura l' d' reparler
lors de votre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle donc moi j'invite euh
après avoir eu ce débat vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président à retirer votre
amendement pour le bien pour le bien de
ce texte parce que il est je crois
proportionnel et il va assez loin euh ça
ne veut pas dire que ça épuise des
débats d'ordre constitutionnel ou
conventionnel dans la proposition de loi
que vous faites mais ici nous sommes en
train de faire la loi ordinaire sinon je
serai donné obligé de donner un avis
défavorable j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs de donner sur d'autres sujets
monsieur le rapporteur à l'exception du
631 de Madame jourdda on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler donc c'est pas un
desésaccord de principe c'est juste pour
sauver ce texte très important pour la
sécurité de nos
compatriotes merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Nara
siga merci monsieur le Président alors
je crois que le fait que ce cet
amendement soit pas soit pas
constitutionnel a déjà été bien établi
il est aussi contraire à la Convention
Européenne des des droits de l'homme et
je je veux quand même plus plus
globalement aussi sur cet article bien
sûr dire que je crois que nous sommes
tous ici préoccupés par la question de
la lutte contre le terrorisme et que
l'État nous voulons tous nous assurer
que l'État a les moyens d'assurer la
sûreté de l'État et la protection de nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes vis-à-vis
de ces menaces donc il serait bon que
chacun évite les faux procès et les les
amalgames et les manipulations les
instrumentalisations euh du de
l'attentat
d'aras puisque par ailleurs ce texte a
été rédigé bien avant cet attentat euh
mais je voudrais aussi dire que le
régime de l'expulsion tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui euh il est il comprend déjà
il comprend déjà des mesures qui
permettent de lever les protections dans
le cas où il est avéré que les personnes
sont dans des entreprises terroristes et
que donc la question ça n'est pas tant
de modifier encore ce droit mais encore
une fois des moyens qu'on veut bien se
donner et peut-être ne pas perdre notre
administration nos préfectures dans du
suivi notamment sur la question du
travail illégal et dans la
multiplication on en parlera plus tard
des
OQTF et que on on puisse mobiliser
plutôt les moyens de l'État justement
sur le suivi de ces individus
véritablement dangereux donc mettons les
moyens là où ils sont nécessaires et
puis rappelons-nous aussi que selon les
chiffres même du ministère de
l'Intérieur la grande majorité des
auteurs d'attentat déjoués ou commis
depuis 2015 sont
français merci madame la sénatrice
madame de La ah non madame de La
Gonterie ne souhaite plus s'exprimer
d'accord monsieur le Président
rotillot de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit
pour mon amendement d'effacer les
protections les exceptions à la
règle que dont bénéfici des étrangers
qui ont été condamné et souvent
lourdement condamné faut toujours lire
les excellents rapports de la commission
des lois je voudrais vraiment remercier
du développement qu' fait il y a
quelques instants Philippe boncarer même
si nous sommes pas exactement sur la
même longueur d'ond sur l'ensemble de
son développement page 103 je cite un
individu condamné à 42 reprises entre 91
et 2019 pour des faits de vol de trafic
de stupéfiant de violents sur conjoint
de violents sur personne dépositaire de
l'ordre public outrage et agression
sexuelle est-ce que ça mes chers
collègues c'est faire un amalgame c'est
de cela dont il est les question c'est
de cela dont nous parlons et on peut pas
noyer ce débat là dans des argués
juridiques moi je suis respectueux avec
l'État de droit et la norme
constitutionnelle mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que souvent il doit y avoir
un équilibre entre l'expression de la
volonté générale la démocratie la
souveraineté populaire et aussi les
décisions juridictionnelles et
rappelez-vous lorsqu'ici je me souviens
avec les critiques au moment des
attentats nous avions avec notre
collègue Philippe Bas déplacer le
curseur entre la liberté publique et la
sécurité parce qu'il fallait faire face
à des situations extrêmement dangereuse
et Conseil constitutionnel sauve
d'ailleurs la consultation des sit
djihadiste à deux fois avait été
sanctionné incompréhensible donc ce
débat moi je le pose je veux bien j'ai
compris l'enjeu juridique je veux bien
retirer mon amendement mais je voudrais
que le rapporteur et le ministre me
donne
l'assurance que les autres amendements
Roger carucci l'amendement de la
commission
Mar et aussi le ministre pour la
commission que vous donniez et l'un et
l'autre et le Gouvernement et la
commission des avis favorables en
d'autres termes je retirerai mon
amendement qu'à la condition de savoir
s' il y a une autre voie de passage
merci président monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous souhaitez donc vous
exprimez après cette interpellation de
du Président rotaillot je vous en prie
oui je je vais peut-être faire la liste
je veux bien m'engager à des choses sur
lesquelles je peux tenir monsieur le
Président rotalo moi je vous ai déjà dit
que je donnerai favorable au au 631 de
Madame Jourda euh pour les autres je
vais regarder mais je pense que c'est
plutôt j'ai pas encore regarder le SU de
Monsieur carucci mais il me semble qu'il
n'est pas qui n'est pas non plus
constitutionnel ou qui pose des
questions en tout cas je vais regarder
tout de suite je vous le promets si vous
me laissez quelques instants pour que le
rapporteur réponde je veux juste vous
dire Monsieur le Président que je
partage évidement ce que vous dites
l'exemple que vous avez pris dans le
rapport de la commission des lois
monsieur le Président
rotagot il est répondu avec notre avec
le texte du Gouvernement et le texte de
la commission c'est pas votre c'est pas
votre amendement qui ferait naître
l'expulsion de cette personne c'est
l'article 10 tel qu'il est rédigé
aujourd'hui par la commission qui permet
l'expulsion de cette personne
entendons-nous bien votre amendement
monsieur le Président roto il permet
pour cette personne d'avoir une peine
automatique par le juge de nonretour et
c'est ça c'est là où fragiliserait mais
vous avez compris évidemment l'avancée
considérable de l'article 10 donc
l'exemple que vous prenez une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui je ne pourrais pas
l'expulser demain je pourrais l'expulser
avec l'article du gouvernement modifié
par la commission des lois et donc je
crois que ça a atteint le but que nous
évoquons je vais regarder l'amendement
de Monsieur carci je vais le regarder
comme je le fais toujours avec les
sénateurs et singulièrement avec
Monsieur carucci avec un œil
particulier monsieur retao
souhaitez-vous ah le président buffet
monsieur le Président Alley poured dire
au président rotaillot et à l'ensemble
des collègues que sur les amendements
630 de Madame la rapporteur 631 de
Madame la rapporteur 580 3 rectifier bis
de notre collègue hashliman 349
rectifier bis de notre collègue kucci et
même 61 gouvernement les avis sont
favorable monsieur le Président
rotillou vous avez bien compris l'esprit
de mon amendement c'est que notre
Parlement sous la 5e République est
terriblement affaibli et si à chaque
fois nous anticipons des décisions du
Conseil constitutionnel en nous
autocensurant on va s'affaiblir encore
plus et on doit porter aussi la
préoccupation de l'intérêt général de la
protection des Français donc si je
comprends bien mon amendement qui
pourrait avoir des difficultés juridique
s'il est retiré le sera au bénéfice
d'amendement qui eux vraisemablement je
regarde aussi la majorité sénatoriale
pourrait être voté c'est dans ces
conditions là que je vais retirer mon
amendement monsieur le
ministre nous nous prenons je pas qu'
March nous monsieur le Président rot
avant de re votre am peut pas donner un
avis favorable à CELI du ministre kuchci
pourquoi c'est l'avis du Conseil d'État
qui me pousse à ne pas le faire l'avis
du Conseil d'État autant il
a oui en fait ça s'appelle l'tat de
droit monsieur le Président bah oui
voilà je je suis désolé le ministre de
l'Intérieur un Conseil d'État un conseil
constitutionnel c'est vrai je je Maxim
coup nous avons porté un article 10 9
pardon que nous pourrions considérer à
peu près similaire au vôtre dans la
version initiale fournie au Conseil
d'État à l'exception près de la peine
automatique de retour le Conseil d'État
nous a dit à la fois que nous avions
raison possiblement raison que nous
pouvions lever les protections c'est ce
que je vous ai dit mais il a dit
attention le Conseil d'État il a dit il
y a deux régimes juridiques il y a un
régime de l'éloignement et il y a un
régime de l'expulsion le régime de
l'éloignement c'est pour les personnes
en situation irrégulière avec leOM de
qtf et qu'on éloigne du territoire
national il y a un régime de l'expul
c'est notamment pour les personnes
régulières chacun doit comprendre ici de
dont nous parlons c'est des arrêtés
ministériel d'expulsion que nous mettons
à des personnes qui ont des papier bon
et ce que dit le Conseil d'État c'est
que par le fait de très nombreuses
actions juridiques de jurisprudence mais
aussi de loi on a rapproché les deux
régimes alors que il ne faut pas les
rapprocher c'est le Conseil d'État quiil
le dit et c'est un un risque de les
rapprocher parce que il n'apporte pas
les mêmes garanties et que si nous
mettions une ame de façon systématique
en levant toutes les protections aux
personnes en situation irrégulière j'ai
bien compris si j'ai bien compris
l'amendement de Monsieur carucci Nous
nous favoriserions l'ame sur
leqtf et donc nous confondions les deux
régimes et il y aurait quelque part une
difficulté ou une inégalité des droits
selon la gravité de la situation et le
Conseil d'État nous a dit le Conseil
constitutionnel considéra sans doute que
l'unification de ces deux régimes ou le
rapprochement de ces deux régimes va
être aggravé par l'amendement de
Monsieur carochci et donc qui ne sera
pas constitutionnel donc la question
c'est pas d'être contre Monsieur caroci
par principe c'estàd qu'il y a deux
régimes c'est pour ça qu'il y a deux
articles dans la loi il y a un régime
d'expulsion pour les personnes
régulières il y a un régime
d'éloignement pour les personnes
irrégulière l'article 10 monsieur le
Président rotaillot prévoit l'article 10
prévoit l'éloignement pour les personnes
irrégulières nous levons les protection
nous faisons pareil que ce que vous
souhaitez faire mais dans deux articles
différents un pour répondre au régime de
expulion et un pour répondre au régime
d'éloignement
donc non mais je je c'est pour ça que je
vous propose monsieur le Président
rotaillot d'abord d'améliorer très
largement l'expulsion pour pour pour les
personnes régulières parce qu'on a déjà
ce premier problème nous aurons un débat
sur l'article 10 c'estaille
objectivement nous pourrions tout à fait
sous-amender lors de l'article 10 en
s'inspirant des propos écrit de Monsieur
koci l'article 10 mais si nous
confondons les deux exions si nous
mettons une ame pour les personnes
irrégulières en levant toutes les
protections personnes irrégulières je
crois qu'il y a un un un fait qui celui
que observe le Conseil d'État et et qui
observit l'attendue du Conseil d'État il
est sur le texte que j'ai déposé donc je
partage votre avis il y a un fait voilà
qui est qu'il y a deux régimes
différents et qui se rapproche donc
c'est un nom non pas parce que j'ai pas
envie de faire adopteramendement de
Monsieur KCI c'est un nom parce que nous
allons confondre les deux régime le
Conseil d'État nous a prévenu alors
qu'il a été je crois très à l'écoute de
la demande du gouvernement sur la levée
des protections en général il aurait pu
très bien considérer qu'il y avait un
principe de fraternité ou je ne sais
quoi il ne l'a pas fait il ne l'a pas
fait le Conseil d'État il nous a suivi
sur l'article 9 sur l'article 10 sur
l'article 13 donc voilà j'attire juste
attention que à force de de de pouvoir
d'être très très dur et c'est ce qu'
voulu le gouvernement puisque c'est la
disposition que nous avons proposé faut
savoir s'arrêter au bord dont on pense
que le Conseil d'État nous nous indique
ces principes du conseil de l'État et de
pouvoir avoir une une validation du
Conseil constitutionnel moi je vais vous
dire Monsieur le Président rotaillot
c'est une discussion intéressante
évidemment TR intéressante mais mais
c'est c'est ça la limite sans doute du
moment où la loi ordinaire s'arrête sur
le bloc de constitutionnalité donc le
débat que vous avez ici que nous avons
ici n'est pas n'est pas anodin et n'est
pas médiocre il est juste pas dans le à
mon avis dans le bon texte de loi il est
dans le texte de loi constitutionnel il
est pas dans le texte de loi
ordinaire merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le
présidentad la
présid bien compris les enjeux qui sont
extrêmement importants sur plan
juridique je vous demande s'il vous
plaît suspension de séance de 3 minutes
pour la suspension de séance est
accordée nous reprenons les travaux dans
3 minutes suspendu c'est un sénateur qui
vient et voilà pour cette suspension de
séance dans le débat au Sénat sur le
projet de loi immigration débat sur un
article important du texte article 9 qui
prévoit de lever les protections contre
l'expulsion pour des personnes
étrangères qui seraient et bien condamné
pour CRIM et délit et justement pour en
parler on va retrouver Steve jour qui
suit les débats dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du Sénat Steve
expliquez-nous les enjeux de ce débat
sur l'article 9 voà Alex on dans le cœur
du du réacteur de ce texte immigration
qui promet d'être beaucoup plus ferme en
la matière c'est une grande promesse de
géralde d'armanin qui joue très gros
politiquement vous l'avez dit il s'agit
et bien d'expulser plus facilement les
étrangers qui représentent une menace
pour l'ordre public le gouvernement veut
faire sauter les protections dont
bénéficient et bien certains
étrangers notamment en raison de leur
statut personnel par exemple les
individus qui sont arrivés sur le
territoire avant l'âge de 13 ans on va
écouter géralde dararmanin exprimer la
position du gouvernement écoutez-le un
ressortissant d'un pays je va pas le
citer entré en France en décembre 2001 à
l'âge 8 ans l'intéressé n'est pas marié
n'a pas d'enfant sur le territoire
national et ne présente aucun
justificatif d'insertion professionnelle
il ne justifie d'aucun tytre de séjour
il présente 12 condamnations je parle
pas d'accusation
de la part de la police 12 condamnations
au casier en 9 ans dans la dernière avec
18 mois de prison ferme conduite sans
permis avec récidive usage de stupéfiant
vol aggravé en récidive il est entré en
France avant l'âge de 13 ans il n donc
pas possible
deexpulsé le même ressortissant d'un
pays différent avec à peu près le même
le même profil à part que lui il a été
condamné seulement à Sep condamnations
comme il est arrivé à l'âge de 13 ans et
demi je peux l'expulser voilà je pense
qu'il y a aucune cohérence à à tout cela
cette personne n'a pas de lien avec
notre pays il n'a pas d'enfants il n'est
pas marié il n'a pas d'instation
professionnelle come même il en aurait
d'ailleurs on pourrait quand même
proposer l'expulsion mais sous prétexte
qui est arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans je
ne peux pas procéder à son expulsion en
tout cas je ne peux même pas aller
devant le juge alors qu'il n'a pas de
lien avec notre pays bon voilà ils
commett en général ses méfit un peu plus
après 18 ans le fait d'être resté
quelques années sur notre territoire ne
ne justifie pas de pouvoir garder des
des des personnes quiettent des crimes
de façon récidiv la droite LR qui aller
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin que ce que
propose Gérald daranin les LR qui
veulent faire sauter non pas certaines
protections mais toutes les protection
dont bénéficient ces étrangers qui
menacent l'ordre public je vous propose
d'écouter Bruno rotaillot qui a déposé
un amendement en ce sens le 13 octobre
nos compatriotes les Français ont été
doublement sidérés une première fois
sidérés parce qu'ils ont appris à
nouveau qu'un professeur de la
République venait d'être assassiné une
seconde fois foidérer lorsque ils ont
appris que cet
individu aurait pu faire l'objet
d'expulsion mais qui n'a pas été expulsé
pourquoi parce qu'il était arrivé sur le
territoire français avant l'âge de 13
ans et les
Français totalement sidéré ont vu que
nous avions une règle l'expulsion pour
des individus dangereux étrangers mais
que cette règle était tellement trouée
qu'elle avait été en quelque sorte tuée
par les exceptions les exceptions ont
tué la règle et ces exceptions menacent
désormais les Français progressivement
nous avons abandonné les instruments
juridique de régulation de l'immigration
progressivement nous avons organisé
parfois nous-même comme vient de le dire
le ministre il y a quelques instants
notre propre impuissance comment
voulez-vous que les Français
comprennent que ce sont des individus
étrangers très dangereux qui parfois ont
été condamnés très sévèrement compris
par des crimes de sang pour des crimes
de sang comment voulez-vous que les
Français nos compatriotes comprennent
que on protège ces individus et qu'on
laisse exposer à leur menaces à leur
violence à leur barbarie les Français
honnêtes paisiblebles je sais qu'il va
mettre tout à l'heure opposé
l'inconstitutionnalité
l'inconventionnalité chers collègues
nous sommes des législateurs nous sommes
là pour exprimer la volonté général
voilà Bruno retaillot qui a qui après un
échange plutôt vif avec Gérald décidé de
retirer son amendement il est 17h sur
Public Sénat on continue évidemment les
débats en séance c'est l'examen de ce
texte immigration article 9 article 10
qui viendra donc après l'article 9 c'est
le moment fermeté de cette examen du
texte immigration vous le voyez les
débats sont très techniques mais il ils
sont aussi très politiques vous le voyez
derrière moi Gérald adarmanin qui
échange avec la majorité sénatoriale
autour de cet article 9 la séance qui va
reprendre Alex dans quelques instants
maintenant merci beaucoup Steve pour ces
explications et si vous nous rejoignez
nous sommes en train de suivre et bien
l'examen au Sénat du projet de loi
immigration avec et bien l'examen en ce
moment d'un article très important du
texte du texte l'article 9 qui fait
partie du volet fermeté de ce projet de
loi immigration qui est porté par le
ministre Gérald de Darmanin l'article 9
on le rappelle prévoit de lever les
protections contre l'expulsion dont
certains étrangers peuvent bénéficier de
lever ses protections lorsqu'un étranger
est condamné à un crime pass possible
d'au moins 10 ans de prison et un délit
pass possible d'au moins 5 ans de prison
ça c'est pour la mesure qui est portée
par le gouvernement et le président du
groupe les républicains au Sénat Bruno
rotao veut aller plus loin veut des
mesures encore plus sécuritaire et il
propose de lever toutes les protections
contre l'expulsion
pour les étrangers voilà et après ce
sera à à l'appréciation de
l'administration et du juge de prononcer
ou non ces expulsions la réponse du
ministre de l'intérieur on l'a entendu
hein c'est que cette mesure de Bren
rotaillot serait et bien
antionstitutionnel car il faut un
équilibre entre la sécurité l'ordre
public mais également la préservation
des liens familiaux et des liens qui ont
qui ont pu être euh nooué par un
étranger avec la France donc il y a euh
voilà cet avis défavorable du ministre
de l'Intérieur géralde d'armanin euh qui
euh a été euh et bien proposé mais en
échange Breno rotillot a accepté de
retirer son amendement si les
amendements suivants proposés euh par la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
et qui sont un petit peu plus euh nuancé
que l'amendement de Breno rotaillot et
bien si euh ces amendements sont
acceptés euh par le gouvernement là
Bruno rotaillot retirera sa proposition
de supprimer toutes les protections
contre
l'expulsion pour les étrangers donc
voilà on attend la reprise de la séance
et en attendant on va revenir sur un
autre point du texte qui a été voté cet
après-midi par le Sénat la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat a voté pour
la création d'un diplôme d'intégration
alors que les débats vont reprendre tout
de suite dans l'hémicycle on retourne en
séance
nous avons demandé pour la clarté des
débats pour que tout le monde soit au
courant nous allons la Commission va
sous-amender l'amendement de Monsieur
carucci la rédaction est en cours elle
sera je pense madame la Présidente
distribuée dans peu de dans peu de
secondes et de peu de minutes donc voilà
la première mesure à faire il faut donc
nous sousamendons votre amendement
monsieur carouci ensuite monsieur rotot
dira ce qu'il fait sur son
amendement merci Monsieur le président
monsieur le Président
rotaillot si j'ai toutes les garanties
que les amendements qui vont restreindre
drastiquement les protections aussi bien
absolu que
relatives aux mesures d'expulsion sont
présente je retire mon amendement bien
merci monsieur le Président nous
arrivons à la discussion de neuf
amendements discussion commune le
premier celui de la commission le 630
présenté par Monsieur Madame la
Présidente conformement l'engagement
avec avec votre prédécesseur il est
soutenu défendu il est soutenu et
défendu monsieur le non non discussion
commune pardon je on va tous les
présenter le 179 rectifié madame de La
Gonterie comment elle s'appelle allez-y
chers collègues merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre alors
pardon de de rompre l'ambiance dans
laquelle nous vivons depuis une petite
demi-heure maintenant je sais pas
pourquoi il y a un écho tiens posousse
peut-être ton por je pense c'est toi qui
fait de l'écho
euh nous avons déposé cet amendement
parce que le sujet tel qu'il est posé il
est grave et sérieux grave et sérieux
sur le plan des principes grave et
sérieux sur le plan de leur mise en
œuvre
euh le projet de loi prévoit d'abollir
les protections légales contre
l'expulsion non plus en fonction de la
peine prononcée mais de la peine
encourue et la levée des protection elle
doit évidemment pouvoir être possible
mais elle doit respecter la
proportionnalité bien sûr et le respect
du principe d'individualisation des
peines et c'est exactement cela qui est
en train d'être mis à bas il y a une
disproportion entre le motif sur lequel
reposerait l'expulsion et les étrangers
concernés je vous donne un exemple hein
un étranger établi en France depuis au
moins 10 ans pour être pourrait être
pardon expulsé pour des délis de faible
gravité un vol à la tir dans le métro
pourrait demain permettre une expulsion
aujourd'hui dans le code pénal c'est un
vol aggravé au sens de l'article 311 4
puni de 5 ans d'emprisonnement ben c'est
ça la traduction concrète et
opérationnelle de ce qui est en train
d'être prononcé et évidemment pardon de
remettre quelques principes qui font en
effet l'État de droit cette mesure elle
contredit le principe
d'individualisation des peines qui
garantit que le prononcé de la peine est
en fonction de la gravité de
l'infraction et de la personnalité de
son auteur je vous rappelle pas
l'article 8 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen et évidemment
le l'ensemble des décisions du du
Conseil constitutionnel et donc c'est
pour ça que nous on propose évidemment
que la levée de la protection ne soit
possible qu'au regard de la peine
effectivement prononcée en l'espèce une
peine d'emprisonnement ferme au moins
égal à 10 ans pour les étrangers
protégés au titre de l'article
l631 3 merci à vous madame Brossel
monsieur benaroche pour rappel au
règlement Mame la présidente règlement
juste pour signaler malgré tout que bien
avant l'interruption de séance euh
j'avais demandé la parole sur les
amendements de Monsieur rotaillot et sur
le sur le la discussion qui avait lieu
entre monsieur Darmanin les rapporteurs
et Monsieur rotillo j'espérais l'avoir
avant de passer à l'étude de des des
amendements suivants je l'ai pas eu donc
je voulais simplement m'en étonner
puceque je comprends bien effectivement
que là il y a une discussion comment
dire en en direct live euh parce que les
négociations d'hier qui ont est à
vootter certains articles sont peut-être
pas totalement terminés mais on se
retrouve un peu dans la même cas de
configuration qu'au moment de l'article
sur les amee c'est-à-dire que je je je
note je déplore que pour la première
fois depuis 3 ans que je me trouve dans
cette assemblée et à la commission des
lois un certain nombre de chos ne sont
plus faites en fonction effectivement
des avis réellement des commissaires des
lois et des avis à la fois juridiques et
bien entendu politique mais sont fait en
fa en fonction d'une négociation qui a
lieu maintenant aujourd'hui j'aurais
presque envie de dire à ciel ouvert même
si nous sommes sous une coupole et que
bien entendu tout le reste de
l'assemblée que nous sommes assiste à
cela aux spectateurs sans que il y a eu
aucune possibilité d'intervenir puisque
même ma demande de parole sur cet
article je n'ai pas pu la faire voilà
merci monsieur benaroche nous avions
bien repéré que vous nous aviez demandé
fait le une demande de parole mais
l'amendement de Monsieur retaillot étant
retiré il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote et donc pas de possibilité de vous
donner la parole en revanche je vous la
donne sur la défense de l'amendement
316 je m'excuse c'était pas une
explication de vote je je demandais la
parole bien avant l'interruption et bien
avant le retrait par monsieurill mais je
peux vous donner la parole que s'il y a
explication de vote et que si
l'amendement est maintenu comme
l'amendement n'est pas maintenu je ne
donne pas la parole par contre vous
l'avez maintenant sur l'amendement
316 merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement de repli par rapport à celui
que nous avons présenté tout à l'heure
vise à lever les dérogations à la
protection des parents d'enfants
français et des personnes mariées contre
l'expulsion le maintien des liens avec
les parents doit être préservé pour
chaque enfant même lorsque ses parents
sont condamnés pénalement ou incarcérés
cela doit s'appliquer sans
discrimination pour les mineurs que
leurs parents soient français ou
étrangers en situation régulière ou
irrégulière le Comité des droits de
l'enfant soulligne que la rupture de
l'unité familiale par l'expulsion de
l'un des parents ou des deux parents en
raison d'une infraction au loi relative
à l'immigration
liée à l'entrée ou au séjour est
disproportionné en ce que le sacrifice
inérant à la restriction de la vie de
famille et au conséquenceces sur la vie
et le développement de l'enfant n'est
pas compensé par les avantages obtenus
par le fait de forcer le parent à
quitter le territoire au motif d'une
infraction à la législation relative le
principe figurant dans de nombreuses
dispositions déjà en vigueur selon
lequel pour les étrangers s'ajoute à la
sanction pénale une sanction spécifique
lié à leur qualité d'étranger qualifié
de double peine est aujourd'hui associé
à des garanties spécifiques pour les
personnes ayant des liens familiaux en
France or le projet de loi éode un peu
plus ses garanties augmentant le risque
de rupture dans l'unité familiale et les
conséquences pour le maintien des liens
familiaux et le développement de
l'enfant ces dispositions risquent de
creuser la différence de traitement
entre les enfants de parents étrangers
ayant menacé gravement l'ordre public et
ceux dont les parents n'ont pas comobbi
infraction le risque ici est de
restraindre de façon disproportionnée la
réalisation des droits des étrangers
parant d'enfants français et de
compromettre les droits de leurs enfants
mineurs parce que ces dispositions sont
contraires à l'article 8 de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme concernant le droit de mener une
vie familiale normale notre groupe
demande l'exclusion des dérogations à la
protection des parents d'enfants
français et les personnes mariées contre
l'expulsion cet amendement est inspiré
des travaux de l'UNICEF merci Monsieur
benaroche Madame Monsieur Madame la
rapporteur pour l'amendement 631 de la
commission il est considéré comme
présenté il a déjà été présenté déjà
défendu l'amendement 561 madame
romag non monsieur ah Paron je suis
là merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
connaissons certainement la fin de cette
histoire mais je tenais quand même à
défendre cet amendement puisque je rejo
il rejoint en tout cas beaucoup le
l'amendement de Monsieur reetaillot cet
amendement que je propose vise à
renforcer l'arsenal juridique et à
outiller la justice et l'administration
pour protéger les citoyens de notre pays
il répond à une demande de fermeté
vis-à-vis des criminels demande
largement partagé par les Français
d'autant plus au regard des derniers
événements dramatiques qu'ont connu
notre pays deux objectifs à cet
amendement qui je le précise tout de
suite n'est pas une mesure d'ordre
général il n'est ni exclusif ni fermé le
premier objectif donc est d'élargir la
peine automatique je sais que c'est un
mot qui dérange d'interdiction de de de
territoire français prévu en matière de
terrorisme à l'ensemble des crimes ou
délits punis de 5 ans ou plus
d'emprisonnement sauf décision motivée
du juge qui pourra prendre en compte les
circonstances de l'infraction ou la
personnalité de son auteur et le
deuxième objectif est de supprimer
l'autom cité cette fois des protections
qui dans le droit actuel empêche au
tribunal et ce de manière inéluctable de
prononcer des ITF j'y ajoute y compris à
l'encontre des terroristes le juge aura
toujours la possibilité de ne pas
appliquer le qtf en fonction de
circonstances motivées l'idée vous
l'aurez compris est d'inverser la vapeur
mais nous en parlons depuis suffisamment
de temps maintenant que l'expulsion des
criminels étrangers devienne la règle et
que le juge et la faculté RET et non
l'inverse je vous remercie merci Madame
romagnie le 134 défendu par Monsieur
sourec
oui c'est vous excusez-moi madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur mes chers collèguue
cet amendement vise à inscrire dans le
marbre de la loi le principe d'une
interdiction du territoire définitive à
l'encontre de tout étranger coupable
d'un crime mais également la
prononciation d'une interdiction de
territoire d'une durée de 10 ans à
l'encontre de tout étranger coupable
d'un plé d'une peine d'emprisonnement
d'une durée supérieure ou égale à 2 ans
cet amendement vise donc à clarifier la
peine d'interdiction du territoire
français les étrangers qui ont gravement
porté atteinte aux règles qui régissent
la société française n'ont pas leur
place sur le territoire national
l'interdiction définitif du territoire
français doit donc s'appliquer à titre
permanent à l'égard de ceux qui ont
commis un crime il est incompréhensible
pour nos compatriotes qu'un étranger
ayant commis un crime est une seule
chance de rester sur le territoire
national à l'issue de sa condamnation un
étranger doit avoir un comportement
irréprochable lorsqu'il est légalement
accueilli par le peuple français sur le
sol national ainsi nous proposons qu'une
pa d'interdiction de 10 ans du
territoire soit prononcé pour tout
étranger coupable d'une d'un d'un délit
euh puni d'une peine d'emprisonnement
d'une durée supérieure égale à 2 ans ou
d'un délit pour lequel la peine
d'interdiction du territoire français
est prévue par la loi de plus les
propres services du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous apprennent que 93 % des
mises en cause pour vol 72 % des auteurs
de vol AC violence 32 % sont des
condamnés pour cou et blessure sont le
fait d'étranger ces personnes une fois
condamné n'ont rien à faire sur notre
sol chers collègues nous vous appelons
au bon sens et à la fermeté l'étranger
qui enfreint nos lois n'a plus sa place
à nos côtés et nous législateurs devons
veiller à protéger avant tout nos
compatriotes en expulsant ce qu'il
mérite merci merci amendement 180
présenté par Monsieur
chayou la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
je voudrais de nouveau comme a pu le
faire ma collègue la sénatrice colombe
brossell insister sur cet aspect qui
nous semble fondamental du principe de
l'individualisation des peines puisque
cet article 9 prévoit qu'il n'y aura
plus d'obligation de motivation de
décision dans deux cas de figure très
particuliers et très honnêtement cela
nous interpelle profondément y compris
au regard des principes fondamentaux du
droit et de l'État de droit pourquoi
craint-on qu'il n'y ait plus de
nécessité de motiver certaines décisions
alors encore une fois c'est un principe
qui nous semble assez fondamental c'est
une mesure très lourde celle qui
consiste à interdire du territoire
français donc il serait tout à fait
légitime de pouvoir considérer que nous
devons toujours et que le juge doit
toujours motiver et justifier cette
décision à la fois au regarde la gravité
de l'infraction mais aussi au regard de
la situation personnelle et familiale de
de l'étranger d'ailleurs n permettons
d'attirer votre attention sur l'avis du
Conseil d'État qui lui-même recommande
de ne pas retenir ir cette disposition
puisque le Conseil d'État a estimé que
cette dérogation introduit une
incertitude quant au maintien de
l'obligation générale de motivation qui
s'impose en matière correctionnelle en
application de l'article l131 1321 du
code pénal et notamment qui précise que
c'est incompatible avec les exigences
attachées au contrôle de
proportionnaliser de proportionnalité
réalisé au titre de l'article 8 de la
CEDH qui implique que l'ensemble des
éléments utiles à ce contrôle ressorte
des motifs du c'est la raison pour
lesquelle à travers cet amendement il
nous semble important de revenir aux
principes fondamentaux de droit et de
l'État de droit merci chers collègues
amendement 103 rectifié madame Darcos
merci madame la Présidente mon collègue
louile Vogel a souhaité que je défende
son amendement considérant qu'il n'est
pas tolérable que des étrangers auteurs
de graves infractions puissent se
maintenir impunément sur le territoire
national la Commission a choisi à
travers cet article de clarifier les
critères de levée de de la protection
systématisé par cette levée à l'encontre
des auteurs de violence intrafamiliales
et généraliser la possibilité pour le
juge de prononcer des ITF l'article 9
prévoit ainsi de faciliter l'expulsion
des étrangers qui constituent une menace
pour l'ordre public ou pour nos
concitoyens seront notamment concernés
ceux qui auront commis des infractions
graves ou répétées pour autant
considérant que l'arlinéa 10 de cet
article emploie le terme de réitération
d'infraction tandis que l'alinéa 24 vise
la récidive il est donc préférable de
s'en tenir à la notion de réitération le
simple fait d'être l'objet de plusieurs
condamnations définitives justifie
l'expulsion de l'étranger concerné je
vous remercie merci Madame Darcos le 52
rectifieré madame
Boyer merci madame la Présidente
euh il s'agit
d'un pour pour les raisons pardon
excusez-moi évoqué par le Président
rotaillot je vais retirer cette
amendement mais parce que je souhaitais
voir le prononcer d'une interdiction du
territoire français à l'encontre de tout
étranger quiuse de menace s de violence
ou qui commet tout autre acte
d'intimidation à l'égard d'une personne
participant à l'exécution d'une mission
de service public deviennent la règle
mais les amendements que vous proposez
ben je pense arriveront à satisfaire
cette demande merci Madame Boyer avis de
la commission si vous pouvez me résumer
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements volontier je ne reviens pas
sur l'amendement sur le l'avis favorable
sur notre propre amendement 630
avis défavorable sur le 179 présenté par
Madame la gterie et ses collègues 316
monsieur de La Roche et Monsieur
bénaroche excusez-moi et ses collègues
631 favorable c'est bien sûr notre
amendement
561 madame
romaniie vous avez suivi débat vous avez
compris que vous avez obtenu
satisfaction et sur la question d'aras
vous avez une double réponse favorable
l'intéressé serait éloigné expulsé
pardon en résultant d'une part des
violences intrafamiliales que nous
étendons aux ascendants et sa situation
irrégulière est-ce que vous pourriez
retirer dans ces conditions votre
amendement je vous remercie je retire
mon amendement le 134 monsieur zurex
c'est défavorable sauf retrait le 180 de
Madame de La Gonterie également
défavorable et le 100 le 103 de Monsieur
Vogel réit tion récidive
favorable très bien avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre c'est un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amendements sauf le 631 de Madame Jourda
les violences intrafamiliales sur
ascendant avec un peut-être un petit
risque constitutionnel qu'on va regarder
lors de la navette mais je pense qu'on
peut prendre ce risque en revanche c'est
un avis donc défav pour les autres soit
parce qu'ils veulent amoindrir ou
supprimer des dispositions d'article 9
soit parce qu'ils ne sont pas
constitutionnels à notre lecture j'en
suis désolé favorable sauf le 631 et y
compris le 630 le premier de la
commission très bien je vais donc mettre
au voix ces amendements donc
l'amendement 630 avec un avis favorable
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour l'adoption de
cet
amendement qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est donc adopté et il fait tomber le
suivant le
179 mets au voix le 316 rectifier avec
un double avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'amendement 631 de la commission avec
un double avis favorable qui est pour
cet
amendement qui s'abstient qui est contre
il est adopté amendement 561 tombe
l'amendement 134 tombe également le 180
tombe également le 103 un avis favorable
de la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est
adopté très bien nous passons ensuite à
trois amendements en discussion commune
le 610 présenté par le gouvernement
défendu le
583 présenté par Madame asliman
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cet amendement vise à lever les
protections contre l'expulsion d'un
étranger condamné définitivement à une
peine de prison supérieure à 5 ans
lorsque les faits à l'origine de cette
expulsion ont été commis contre les
titulaires de certaines fonctions
notamment les agents publics les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique les policiers les pompiers les
enseignants et l'assassinat récent du
professeur euh d'aras en est un exemple
flagrant euh les soignants je disais
mais aussi les avocats les magistrats
j'ajoute que cette levée de protection
concerne autant les protections
relatives que les protections absolues
on ne peut en effet tolérer qu'un
étranger qui s'attaque à ceux qui œuvre
quotidiennement pour l'intérêt général
pour notre sécurité pour notre État de
droit pour l'éducation de nos enfants ne
puissent être expulsés du territoire
français notre République doit faire
preuve de la plus grande fermeté
vis-à-vis de ceux qui s'attaquent à elle
qui sappent les fondements de notre État
de droit de nos libertés et de la
démocratie je vous remercie merci Madame
agiman président kouci
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je veux pas être très long
parce que on en a tellement parlé de cet
amendement avant même que je ne le
présente
que il en devient quelque chose d'assez
banal conformément monsieur le ministre
à ce que vous avez fait comme remarque
sur le positionnement du Conseil d'État
ce que pourrait être le positionnement
du Conseil constitutionnel et après donc
discussion avec le président de la
commission des lois le
349 est
modifier c'est-à-dire que puisque tout
le monde l'a reçu le rectifier si je
puis dire comment non B si on m'a dit il
est
rectifié 349 Pr
és
d'impression allez-y monsieur carucci
c'est pas très difficile je vous rassure
que ce soit après la ligée ass si vous
avez l'amendement sous les yeux ou après
la ligée à 10 nous rajoutons dans les
deux cas la même
formulation vous avez jusqu'au bout qui
est en situation irrégulière au regard
du séjour et là ça se modifie si cette
irrégularité résulte d'une décision de
retrait du titre de séjour en
application de l'article 432 d'un refus
de renouvellement sur le fondement de
l'article 412 ou du 1 de l'article 432 3
dans les deux cas que ce soit sur le 6
ou le 10 c'est la même modification ce
qui rend cet cet amendement donc
apparemment du moins je l'espère
conforme aux règles établies conforme à
ce que souhaite un pose le Conseil
d'État pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème devant le Conseil
constitutionnel si la Commission en est
d'accord et le gouvernement aussi j'en
serai ravi pour que le Conseil
constitutionnel soit dans un état
d'extase devant mon amendement merci
chers collègu en attendant l'extase du
Conseil d'État on va demander l'avis de
la commission sur ces trois amendements
oui madame la Présidente comme vous
l'avez compris nous sommes favorables à
l'amendement de schlichman
excusez-moi ashlem excusez-moi madame je
je ça je me permettrai
pas favorable également à l'amendement
présenté par Monsieur carouci et ses
collègues en tenant compte de la réserve
du Conseil d'État et à travers cela
euh le cet amendement se trouve
euh fait l'objet de la même rédaction
que celle du gouvernement ce qui nous
permet euh de vous donner trois
amendements de favorbles et comme madame
le Président chacun fait un grand effort
pour vraiment respecter les règles
constitutionnelles sans permettre
d'empiéter sur vos prérogatives de
présidence de la séance je voudrais
simplement avoir la certitude au moment
où on passe au vote que tout le monde a
bien eu l'amendement que tout le monde a
eu le temps de lire pour que nous ne
heurtions pas au moment du contrôle du
Conseil constitutionnel sur un débat
quant à la connaissance de la loi la
clarté je permet excusez-moi sans je je
ne doute pas que vous auriez prêté
attention madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le rapporteur pour la c'est
chacun le temps de lire l'amendement je
vais demander l'avis du Gouvernement sur
les deux amendements de Madame hashliman
et du président
kuchci madame la Présidente je vais
donner un avis favorable à sur
l'amendement de monsieur kouci qui
rectifie son amendement si j'ai bien
compris en reprenant une partie du 610
du gouvernement
donc je retire le mien je retire le 610
je soutiens donc celui de Monsieur
carucci et je donne un avis favorable à
celui de Madame
haschiman très bien merci Monsieur le
Ministre est-ce que tout le monde a pu
prendre connaissance du rectifieré TER
de monsieur
carucci ne voyons pas d'opposition je
vais donc mettre au voie les deux
amendements qui restent puisque le 610 a
été retiré par le gouvernement donc je
mets au voix l'article l'amendement
pardon4 83 rectifi bis porté par Madame
hasliman avec deux avis favorables du
gouvernement et de la commission qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
mets au voix le 349 rectifié ter du
président kucci même
vote non pas même vote donc qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
vais mettre au voix ainsi l'AM le le oui
voilà oui c'est bon je
mets non il est retiré ah
pardon pardonnez-moi j'allais retirer au
gouvernement son amendement 611 monsieur
le ministre
pardonnez-moi avec cet amendement
gouvernemental nous mettons finalement
la disposition du 6 du 13 au 9article 13
au 9 l'article 13 donc prévoit sil la
personne ne respecte pas les valeurs de
de la République qu'on puisse retirer le
titre de séjour ce qu'ère à la
discussion qu'on a eu sur la loi
séparatisme qui a été validé par le
Conseil constitutionnel et donc là
l'idée c'est effectivement de mettre
comme disposition supplémentaire la
violation grave des principes
républicains tels que définis par la loi
qui consue constitue pardon par nature
des comportements qui portent atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de l'État ce
qui permettra de lever en effet les
protections il complète donc l'article 9
sur les valeurs de la République merci
Monsieur le Ministre avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
favorable avis favorable je vais donc
mettre au voix cet amendement 61 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je vais mettre au voix
l'article 9 qui est pour l'article
9 qui est contre l'article 9 qui
s'abstient il est adopté nous avons
ensuite un amendement 112 qui est
présenté par monsieur sourec
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
présenter le 112 et le 113 en même temps
euh pour le 112 l'étranger qui fait
l'objet d'une interdiction
administrative du territoire et qui
s'apprête à entrer en France ne doit pas
pouvoir rentrer sur le territoire
national pour l'instant c'est que le
texte laisse penser qu'il peut s'agir
d'une éventualité même esprit concernant
le 113 lorsqu'un étranger qui fait
l'objet d'une interdiction
administrative du territoire est prè sur
le territoire français il doit être
reconduit d'office à la frontière dans
le texte c'est également une éventualité
je vous remercie merci Monsieur Z
d'avoir d'avoir défendu les deux avis de
la commission donc sur ces deux
amendements retrait sinon défavorable
puisquil s'agit bien entendu de la
pratique univoque de nos services de
police avis du
gouvernement vous êtes sollicité pour
des retrait monsieur
pardon il maintient très bien donc je
mets au voix ces de am enfin cet
amendement 112 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 113 avec les deux
mêmes avis défavorables qui est
pour personne qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
avons ensuite deux amendements en
discussion commune le 538 qui est
présenté par Monsieur ravier
oui merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues l'interdiction administrative
du territoire est une mesure
administrative prononcée par le ministre
de l'intérieur lorsque la présence de
l'étranger constituerait une menace
grave pour l'ordre public la sécurité
intérieure ou les relations
internationales de la France avant que
celui-ci ne soit sur le territoire cet
amendement supprime le réexamen
automatique des interdictions
administratives du territoire tous les 5
ans de plus il repousse le délai minimum
ouvrant à l'étranger le droit
d'introduire une demande de réexamen de
1 à 5 ans au vu de la multiplication des
menaces extérieures de l'afflux des
étrangers sur notre sol et de l'embolie
administrative il paraît nécessaire
d'alléger ces procédures dans ce pays
les seules peines qui soi automatiques
ce sont celles qui vont à l'encontre de
notre pays nous n'avons pas à garantir
un droit au réexamen automatique des
interdictions administratives c'est une
des seules interdictions qui se fassent
encore en amont de tout désordres
étendre le champ des interdictions
administratives du territoire c'est
réduire le nombre d'qtf non exécutés ou
non exécuta à vous entendre
nous cet amendement nous offre pardon
des marges de manœuvre mes chers
collègues je vous invite à ne pas nous
en priver très bien amendement 51
défendu par Madame
Boyer madame la Présidente cet
amendement précise que la demande de
réexamen d'une réexamen d'une
interdiction administrative sur le
territoire français ne peut intervenir
avant 10 ans lorsqu'elle a été prononcée
pour une infraction à caractère
terroriste ou pour atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation contre 5
années aujourd'hui pour l'ensemble des
interdictions aujourd'hui prononcées
merci Madame Boyet avis de la commission
sur ces deux amendements
défavorable défavorable sur les deux
amendements avis du
gouvernement défavorable voilà si vous
nous rejoign vous suivez bien sûr les
débats autour du projet de loi
immigration débats qui ont débuté lundi
au au Sénat sur un texte qui a été
considérablement durci par la majorité
sénatoriale et d'ailleurs les sénateurs
viennent d'adopter l'un des points
principaux sur le volet fermeté de ce
texte l'article 9 l'article 9 qui était
comme une réponse à l'attentat d'aras
c'est ce qu'en tout cas ce qu'a plaidé
et bien le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin puisque cet article
permet d'expulser plus facilement les
étrangers qui représente une menace
grave à l'ordre public et on va
retrouver Mathias araes dans l'émic
ticle du Sénat et qui suit pour nous la
séance Mathias et c'est d'ailleurs un
article qui a été à nouveau modifié par
la commission avec d'ailleurs l'accord
du gouvernement oui absolument depuis
cet après-midi on voit d'apres
négociation entre la Commission le
gouvernement la majorité sénatoriale
vous l'avez dit on se trouve dans un
volet de fermeté un volet répressif
vis-à-vis des étrangers pour musclé le
jeu en matière d'expulsion les sénateurs
ont débattu la possibilité d'expulser
plus facilement ou en tout cas de lever
les protections vis-à-vis d'une
expulsion pour des étrangers qui
représentent une menace il a également
été question des fichiers s dans cette
dans cet article 9 il y a eu aussi une
autre négociation là il y a un
amendement qui avait été déposé par
Bruno rotillot qui visait à supprimer
simplement toute protection contre des
étrangers qui représenteraient une
menace pour la France Bruno rotaillot
qui a accepté de retirer son amendement
à condition que le gouvernement
soutienne les nouveaux amendement déposé
par la commission un peu plus permissif
mais tout aussi dur au regard du
président des républicains le
gouvernement qui s'est exécuté et qui a
retiré ses amendements au profit
notamment d'un amendement présenté par
Roger carouti voilà ça c'est pour
expliquer un petit peu le rythme des
débats cet après-midi on a assisté à
beaucoup de suspensions tout simplement
et bien parce que le Gouvernement et la
commission ont négocié un texte qui
conviendrait à tout le monde t merci
merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes ces
explications noté donc que et bien cet
article 9 ainsi modifié par la
commission lève un certain nombre de
protection contre l'expulsion des
étrangers en en situation irrégulière
notamment dès lors qu'il représente une
menace à l'ordre public c'était
l'amendement de Roger carucci dont vous
venez de parler à l'instant Mathias nota
également et bien qu' a été adopté un
amendement du Gouvernement qui permet
également et bien de lever les
protections dès lors qu'il y a des
violations graves des principes
républicains de la part des étrangers on
continue et bien à suivre ces débats sur
le projet de loi immigration nous sommes
bien sur la suite d'amendements qui ont
été ajoutés les articles additionnels
après l'article
9 sont tout à fait correctes et le seul
débat c'est les moyens matériels
financiers que peut mettre en œuvre le
ministère de l'Intérieur sur ce plan
donc avis dé faavorable monsieur le
ministre pour le gouvernement même avis
vous êtes sollicité pour un retrait
madame
Martin retrait très bien amendement 548
monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente il
s'agit via cet amendement de pouvoir
expulser les étrangers condamnés pour
trafic de stupéfiants aux États-Unis un
président avait déclaré la guerre à la
drogue en prenant des mesures
d'exception c'est aussi ce qu'il faut
faire en France et particulièrement à
Marseille où le narcotrafic devient
petit à petit un narco-état le le trafic
est international on ne saurait donc se
limiter à des mesures Franco française
il faut se débarrasser des étrangers
peties main ou grands parrains du trafic
qui servent d'intermédiaire entre les
producteurs de de cannabis
essentiellement voire exclusivement
maghrébain et les distributeurs dans le
sud de la France c'est une des façons de
déstabiliser le trafic s'attaquer à la
filière via la diaspora à Marseille
l'extension du trafic engendre désormais
le recrutement soit de clandestin il
représente 50 % des petites mains soit
des demandeurs d'asile en attente de le
réponse l'administration et la justice
française doivent enfin les effrayer
réellement ils ont plus peur d'être
expulsés dans leur pays que de recevoir
une balle prenons les au mot asséchons
le recrutement en leur faisant bien
comprendre qu'ils perdront tout s'ils se
font prendre la main dans le trafic de
stupéfiants merci Monsieur ravier pour
la mesure avis de la commission
défavorable puisque vous avez déjà donné
à monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur la
possibilité de prononcer des expulsions
pour menace grave pour l'ordre public en
levant les fameuses protections et le
juge pourra également prononcer une
décision d'interdiction du territoire
français donc défavorable ou satisfait
comme vous voudrez monsieur le ministre
même avis même avis madame Kerman a
demandé la parole merci Madame pardon
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'entends
ce qui viendraêtre dit et
malheureusement cela fait un écho un peu
dissonant ou parfois d'ailleurs trop
juste avec d'autres choses qui ont été
dit précédemment vient d'être fait
référence au propos de l'ancien
président des
États-Unis qui sachant très bien user
des médias de communication pouvait
avoir les meilleures formules choc
est-ce que ces meilleures formules choc
on régler le problème de la drogue et du
narcotrafic aux États-Unis la réponse
est non donc je veux bien on peut
prendre toutes les mesures ici et faire
tous les affichages que nous souhaitons
mais nous avons deux débats la première
qui est celui que nous avons depuis
lundi sur la question de l'immigration
de l'intégration et des sanctions y
compris pour celles et ceux qui ne sont
pas là pour faire République avec nous
toutes et tous et puis après nous avons
un autre vrai débat mais d'ailleurs qui
passe la question de l'immigration parce
que et et et je ne sais pas s'il faut
dire heureusement ou malheureusement ce
débat aujourd'hui du narcotrafic impacte
notre pays et toute notre jeunesse de
manière très très très très forte je
sais que nos collègues ont déposé une
commission d'enquête et nous y
contribuerons mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas faire trop d'amalgam en la
matière parce que il serait mentir aux
françaises et aux Français et je crois
que nous avons tous ici ce même
engagement qui est celui de la sincérité
mais il serait mentir aux françaises et
aux Français que de leur disant qu'en V
en votant votre amendement nous
règlerions une bonne fois pour toutes
les conséquences et le le trafic du
quotidien dans un certain nombre de
quartiers de notre des villes pardon de
notre pays madame la Présidente je mets
donc au voix cet amendement 548 qui fait
l'objet d'une demande de retrait car
satisfait il est maintenu très bien je
le mets au voix avec deux avis
défavorables donc qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 55 rectifié défendu
par Madame Boyer merci madame la
Présidente vous le savez en France
au-dessus de 13 ans un mineur est
considéré comme responsable pénalement
de même à partir de 13 ans un mineur
peut-être condamné à des travaux
d'intérêt général une amende ou un
placement dans un centre éducatif fermé
ou bien placé sous contrôle judiciaire
de 13 à 16 ans les mineurs bénéficie de
l'excuse de minorité qui divise par deux
les peines prévues par le code pénal
tant les tant les amendes que les peines
de pris prison pour les mineurs de 16
ans à 18 ans cette excuse de
minorité ne peut pas être appliquée sur
décision motivée du juge et les mineurs
condamnés à la peine complète et pas
celle divisée par de aussi dans cet
esprit cet amendement demande de prévoir
des expulsions
administratives que ces expulsions
administratives puissent être prononcé à
l'encontre d'étranger posant une menace
à l'ordre public de 16 ans au lieu de 18
ans boy avis de la commission
défavorable on est d'accord sur la
notion de minorité pénale mais peut-être
pas quand même jusqu'à étendre les les
possibilités d'expulsion pour les
mineurs âgés de 16 à 18 ans monsieur le
ministre pour le gouvernement même avis
donc je mets au voix cet amendement avec
deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous avons ensuite
plusieurs amendements en discussion
commune trois exactement qui commenc par
le 543 monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues dans le cadre d'une
procédure administrative d'expulsion
l'autorité compétente et le préfet
aujourd'hui le droit prévoit la réunion
d'une commission d'expulsion composée du
président du tribunal judiciaire du
cheflieu de département d'un magistrat
désigné par l'assemblée générale du
tribunal judiciaire du chef-lieu du
département d'un conseiller de tribunal
administratif or cette commission ne se
réunit pas en cas d'urgence absolu au vu
de l'embolie des tribunaux la
multiplication des séjouresréguliers et
des menaces à l'ordre public par les
étrangers la procédure d'urgence absolue
doit être de mise la réunion de cette
commission impose des délais et des
coûts de convocation la mobilisation de
magistrat la possibilité de recourir à
l'aide juridictionnelle tout cela est
une gabgie de plus le préfet est en
mesure de juger par lui-même
l'objectivité d'un séjour irrégulier le
clandestin a déjà suffisamment de voix
de recours pour contester les décisions
du préfet cette commission est une étape
de trop au vu de l'embolisation du
système c'est pourquoi cette C
amendement supprime la commission
d'expulsion merci Monsieur ravier
amendement 114 monsieur
Zurek merci madame la Présidente dans le
même esprit nous souhaitons réaffirmer
la pleine compétence des préfets en
matière d'expulsion prévu par
l'ordonnance du 2 novembre 1945 relative
au séjours des étrangers elle examine le
cas des étrangers que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a décidé d'éloigner du
territoire français pour menace grave à
l'ordre public depuis la loi parce quoi
l'avis de cette commission n'a plus
qu'une portée consultative c'est raison
pour laquelle nous pensons que cette
commission sans réel butou utilité doit
être supprimée merci Monsieur Zurek
monsieur Baroche pour l'amendement
317 merci madame la Présidente vous
l'aurez compris bien entendu mon
amendement est en discussion commune
avec les deux précédents mais n'a rien à
voir avec les deux précédents je préc
non monsieur ravier je comprends que
vous l'ayez compris mais je précise
quand même pour mes collègues n'est-ce
pas voilà euh cet amendement de repli le
nôtre a pour objet de prévoir
l'évaluation de l'intérêt supérieur des
enfants de parents d'enfants français
avant le prononcer d'une décision
d'expulsion l'article 3 de la Convention
des droits de l'enfant précise que dans
toutes les décisions qui concne les
enfants qu'elle soit le fait des
institutions publiques ou privées de
protection sociale des tribunaux des
autorités administratives ou des organes
législatifs l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant doit être une considération
primordiale le Comité des droits de
l'enfant précise que les États partis
sont tenus de veiller à ce que toute
décision de renvoyer un enfant dans son
pays d'origine soit fondé sur des
éléments de preuve et soit prise au cas
par cas conformément à une procédure
prévoyant des garanties approprié et
comprenant notamment une évaluation
individuelle rigoureuse et la
détermination de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant c'est pour cela que nous
demandons de prévoir cette intérêt
l'évaluation de cet intérêt supérieur
des enfants de parents d'enfant français
avant le prononcer d'une décision
d'expulsion merci Monsieur benaroch avis
de la commission sur ces trois
amendements alors défavorable pour les
deux amendements tendant à supprimer la
commission
d'expulsion vous comprenez que les
décisions d'expulsion étant exécutoire
par provision les recours ne sont pas
suspensif en clair nous aimons beaucoup
nos préfets mais sauf urgence absolue là
il y a une disposition particulière qui
a été validée par le Conseil
constitutionnel il n'est quand même pas
raisonnable de se priver d'un minimum de
contrôle et de ne pas renouer avec des
lettres de caché sur le fait de la
proposition de Monsieur bénaroche que la
Commission d'excultion prenne en compte
l'intérêt de l'enfant mineur vous
comprenez bien que sa vocation même
c'est d'examiner au cas par cas en
tenant compte des situations donc je ne
il n'y a pas de motif à
rajouter ce que vous proposez dans
l'amendement puisque la nature des liens
familiaux d'étranger font part des
finition l'objet du travail de la
commission d'exultion donc défavorable
sur les trois amendements merci monsieur
le rapporteur avis du gouvernement même
avis donc je vais mettre au voix ces
trois amendements commençant par le 543
avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 114 rectifié deux
avis défavorables qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté amendement 317 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
oui pardon qui est contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas
adopté je amendement 117 présenté par
Monsieur
Zurek merci madame la Présidente par cet
amendement nous exigeons le renforcement
des mesures permettant l'explulion
immédiate d'un étranger faisant l'objet
d'une interdiction judiciaire de
territoire par cet amendement nous
demandons en effet que l'étranger
faisant l'objet d'une interdiction
judiciire du territoire communique à
l'autorité administrative l'adresse de
ces locaux de résidence je n'ai pas de
doute sur le fait que ce fera ça sera
l'unanimité parmi nosant avis de la
commission avant l'unanimité défavorable
imaginez que pour nos policiers
notifiant une assignation en résidence
ne demande pas la dite adresse me paraît
assez
sougrenu avis du gouvernement même avis
donc je vais mettre au voix cette
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
amendement 541 monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente j'ai
alerté à de nombreuses reprises le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur le caractère
islamiste de plusieurs mosquées à
Marseille il ne m'a jamais répondu une
seule fois une seule fois plutôt
concernant l'Institut des bleuet dans le
13e arrondissement il a juste dit à la
télévision que grâce à la loi que j'ai
voté que j'ai voté grâce à la loi
pour lutter contre l'islamisme il allait
pouvoir la faire fermer et bien monsieur
le ministre ce n'est toujours pas le cas
elle est bien ouverte à moins que ce ne
soit encore la faute des Anglais des
Kevin ou des Mathéo le pire dans tout ça
c'est que j'ai dû mener ma propre
enquête parce que le ministère de
l'Intérieur préfère laisser tranquille
les mosquées islamistes plutôt que d'
d'avertir de leur dangerosité il n'est
pas normal que les élus locaux soient
laissés complètement de côté concernant
les personnes dangereuses et fichées
pour terrorisme dans leur propre commune
les maires connaissent tout de tout de
leur commune du pavé qui est cassé au
lampadaire qui ne fonctionne pas mais
ils ne devrai pas savoir s'ils hébergent
dans leur propre commune de potentiels
terroristes surveillés par les
renseignements le maire est OP PG
officier de police judiciaire il est
temps de le considérer comme tel pas
comme un simple fonctionnaire qui doit
se mettre au garde àou devant les
injonctions du gouvernement ils sont un
relais essentiel du travail des forces
de l'ordre sur les 1370 personnes
inscrit au fi git en 2021 536 avaient
une nationalité étrangère 536 potentiel
bomb à retardement qu'on doit surveiller
au plus près en impliquant toutes les
autorités pour que les drames comme
celui d'arace ne se reproduise
plus merci Monsieur ravier avis de la
commission alors défavorable nous ne
pouvons qu'encourager monsieur ravier à
fournir au préfet des boug Ron toutes
les informations dont il aurait
connaissance en manière de manquement
aux valeurs de la République mais son
amendement porte sur un sujet différent
que nous connaissons bien dans cet
hémicycle qui concernerait la
possibilité pour les maires de demander
l'accès au fichiers le fichier des
fichiers S et dans le cas présent le
fichier des auteurs d'infraction
terroristes nous ne pensons pas que ce
soit le meilleur service à rendre au
maire que d'ouvrir cette possibilité
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement même avis donc défavorable
je mets au voix l'amend amendement 540
monsieur Zurek ah c'est d'accord donc je
mets au voix cet amendement 541 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont
pas adoptés amendement 604 monsieur le
ministre amendement du Gouvernement
oui c'est un amendement important madame
la Présidente il vise en effet à à
revoir le régime de libération sous
contrainte des détenus qui seraient en
situation irrégulière comptabilise au 3
octobre 2023 19 9953 personnes de
nationalité étrangère incarcéré sur le
territoire français soit 26 % des
74513 détenus 1/3 de ces 20000 détenus
étrangers sont irrégulier vous avez voté
une loi celle du garde d' saau sur la
Libération qui notamment prévoit le fait
qu'il n'y aur pas de sortie sèche et
donc qui une réinsertion et donc une
libération dans les quelques mois qui
précèdent si j'amais jamais il y a
effectivement un une possibilité
d'intégration on voit mal comment un
étranger en situation irrégulière
condamné à de la prison pourrait aller
s'intégrer puisqu'il a vocation à
quitter le territoire national ce que
nous souhaitons c'est que nous puissions
faire cette libération conditionnelle
sous contrainte on va dire que si on a
la possibilité d'être certain d'avoir le
laisser passer consulaire qui nous
permet de mettre ces personnes en centre
de rétention administratif puis dans un
avion pour repartir dans son pays si
nous ne l'avons pas nous préférons qu'il
reste quelques jours de plus dans
l'établissement pénitentiaire afin de
récupérer se laisser passer consulaire
de le mettre dans le centre de r dans
rétention administratif il n'a pas la
vocation comme les autres détenus à être
intégré à la République puisque il a
lui-même pris la possibilité de ne pas
respecter les règles de la République
s'agissant au fait qu'il soit condamné
il est en plus irrégulier dans la prison
donc ça nous paraît un amendement de bon
sens qui permet la bonne coordination
entre les services deadministration
pénitentiire et les les services du
ministère d'intérieur et les services du
ministère d'affaires étrangères monsieur
le rapporteur votre avis enfin l'avis de
la commission avis favorable c'est un
amendement qui apporte une plusvalue
pratique règle et je regrette avec
Madame jouran de ne pas avoir eu
l'habilité ou cette idée l'habilité de
d'imaginer ce système très bien je vais
donc mettre au voie l'amendement 604 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui ' abstient il
est adopté nous passons désormais à
l'examen de l'article 10 avec trois
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 546 monsieur
ravier et bien vous l'avez vu la
commission regrette de ne pas avoir eu
l'idée de Gérald daranin cette idée et
bien c'est de ne faire la libération
conditionnelle de détenus en situation
irrégulière uniquement lorsqu'on a la
garantie que l'étranger va pouvoir être
expulsé alors toujours un peu dans la
même lignée de ce que l'on a pu voir
dans l'article 9 on va maintenant
s'intéresser à l'article 10 on en
commence l'examen de cet article qui va
autoriser l'émission d'qtf d'obligation
de quitter le territoire français à
l'encontre de personnes aujourd'hui
protégé lorsque leur comportement
constitue une menace grave pour l'ordre
public Mathias là encore c'est un
article important dans le volet fermeté
de ce texte oui absolument c'est un
article important va continuer grosso
modo sur les mêmes discussions que
l'article 9 vous l'avez expliqué on ne
va plus parler là d'expulsion mais
d'émission d'obligation de quitter le
territoire français à l'encontre de
personnes aujourd'hui protégé vous
l'avez dit lorsque leur comportement
constiue une menace grave pour l'ordre
publi il y a plusieurs amendements on
est en train d'écouter Stéphane Ravier
il y en a sûrement deux qu'il va falloir
suivre plus particulièrement le premier
qui va très rapidement arrivé qui va
être présenté par Bruno retaillot le
président des républicains et qui
souhaite supprimer les protections dont
bénéficie certaines catégories
d'étrangers contre ces otf précisément à
l'exception vous vous en doutez des
mineurs le deuxième amendement qu'il
faudra suivre avec attention c'est un
amendement du Gouvernement qui souhaite
faciliter l'éloignement des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui ont
manifestement des manquements graves et
réitérés au principes de la République
on va peut-être retourner en sence parce
que c'est en train de s'échauffer on
entend que ça s'échauffe tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle criminel et des
délinquentss d'autres pays si ces pays
ne veulent pas délivrer de laisser
passer consulaire il faut être prêt à
engager un bras de fer avec eux la
France a récemment engagé 100 millions
d'euros pour le développement du le
développement du Nigéria le gouvernement
a-t-il pris des garanties pour qu'ils
accepent l'intégralité des demandes de
laisser pass Monsieur R en discussion
commune le 350 présenté par le président
retaillot tout à l'heure j'ai indiqué
que les article 9 et 10 sont très
importants les deux concernent la levée
des protections ce que j'ai appelé tout
à l'heure les exception à une règle qui
est affaiblie à force d'avoir été troué
justement par ces protections relatives
absolues attention parce que les deux
articles sont différents les deux
amendements que j'ai porté sont très
différents ils ne concernent pas la même
nature des actes c'était les expulsions
là il s'agit des obligations de quitter
le territoire il ne concerne pas les
mêmes publics ce ne sont pas des gens
qui ont été condamnés ce sont surtout
des euh irréguliers en réalité des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et je
voudrais dire pour prévenir les
préventions si j'ose dire du du
rapporteur que au regard de
l'inconstitutionnalité on n' pas du tout
les mêmes conséquences une expulsion le
recours n'est pas suspensif donc
évidemment la conséquence elle est grave
pour l'individu pour uneqtf le recours
est suspensif donc il y a pas du tout du
tout la même gravité dans les
conséquences par conséquent je pense que
cet amendement devrait être voté il est
complété d'un sous-amendement que la
Commission va présenter oui qui consiste
à à verrouiller si je peux dire la
sécurité juridique de votre amendement
en introduisant conformement au sous du
Conseil d'État la référence à la
vérification du droit au séjour prè
préalable conformément à ses
jurisprendance traditionnelle donc le
l'avis de la commission des lois vous
sera favorable et et la votre avis
monsieur le rapporteur sur le 546 de
Monsieur
ravier défavorable et défavorable très
bien donc si je comprends bien VI
défavorable sur le 546 et 350 sous
conditions d'adoption de votre
sous-amendement absolument c'est bien ça
avis du gouvernement
le le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable à l'amendement de Monsieur
rotillot non pas parce qu'il en refuse
le principe et parce que il nous semble
qu'il ne correspond pas tout à fait à
l'avis du Conseil d'État et nos
discussions préalable même si je
comprends qu'effectivement il n'est pas
similaire à l'amendement qu'il avait
déposé sur l'article l'article 9 nous
préférons j'ai pour ça que j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il est en discussion
commune mais ce n'est pas bien grave
madame la Présidente le 612 du
gouvernement qui lui reprend prend à peu
près les mêmes termes de façon un peu
différente si je dire monsieur rotagot
retire les protections et laisse
finalement le juge faire nous nous
gardons les protections pour essayer
d'être conforme à ce que nous évoquons
et puis nous mettons la gravité de la
menace bon voilà donc le 612 est plutôt
défendu si je dire en parallèle du celui
de Monsieur retaillot ou de Madame joura
sousamendé pour que un avis défavorable
évidemment un avis défavorable à
Monsieur ravier j'attire votre attention
monsieur ministre que si l'amendement
350 rectifié est adopté avec son
sous-amendement il fait tomber
l'ensemble du de l'article c'est pour ça
que je regrettter madame la Présidente
qu'il pas de discussion commune très
bien monsieur le rapporteur vous vouliez
prendre la parole non c'était pour vous
avez anticipé madame sur ce que je
souhaitais dire que chacun mesure bien
la portée de l'approbation que nous vous
suggérons de l'amendement de Monsieur
reetaillot il n'y aura pas de discussion
de l'amendement du Gouvernement qui est
donc écarté comme incompatible très bien
président retaillot explication de vote
j'accepte totalement le sous-amendement
de la commission puisque je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs et je l'ai un peu anticipé
dans la présentation de de dans la
défense de mon amendement puisque j'ai
indiqué que le public c'était vraiment
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
donc qu'on vérifie leur situation
irrégulière ça me semble être une mesure
qui au-delà du droit et de bon sens bien
donc je vais mettre au vote l'amendement
546 de Monsieur ravier avec un double
avis défavorable qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je vais mettre au voix d'abord le
sous-amendement de la commission le
sous-amendement
650 de la commission donc qui avec un
avis forcément défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour l'adoption de
ce sous-amendement qui est contre il est
adopté je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement 350
maintenant rectifié par le
sous-amendement le scrutin est donc
ouvert demandé par le groupe les
républicain
pardon
vous l'avez vu he une demande donc de
scrutin public sur cet amendement de
Bruno retaillot un amendement qui a été
qui fait également l'objet d'un
sous-amendement de la commission vous
avez vu adoption du sous-amendement de
la commission alors je vous précise
exactement ce que dit l'amendement
retaillot il supprime les protections
dont bénéficie certaines catégorie
d'étrangers contre les obligations de
quitter le territoire français les
fameuses TF à l'exception des mineurs
pour Bruno reetaillot et cela conduit à
une situation paradoxale où
l'administration est rendue
juridiquement incapable de tirer les
conséquences de l'irrégularité avérée du
séjour d'un étranger l'article 10 qui
est actuellement en discussion il
s'inscrit dans la lignée de l'article 9
he je vous rappelle l'article 9 qui a
été adopté tout à l'heure il facilite la
levée des protections contre les mesures
administratives d'expulsion et le
prononcé de peine judiciaire
d'interdiction du territoire français et
l'article 10 il est également dans la
même lignée puisqu'il s'agit non pas euh
de d'interdiction de du territoire
français mais d'autoriser l'émission
d'une OQTF une obligation de quitter le
territoire français à l'encontre de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui protégées
lorsque leur comportement constitue une
menace grave pour l'ordre public tout de
suite on va voir et bien le résultat du
scrutin2 exprimé 316 pour 204 contre 112
l'amendement est donc adopté et il fait
tomber l'ensemble des autres amendements
sur cet article et l'article 10 est donc
ainsi adopté puisque réécrit par
l'amendement du Président retaillot nous
sommes saisis désormais d'un amendement
542 présenté par Monsieur
ravier
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues au vu du nombre d'obligations
de quitter le territoire dit au qtf
ordonné chaque année 124000 en 2021
selon les juges administratifs du
Conseil d'État de l'embolie des
tribunaux administratifs conséquent de
et de l'explosion de l'insécurité due à
cette immigration irrégulière sous OQTF
cet amendement réduit le délai de départ
volontaire des OQTF de moitié en passant
ce délai de 30 à 15 jours nous envoyons
un message de fermeté nos compatriotes
n'acceptent plus ce délai de départ
volontaire ni les délais de recours
beaucoup trop long car ils savent que
c'est une manière de s'évader dans la
nature il se passe le mot à l'aide des
associations et de leur communauté sur
place sans oublier bien sûr le réseau de
la gauche la procédure administrative
française devient alors une farce pour
eux c'est pour cela qu'on est passé de
22 % d'exécution des octtf en 2012 ce
n'est pas fameux déjà à 7 % en 2022
c'est catastrophique le message doit
être la fermeté ne pas laisser au
clandestins le temps de se retourner
pour organiser le prolongement de leur
clandestinité c'est pourquoi chers
collègues je vous invite à soutenir cet
amendement de bon sens merci Monsieur
ravier avis de la
commission merci madame le Président la
Commission ne soutiendra pas votre
amendement monsieur ravier puisque nous
estimons que au regard aujourd'hui de de
la difficulté à éloigner et bien réduire
le délai n'aura pas grand sens et qu'il
nous paraît préférable de maintenir ce
délai de départ à 30 jours en cohérence
avec les nouveaux délis qui vont être
prévu par la réforme du contentieux que
nous discuterons tout à l'heure merci
Madame la rapporteur avis du
gouvernement même avis donc je mets au
voix cet amendement 542 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il ne n'est pas adopté
nous avons ensuite deux amendements en
discussion commune le 537 monsieur
ravier
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues l'interdiction de retour sur
le territoire français l'IRTF est une
décision prise par le préfet à la suite
d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français l'qtf dans les
précédentes versions du Code de l'entrée
du séjour des étrangers du droit d'asile
les interdictions de retour sur le
territoire français n'était pas soumise
à la limitation dans le temps cet
amendement propose de revenir à cette
version la la raison va de soi par souci
de fermeté le caractère illimité de ces
interdictions doit être érigé en
principe si on ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde et on ne le
peut pas on ne peut pas à forcierie on
ne peut à forcierie pas accueillir toute
la misère du monde plusieurs fois avec
ces limites on se lit les mains on se
condamne à recommencer toujours les
mêmes procédures un client satisfait est
un client qui revient et ce la cause de
la désespérance au sein de
l'administration préfectorale qui tente
par tous les moyens d'assurer ses
missions et d'éviter le naufrage
national les articles
l613-7 et
l613-8 du code de l'entrée et du séjour
des étrangers et du droit d'asile
constitue des garanties et nous
interrompons quelques instants cette
séance he pour revenir et bien sur
l'événement qui vient de se dérouler
c'est-à-dire l'adoption des articles 9
et 10 du projet de loi immigration et
pour en parler je suis avec la
présidente du groupe communiste Cécile
cucerman bonsoir bonsoir Cécile cuerman
tout simplement votre réaction à
l'adoption de ces deux articles qui
facilitent la levée des protections
contre les mesures administratives
d'expulsion pour l'un et l'autre pour
faciliter les émissions d'qtf
d'obligation de de quitter le territoire
français des mesures qui ont été
présentées aussi comme des réponses à
l'attentat d'aras par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et par BR vous savez moi je
crois depuis lundi soir ce que nous
avons essayé de défendre nous devons
avoir un discours de sincérité avec les
Français et donc ces à ceux à qui nous
nous adressons à travers cette loi je
crois que ne faisons pas croire que à
travers le vote de ces articles nous
allons régler tous les problèmes de
sécurité intérieure dans notre pays ils
sont réels et je ne les ni pas ce que je
constate c'est qu'effectivement
maintenant depuis quelques jours et
depuis quelques heures encore plus nous
sommes dans une loi qui est une forme de
fuite en avant qui n'est même plus sur
la recherche d'un équilibre mais qui est
finalement sur du durcissement article
après article de ce que nous pouvons
faire ou offrir aux étrangers qui sont
d'ors et déjà et qui résident dans notre
pays et moi je d'équilibre par exemple à
travers le compromis sur lesquels se
sont mis d'accord les centristes et les
élèves sur l'article l'article 3 on est
dans une remise en cause totale de même
de cette recherche d'équilibre que nous
ne partagions pas au départ mais qui
était réel de la part du gouvernement
article après article on va vers une
fuite en avant et un renforcement du
tout sécuritaire dans notre pays qui ne
règlera rien d'abord parce que les
étrangers sont d'ors et déjà présents
dans notre pays et que nous nous avons
défendu depuis le début l'intégration
par le travail et la maîtrise de la
langue française et nous ne dérogerons
en rien à cette objectif là deuxièmement
parce que oui il y a des problèmes de
sécurité mais sachant les traiter dans
leur ensemble et dans leur globalité
parce que j'ai envie de dire mais c'est
ainsi et c'est une réalité ce ne sont
pas que des étrangers qui aujourd'hui
provoquent leseffet qui génère de
l'insécurité dans notre pays donc on
peut renforcer à travers cet article 9
et et 9 et 10 ce que les uns et les
autres veulent faire pour agiter la peur
de l'étranger mais malheureusement on ne
règlera rien à la sécurité du quotidien
des Françaises et des Français est-ce
que ce n'était pas nécessaire après
néanmoins l'attentat d'aras où il y a eu
toute cette polémique autour de la
présence hein de ce jeune tetchen qui
aurait pu être expulsé et qui ne l'a pas
été à l'âge en
2014 notamment parce qu'il a été soutenu
par des partis politiques et par la
simade par le Parti communiste notamment
d'abord je crois que le drame qui s'est
passé à ras c'est terrible et que nous
ne pouvons pas utiliser la mort d'un
enseignant pour justifier quelques choix
politiques qui seront faits et que nous
ne devons pas réduire justement la loi à
des faits très et heureusement dans
notre pays très circonscrit à des
réalités tout autant horribles qu'ils le
sont et je ne suis pas sûr que n'est pas
une loi de circonstance puisquelle a
déjà déjà prévue à l'avance donc je ne
feraai pas l'offense au gouvernement
d'avoir fait une loi de circonstance
mais je ne suis même pas certaine que
telle que rédigé aujourd'hui l'article 9
et 10 aurait empêché malheureusement ce
drame et donc je crois que nous avons un
vrai sujet qui est la question de
comment est-ce que en France et quel
rapport nous avons avec l'immigration et
avec les les S papiers qui travaillent
dans notre pays et et quel est l'autre
rapport qui est la sécurité la lutte
contre le radicalisme la lutte contre
les intégrismes au sens très large parce
que malheureusement d'ailleurs mais
aujourd'hui le radicalisme et
l'intégrisme n'est pas uniquement du
fait des étrangers dans notre pays et
donc cette problématique est beaucoup
plus complexe qu'une question de
nationalité ou de situation régulière ou
irrégulière dans notre pays un mot sur
l'accord politique que l'on voit se
dessiner entre le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale on a vu et bien
certain nombre d'amendements qui ont été
tricotés entre le gouvernement et la
majorité des accords entre les uns et
les autres est-ce que cela peut tenir
ensuite à l'Assemblée nationale où la
majorité n'est pas la même bah écoutez
je crois que nous aons nous aurons un
discours de vérité quand le texte
arrivera à l'Assemblée nationale nous
l'acterons et nous en tirerons les les
conséquences et notamment nous en
tirerons les conséquences parce qu'il y
aura-t-il ou n'y aura-t-il pas de
commission mixte paritaire et jusqu'où
effectivement ces recherches d'équilibre
au sein de la droite sénatoriale
continueront et seront-ils acceptter
après je je je crois que voilà le débat
législatif en tout cas est en cours en
tout état de cause ce texte aujourd'hui
va ressorti du Sénat avec une vision
beaucoup plus sécuritaire qui ne règle
rien et je le disais en la question de
la sécurité des habitants de notre pays
ni en la question de la régularisation
de ceux qui travaillent qui créent la
richesse au quotidien dans notre pays
bien merci beaucoup Cécile cucarman
d'avoir répondu à mes questions tout de
suite et bien retour dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat où se poursuivent les débats
autour du projet de loi immigration tout
étranger et de toute étrangère même si
ce dernier cette dernière na a priori
n'est a priori coupable d'aucun délit le
Conseil d'État et le Conseil
constitutionnel avait rappelé la
nécessité d'encadrer cette disposition
pour assurer un respect des libertés
publiques la commission des lois
elle-même une fois n'est pas coutume a
quand même cherché à atténuer le texte
en soustrayant notamment les mineurs de
13 ans à une telle innovation et en
rappelant la nécessité de la présence
d'un avocat lors du relever des
empreintes ou de la prise de
photographie mesdames et mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs aller
jusqu'au bout de cette volonté de
protection des droits en supprimant cet
article 11 merci madame
corbizo je demande l'avis de la
commission merci madame le Président
effectivement nous étions d'accord sur
la mesure proposée par le gouvernement
dans dans son projet de loi pour rendre
plus efficiente l'identification des
étrangersation régulières et euh cette
possibilité de prise d'empreinte par
coerition nous n'avons pas cherché à
atténuer mais nous avons cherché au
contraire à garantir cette possibilité
en tirant toutes les conséquences d'une
QPC qui a été posée et à laquelle le
Conseil constitutionnel a répondu le 23
février dernier et Monsieur baroch à
juste titre vous avez indiquer que
vous-même vous aviez fait une demande
similaire je vois que vous avez changé
d'avis pas nous notre avis est donc
défavorable bien avis du
gouvernement un avis évidemment
défavorable cette proposition du
gouvernement qui a modifié le la
Commission des des lois elle vise
évidemment à permettre l'identification
des personnes et s'il y a pas
d'identification des personnes il peut
pas y avoir évidemment éloignement parce
qu'on perd beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps et donc nous avons besoin de cette
identification d'ailleurs les sanctions
pénales qui sont prévues ne sont pas
assez dissuasives d'ailleurs c'est pour
cela que nous revenons avec cette cet
article que la commission des lois donc
a modifié juste pour dire à madame la
sénatrice à Monsieur benaroche que nous
ne sommes pas le seul pays à pouvoir
avoir cette coerition l'Autriche la
République tchèque l'Allemagne l'Italie
les Pays-Bas la Pologne la Slovaquie le
Royaume-Uni et la Norvège mais aussi la
Hongrie la Finlande la Croatie et
l'Estonie l'autorise donc je crois que
en fait c'est plutôt nous qui sommes
l'exception très bien donc je mets au
voix ces amendements avec deux avis
défavor ah pardon madame corbierne
amzo merci monsieur le ministre de nous
avoir énumérer ces pays moi je vous
invite à regarder aussi ce qui se passe
dans les territoires d'outrem sachez que
les étrangers sont aussi des étrangères
à la Réunion que elles arrivent sur le
territoire français parce que de bons
Français sont aller les chercher dans
leur pays le leur faisant miroir TM et
merveill les ont ramené en France les
ont maltraité les ont contraintes à la
clandestinité et ce sont ces personnes
qui seront donc dans l'illégalité qui
seront contrôlé et
fichées très bien merci je mets au voix
donc ces deux amendements de suppression
avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour leur
adoption qui est
contre
ah je vais être obligé de compter je
pense alors on va recommencer donc qui
est pour qui est pour leur adoption 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 23 qui est contre 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 23
24 il n'est pas adopté ils ne sont pas
adoptés merci amendement 11 recéctifier
monsieur la la pardon madame la
Présidente et nous interrompons quelques
instants cette séance alors que
discussion se poursuivent autour de ce
projet de loi immigration les sénateurs
en sont à l'article 11 et on va tout de
suite rejoindre Mathias SZ pour en
savoir un petit peu plus sur ce qui
vient d'être adopté il y a quelques
minutes oui c'est un c'est la fin d'un
gros volet fermetéin qui qui vient donc
de se de se clôturer entre les articles
9 et 10 c'est tout une série de
protection face à l'expulsion face à
l'émission d'obligation de quitter le
territoire pour des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui viennent
d'être levé des protections levées à
forciori quand les étrangers
représentent une menace pour l'ordre
public ou lorsqu'il ne respecte pas les
principes de la République voilà c'est
un c'est ce sont deux articles qui ont
été tricoté écrit réécrit parfois même à
quatre mains t entre le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale qui laisse
comprendre et bien qu'il y a un accord
apparent entre ces deux composantes ici
dans l'hémicycle du
sénatam merci merci beaucoup Mathias et
tout de suite on va rejoindre et bien
l'hémicycle du Sénat où les discussions
se poursuivent donc autour de l'article
11 très bien vous chipotez parce que
vous souhaitez qu'il souhaite
indiquer terme dans la mesure
strictement nécessaire alors que
nous-même nous avons écrit strictement
proportionné je pense que véritablement
votre amendement est satisfait et je
vous demande de le retirer à défaut ça
sera un avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement même avis monsieur law vous
êtes sollicité pour un retrait
je écoutez mon groupe veut le retrait
moi je ne veux pas donc je suivrai le le
groupe
RDSE donc est retiré mais je vais
peut-être vous laisser très bien je vais
peut-être vous laisser la parole pour le
suivant pour le 13
rectifié non c'est Monsieur massé madame
la Présidente dans la même veine
monsieur le ministre chers et chers
collègues cet amendement s'inscrit dans
la continuitité du précédent présenté
par mon ami Ahed il poursuit le même
objectif puisqu'il s'agit à nouveau
d'aligner le régime des étranger de la
prise d'empreunte par coerition à celui
qui existe déjà dans le cadre de la
procédure pénale en l'espèce il prévoit
que la prise d'empreunte par coer fasse
l'objet d'un procès verbal je crois que
ce n'est pas excessif de le demander dès
l'ors qu'un acte coercissif est réalisé
auprès d'une personne vous chipotez avec
l'avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur je ne peux pas le dire à
chaque fois madame le Président je vais
simplement dire qu'effectivement
l'établissement d' procès-verbal va de
soi dans ce type de contrôle il il sera
nécessairement procédé je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il faille euh le rajouter le
rajouter dans le texte pas plus que le
reste de l'amendement c'est un avis
défavorable très bien avis du
gouvernement même avis vous le maintenez
monsieur
massé il est
maintenu alors avec deux avis
défavorables je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté monsieur
benaroche pour le 271 monsieur ferernic
pardonnez-moi oui vous êtes pardonné
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues depuis la
fermeture des frontières intérieures
consécutives aux attentats de 2015 le
rôle de la police aux frontières
notamment à la frontière italienne s'est
considérablement accru incluant
notamment la gestion du flux migratoire
en provenance de l'Italie le
durcissement constant de la politique
migratoire et la pression des directives
assignées à la police aux frontières
entraîne de plus en plus d'irrégularités
dans le traitement des cas individuels
et notamment dans l'établissement des
décisions de refus d'entrée un certain
nombre de ces irrégularité ont été
documenté il appar il apparaît d' alors
de plus en plus indispensable que les
agents de la police au frontières comme
tous les agents de police et gendarmerie
nationale applique strictement
l'obligation de port visible de leur
immatriculation administrative
conformément à l'arrêté du 24 décembre
2013 les forces de l'ordre sont soumises
à l'obligation de porter leur Rio
référentiel des identités de
l'organisation lors de l'exercice de
leur mission depuis lors cette mesure
n'est que partiellement appliquée comme
la notamment doc documenter le Défenseur
des droits ainsi le 11 octobre dernier
le Conseil d'État ordonnait encore au
ministère de l'Intérieur de veiller à
l'application effective de cette
obligation pour les forces de l'ordre
dans son arrêté le Conseil d'État juge
que les dimensions actuelles du numéro
d'identification porté par les forces de
l'ordre sont inadaptés lors des
rassemblements il s'agit de favoriser
des relations de confiance entre les
forces de sécurité intérieure et la
population et d'assurer dans l'intérêt
de tous l'identification des agents
précise la juridiction qui enjoint que
ce num soit agrandi afin qu'il soit
suffisamment lisible en particulier
lorsque les forces de l'ordre
interviennent lors de rassemblement ou
d'attroupement le Conseil d'État a donné
12 mois au ministère pour se conformer à
sa décision cet amendement vise donc dès
l'adoption de la présente loi à
appliquer cette obligation aux agents de
la police au frontières dans l'objectif
de garantir une meilleure application
des droits des personnes migrantes
monsieur ferern avis de la
commission merci madame le Président
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
pourquoi ce serait même une demande de
retrait d'ailleurs parce que vous
l'indiquez vous-même dans votre
amendement il existe déjà une obligation
générale de porter ce numéro
d'immatriculation que le Conseil d'État
a estimé que cette obligation ne soit
pas bien décliné aujourd'hui c'est une
question
d'exécution de cette obligation mais
elle existe déjà et ce n'est pas la
répétant dans les textes qu'elle sera
correctement appliquée retrait ou avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre pour le
gouvernement même avis monsieur ferernic
vous êtes sollicité pour un
retrait
très bien donc je le mets au voix qui
avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'article 11 ainsi amendé qui est pour
l'article
11 qui s'abstient qui est contre
pardonnez-moi qui s'abstient il est
adopté à l'article 11 bis nous sommes
saisis de deux amendements identiques de
suppression le 215 porté par madame
madame
Daniel merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous demandons effectivement la
suppression de cet article 11 bis qui
prévoit d'alourdir les peines encourues
en cas de refus de se soumettre aux
opérations de relevé d'empreinte ceci
nous apparaît complètement superféatoire
puisque la peine actuellement encourue
est d'un an d'emprisonnement et de 15000
€ d'amende c'est loin d'être une peine
légère pour une infraction de ce type
vous en conviendrez nous serions
d'ailleurs intéressés de savoir les
peines effectivement prononcées pour ce
type d'infraction avant de décider s'il
est opportun de les réosser ou non par
ailleurs il nous semble un peu naïf de
penser qu'il suffirait de porter la
peine d'emprisonnement de 1 à 2 ans pour
mettre un terme au cas de refus
d'empreinte l'enjeu nous paraît
peut-être plus d'appliquer les sanction
à l'œuvre actuellement plutôt que de
chercher à reéhausser ses peines merci
Madame Daniel monsieur benaroche pour le
même amendement mais 289 oui tout à fait
c'est c'est également une suppression de
cette article 11 qui renforce comme ça a
été dit à l'instant les peines encouru
en cas de refus de prise d'emprinte
visant particulièrement les mineur
étrangers isolés cet article prévoit de
faire passer la peine d'emprisonnement
d'un à 2 ans en cas de refus de donner
ses
emprintes les mineurs isolés sont
souvent on l'a entendu quelquefois y
compris ici dans cette ence euh associé
à la délinquance alors qu'en fait il
s'agit d'enfants qui bien souvent sont
victimes de traite et sont contraints à
commettre des délits au lieu de les
protéger l'article 11 B prévoit le
renforcement des pines encouru en cas de
refus de donner ses empreintes si une
réponse à ce délit doit être apporté
cela doit se faire sous l'orle de la
protection et non consister en un
allongement de la peine d'emprisonnement
qui par ailleurs n'aura aucun effet
dissuasif sur le développement des
réseaux de trafic d'êtres humains
aggraver les peines de de prison pour un
tel refus nous paraît révélateur d'une
dérive vers une société de surveillance
où les données personnelles de mineurs
non modifiables dont le devenir est
incertain le présent amendement prévoit
donc la suppression de l'article 11 B
merci Monsieur benaroch avz de la
commission merci madame le Président la
Commission avait effectivement estimé
que cela pouvait être plus protecteur
pour les mineurs puisque vous savez que
les mineurs n'encourent que la moitié de
la peine et les réseaux peuvent être
tout à fait enclins de ce fait a
utiliser des mineurs c'est donc un avis
défavorable défavorable même avis du
gouvernement je mets au voie ces deux
amendements avec deux avis défavorable
monsieur
benaroche juste pour bien comprendre
madame la rapporteur vous semblez dire
qu'en fait le fait d'allonger les peines
pour les mineurs va dissuader les
réseaux de faire de la traite avec les
mineurs voudrais bien comprendre est-ce
que j'ai bien compris en
fait vous voulez répondre vous répondrez
plus tard en privé très bien alors je
mets au vo ces de oui monsieur le
ministre non plus d'accord je mets au
voix donc ces deux amendements avec deux
avis défavorables de la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
il qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés
[Musique]
oui monsieur le
ministre à la demande du ministre je
fais une pause de 2 minutes une
suspension de
séance
et voilà une petite suspension de séance
de 2 minutes est prévu à la demande du
ministre à la demande de Gérald
dararmanin cela alors que et bien nous
venons de voir également l'adoption de
l'article 11 l'article qui prévoit le
relevé des empreinte digitale et la
prise de photographie d'un étranger sans
son consentement voilà sur quoi portait
cet article mais auparavant et bien on a
également vu l'adoption d'un article de
deux articles importants les articles 9
et 10 et pour cela on va rejoindre
Mathias Arz qui nous attend dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat d'ù il suit et bien
toute cette séance Mathias deux articles
important je le disais viennent d'être
adopté tout à l'heure oui absolument
Tamin c'est la fin d'un gros volet
fermeté vous l'avez dit les articles 9
et 10 qui concernent toute une série de
levées de protection des protections
face à l'expulsion face à l'émission
également d'obligation de quitter le
territoire français c'est fameuse OQTF
pour des étrangers en situation
irrégulière voilà toute une série de
protection qui été visé par des
amendements des protections levées à
forciori quand les étrangers
représentent une menace pour l'ordre
public ou lorsqu'il ne respecte pas les
principes de la de la République on a vu
des articles des amendements tricotés
écrit réécrit parfois même à quatre
mains qui ont fait l'objet d'accord
entre le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale il y a eu un amendement
notamment qui a été retiré par Bruno
retaillot je vous propose d'écouter ces
explications les deux amendements que
j'ai porté sont très différents ils ne
concernent pas la même nature des actes
c'était les expulsions là il s'agit des
obligations de quitter le territoire il
ne concerne pas les mêmes publics ce ne
sont pas des gens qui ont été condamnés
ce sont surtout euh des irréguliers en
réalité des étrangers en situation
irrégulière et je voudrais dire pour
prévenir les préventions si j'ose dire
du du rapporteur que au regard de la
constitutionnalité on na pas du tout les
mêmes conséquences une expulsion le
recours n'est pas suspensif donc
évidemment la conséquence elle est grave
pour l'individu pour UNEF le recours est
suspensif donc il y a pas du tout du
tout la même gravité dans les
conséquence par conséquent je pense que
cet amendement devrait être voté voilà
c'est un président retaillot à la
manœuvre qu'on a vu travailler toute cet
après-midi parfois jouant des tours au
gouvernement à l'image de son amendement
qui a réécrit l'article 10 et au moment
de son adoption a fait tomber toute une
série d'amendements certains d'ailleurs
qui étaient porté par le gouvernement
Tam merci merci merci beaucoup Mathias
pour toutes ces explications et pour
revenir sur l'adoption de ces deux
articles importants articles 9 et 10
important sur ce volet fermeté et bien
bien nous sommes tout de suite avec
Roger carucci
bonjour Roger carucci votre réaction à
l'adoption de ces deux articles qui
facilitent bien la levée de protection
contre les mesures administratives
d'expulsion le prononcé de peine
judiciaire d'interdicition du territoire
français et également d'qtf d'obligation
de quitter le territoire français
c'était un peu une réponse notamment
disait gerérald harmanin après
l'attentat d'arastre oui c'est c'est pas
seulement une réponse après l'attentat
d' race c'est simplement de dire que
lorsque des étrangers notamment en
situation irrégulière commettent des
actes délictueux sur le territoire
national ou des crimes il faut
évidemment que nous ayons la capacité de
les expulser chacun se souvient de cette
situation aberrante où on nous a
expliqué que l'un des assassins était
arrivé sur les territoire français alors
qu'il avait moins de 13 ans et que par
conséquent on avavait pas pu l'expulser
par la suite quel que soit les les les
dél commis donc voilà vous dites qu'avec
les levé de protection là ça ne serait
pas
arrivé en tout cas serait pas arrivé
dans ce cas précis je dis pas que il y
en aurait pas eu en parallèle la la
protection absolue la sécurité absolue
ça n'existe pas mais en revanche il me
paraît normal et je pense que tous les
Français peuvent être d'accord sur le
fait de dire un étranger en situation
irrégulière qui commet des crimes et
deslits sur le territoire
national on ne peut décemment pas lui
accorder des protections telles qu'il
reste sur le territoire national par
conséquent il fallait prendre des
mesures oui d'éloignement et d'expulsion
on a entendu la gauche qui estime
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie par exemple
dès le premier jour des débats qui a dit
qu'il y avait une une
instrumentalisation de de ce drame de la
mort de Dominique Bernard en disant que
ce texte était une réponse qu'est-ce que
vous dites vous m dites que ce n'est pas
une une réponse forcment c'est
totalement faux parce que si vous
regarder les propositions d'amendements
ou de textes qui ont été fait par la
droite sénatoriale depuis 6 7 ans et
j'ai moi-même fait voter des amendements
sur un certain nombre de mesures il y a
déjà 45 ans par définition ça n'avait
rien à voir avec l'émotion du moment
mais nous sommes dans une situation plus
compliquée qu'autrefois et pas seulement
sur un attentat sur un meurtre mais sur
une situation où clairement depuis 7 ans
nous avons affaire au terrorisme
islamiste nous avons à faaire à un
certain nombre d'éléments que nous
n'avions pas autrefois et sur lesquels
il faut par conséquent réagirog carucci
le début de la semaine a été un petit
peu compliqué dans la majorité
sénatoriale entre LR et les centristes
sur les fameux articles 3 et 4 sur la
régularisation des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui occupent un
métier en tension bon on a vu un
amendement de compromis se dessiner ça
va laisser des traces quand même avec
vos alliés centristes je serais presque
tenté de dire l'inverse
euh le fait de ce qui ne vous tue pas
vous rend plus fort peut-être et en tout
cas ça nous a permis
d'approfondir de
voir combien la capacité de vouloir
maintenir la majorité sénatoriale
permettait à chacun d'aller vers l'autre
et de discuter nous n'étions pas
forcément d'accord sur un certain nombre
de rédactions pas tellement sur le fond
mais sur un certain nombre de formme là
nous avons de depuis mardi un débat
extrêmement apaisé interne à la majorité
sénatoriale qui fait bloc dans tous les
votes notamment dans les scrutins
publics par conséquent les choses se
passent au mieux la droite sénatoriale
aura durs renforcer toutes les mesures
de ce texte d'immigration dans l'unité
et c'est parfait toute dernière question
Roger carucci est-ce que vous pensez que
ces durcissements que vous avez adopté
vont pouvoir rester dans le texte final
car il va y avoir ensuite bien sûr la
navette et le passage à l'Assemblée
nationale alors tout va dépendre soit à
l'Assemblée
nationale les députés détricote le texte
du Sénat mais il y a pas de 493 au bout
par le gouvernement auquel cas il a une
commission mixte paritaire et dans la
commission mixte paritaire nous ferons
l'essentiel de nos efforts pour que
naturellement reviennent aux mesures
décidées par le Sénat si évidemment
c'est du 493 ce qui voudrait dire
d'ailleurs que pour le gouvernement
c'est le signe
que le gouvernement n'a pas trouvé de
majorité à l'Assemblée si c'est du 493
il y a pas de commission mixte paritaire
au quel cas bah on verra ce que le
gouvernement retient mais je pense
franchement dans le débat qu' un certain
nombre de mesures de renforcement qui
ont été y compris faites avec
l'assentiment du ministre après il faut
que le gouvernement manifeste son unité
jusqu'au bout on a entendu hein
plusieurs fois un des acccord
effectivement avec Gérald Darmanin qui
manifeste beaucoup d'accord avec la
majorité sénateur on l' encore entendu
aux questions d'actualité où sur l'aide
médicale d'État la réponse de la de la
première ministre n'était pas du tout
celle du ministre de l'Intérieur ah
peut-être qu'il va falloir qu'il voir
entre eux c'est ce que vous dites à
chacun ses négociations merci beaucoup
Roger d'avoir répondu à mes questions
tout de suite on reprend et bien la
direction de l'hémicycle les discussions
sont à présent sur l'article 11 TER de
ce projet de loi immigration le chapitre
des fichiers baroc cet article eff ement
est sans doute l'un des plus baroques de
de ce projet de loi je relis l'exposé
des motifs il s'agissait de créer un
fichier des mineurs étrangers condamnés
tout est faux dans cette présentation
d'abord ce fichier ne concerne pas les
mineurs étrangers il suffit de relire
cet article h TER ce fichier concerne
tout mineur privé temporairement ou
définitivement de la protection de sa
famille sans considération de sa
nationalité ce fichier inclurait donc
des mineurs de National
française on se demande donc ce que
cette disposition fait dans un code de
l'entrée et du séjour des étrangers et
du droit d'asile on se demande également
ce que cet article fait dans ce projet
de loi un fichier qui concerne les
mineurs français ou étrangers constitue
à l'évidence un cavalier législatif
deuxièmement ce fichier ne concerne pas
non plus des mineurs condamnés il suffit
de lire l'article et de relire l'article
11 ce fichier concernait ce je cite à
l'encontre desquels il existe des
indices graves ou concordants rendant
vraisemblabl vraisemblable qu'ils aient
pu participer comme auteur ou complice à
des infractions à la loi pénale ou
l'établissement d'un lien entre
plusieurs infractions commise par un
seul de ces mineurs c'est un fichier qui
est définitivement inutile il existe
déjà un fichier d'itage traitement des
antécédents judiciaires qui contient des
informations sur les personnes m en
cause y compris mineur comme auteur ou
complice d'un crime d'un délit ou de
certaines infractions de 5e classe soit
les troubles à la sécurité ou à la
tranquillité publique atteintte aux
personnes au bien ou à la sûreté de
l'État le bon sens mes chers collègues
vous invite à supprimer cet article
merci madame Danielle monsieur benaroche
pour le 190 oui c'est un article
également de c'est un amendement de
suppression de cet article
hostère qui a été introduit par la
commission des lois du Sénat et qui
prévoit la création d'un fichier
ressorant les mineurs non accompagné
deslcant comme ça a été expliqué encore
une fois avec cet article la majorité
sédatorial témoin de son intérêt très
sécuritaire en ce qui concerne
l'immigration les mineurs non
accompagnés son ai réduit à une seule
chose les délit qu'il pourrai commettre
sans jamais proposer de solutions pour
leur accueil leur insertion ou leur
prise en charge qui manque totalement
d'ailleurs dans ce dans les dans ce
projet de loi l'article prévoit
d'insturer un fichier mémorisant les
empreintes digitales et les
photographies des urs étrangers
condamnés à un panel très large
d'infraction pénale les auteurs du
présent amendement s'opposent à ce
nouveau fichage à cette vision
réductrice de l'immigration à cette
fuite en avant sécuritaire qui ne semble
avoir aucune limite au mépris d'un
certain nombre de valeurs d'accueil et
au mépris d'un certain nombre de
conventions internationales là encore
nous ne pouvons accepter cette dérive
vers une société de surveillance où les
données personnelles de mineurs non
modifiables seront stockés dans des
conditions d'utilisation et de
conservation qui ne ne sont pas encore
connu c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons
comme vous venez de le faire pour
l'article 11 bis de ne pas voter cet
article et de le supprimer merci
Monsieur benaroche avis de la
commission merci madame le Président ce
fichier qui a été voté par la commission
des lois il il émane d'un dispositif
proposé par une recommandation d'un
rapport que vous connaissez sans doute
puisquil date de 2021 c'est un rapport
qui avait été établi par nos collègues
Bourgi burgois yacovelli et le roi sur
les MNA et qui avait mis en avant un
constat qui était partagé qui
malheureusement est connu qui est la
délinquence associée aux jeunes en
errance elle est en forte augmentation
c'est ce que ce ce constat avait été
fait dans ce rapport et les forces de
l'ordre manquent d'outils adaptés pour y
faire face ce fichier peut permettre je
ne dis conviens pas qu'il soit
perfectible mais il peut peut permettre
effectivement de donner un outil utile
aux forces de l'ordre face à cette
difficulté qui est qui est grandissante
et et c'est pourquoi l'avis de la
commission est
défavorable merci Mad la rapporteur av
donc défavorable monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement même avis avis
défavorable monsieur le Président canner
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre on est là sur encore une fois
les porté par la droite sénatoriale
puisque vous savez qu'il y a un fichier
qui existe déjà sur les antécédents
judiciaires cet ajout ne sert à rien
sauf bien sûr à à marquer dans votre
positionnement et à créer un lien dans
la tête de nos concitoyens entre
délinquence et immigration c'est ça
devient obsessionnel chez vous
immigration égale délinquence égale
terrorisme et on peut continuer comme ça
longtemps ce fichier ne serait rien
d'autre qu'un au service de votre
idéologie particulièrement inquiétante
vous êtes dans une posture politicienne
qui devient je vous le dis très
inquiétante par rapport aux valeurs de
de notre République je vous rappelle que
nous parlons de mineurs nous parlons
d'enfants au lieu de les considérer
comme des enfants de la République vous
cherchez à les stigmatiser à les
cataloguer au lieu de penser finalement
à une meilleure protection une meilleure
intégration une meilleure formation de
meilleurs débouché vous souhaitez encore
une fois les rejeter et de de manière
vraiment obsessionnelle et caricaturale
et donc c'est pour cela que nous
soutiendrons les amendements présentés
par Madame de La Gonterie et Monsieur
benaroche très bien plus d'explication
de vote je vais donc mettre au voix ces
amendements je suis saisie d'un scrutin
public d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe les républicains le
scrutin est
ouvert voilà vous le voyez une demande
de SCR tin publ autour de cet article 11
ter du projet de loi
immigration cet article 11 c'est un
article qui a été ajouté en commission
c'est un amendement du sénateur les
républicains philippe Tabarot et qui
prévoit et bien la création d'un fichier
relatif aux personnes se déclarant
mineur et qui sont impliqué dans des
infractions à la loi pénale et vous
voyez et bien qu'il y a deux amendements
de suppression qui ont été défend dans
l'hémicycle l'un signé de Marie-Pierre
de la Gonterie socialiste et l'autre du
groupe écologiste de monsieur benaroche
qui tous deux s'opposent et bien la
création de ce fichier avec notamment
vous avez entendu à l'instant le
plaidoyer de Patrick caner qui a
considéré que on ne pouvait pas
considérer et bien ces personnes
autrement que comme des enfants il
s'agit effectivement de mineurs et que
il fallait donc les considérer autrement
que par la voix de la création de ce
fichier nous sommes donc toujours en
train de suivre ce projet de loi
immigration un petit point sur ce qui
s'est passé cet après-midi notamment et
bien l'adoption de deux articles
importants les articles 9 et 10 mais
tout de suite j'entends et bien que la
sonnerie retenti on va retourner en
séance pour écouter le résultat du
scrutin ne sont pas adoptés je vais
mettre au voix l'article 11 TER et je
suis saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les républicains le
scrutin est
ouvert et bien décidément le groupe les
républicains a voulu renforcer ses
arrières puisqu'il a demandé et bien un
double scrutin public l'un sur les
amendements de suppression amendements
qui vous l'avez vu n'ont pas été adoptés
des amendements de suppression qui a été
souhaité par la gauche les écologistes
et les socialistes et cette fois-ci à
nouveau une demande de scrutin
publque sur l'ensemble de cet article on
peut imaginer et bien que le résultat va
être en miroir je vous rappelle à
nouveau he ce que prévoit cet article 11
TER c'est-à-dire la création d'un
fichier relatif aux personnes se
déclarant mineur et impliqué dans des
infractions à la loi pénale sans doute
que et bien ce fichier la principe de ce
fichier va être adopté le scrutin vient
de se clore on va écouter tout de suite
Sophie prima résultat de ce scrutin
votant 341 exprimé 338 pour 205 contre
133 l'article est donc adopté nous
passons à l'examen des amendements sur
l'article 12 nous sommes saisis d'un
amendement 132 de Monsieur sourc qui
n'est pas là il n'est donc il tombe
ensuite quatre amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 182
présenté par Madame de La gontere par
Madame link
held L
pardon
madame merci madame la Présidente c'est
donc linken voilà Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs monsieur le ministre
notre notre amendement n'est pas
contrairement à celui qui n'a pas été
défendu à l'instant un amendement de
suppression mais un amendement plutôt
d'amélioration car nous sommes
finalement en faveur en tout cas
partiellement de de C article 12 que
nous que nous propose le gouvernement à
travers cet article 12 le le
gouvernement nous nous
dit le gouvernement nous dit qu'un qu'il
serait désormais interdit de placer un
un mineur de de de 16 ans dans un centre
de rétention administrative c'est
évidemment une bonne chose que de
proposer cela parce que la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
considère évidemment que tous les
enfants ont droit à la protection sans
exception mais ce que dit aussi la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant c'est qu'un enfant c'est un
mineur de 18 ans et notre amendement
vise tout simplement à proposer que on
interdise de placer non seulement les
mineurs de 16 ans mais tous les mineurs
donc les mineurs de 18 ans parce que ils
ont droit à cette protection d'autant
plus qu'on parle évidemment de mineurs
qui ont en général été confrontés à des
évén traumatisant et notre amendement
propose également que ce qu'on
appliquerait à un centre de rétention
administrative puisse évidemment
concerner tous les lieux de rétention
administrative donc y compris les autres
ces pièces dans un
commissariat un hôpital un hôtel que
tous ces endroits-là soient des endroits
où on ne peut pas placer un enfant de
mineur de 18 ans parce qu'il n'a rien à
y faire un enfant doit être protégé il
n'y a pas de raison de faire de
différence entre les ocutif les
expulsions et les CRA ou ou les LRA
c'est l'objet de cet amendement merci
chers collègues amendement 39 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur
brossa merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le le ministre je pense que
toute personne qui a qui a visité un un
centre de rétention administrative
admettra qu'il n'est pas acceptable que
des enfants puissent se retrouver en C
vus ce que sont les CV vu les conditions
dans lesquels euh les personnes y sont
retenues c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous portons cet amendement cet
amendement vise deux choses à l'image de
de celui qui a été présenté par Audrey
linconel à l'instant il vise d'abord à
faire en sorte que cette
interdiction de rétention pour les les
moins de 16 ans soit étendue à tous les
mineurs c'est-à-dire y compris à ceux
qui ont entre 16 et 18 ans je crois
d'ailleurs que c'est ce que prévoyait le
texte initialement prévu par le
gouvernement et
deuxièmement que cela concerne aussi les
LRA pas seulement les cras les locaux
adaptés de rétention administrative
parce que si on est contre la rétention
des enfants il faut aller jusqu'au bout
et c'est le sens de cet amendement
d'amélioration merci amendement 298
monsieur
benaroche merci madame la Présidente
c'est le même amendement de
de réécriture qui est proposé par mes
deux excellents collègues je rajouterai
qu'ayant visité l'espace de 3 ans un
grand nombre de cras de LRA de zon
d'attente et même de zones de mise à
l'abri d'ailleurs zones de mise à l'abri
qui sont en fait des ZES de rétention
comme le disent d'ailleurs les gens
eux-mêmes les fonctionnaires eux-mêmes
de police qui s'occupent des ZES de mise
à l'abri donc il faudra changer le
statut nous ne comprenons pas qu'on
puisse imaginer que il n'y ait pas de
dispositif d'interdiction de placement
dans ces lieux-là des mineurs des
mineurs c'est-àd des gens de moins de 18
ans et pas de moins de 16 ans de la même
façon d'ailleurs nous demandons à ce que
et nous souhaitons que les femmes
enceintes et les familles qui
accompagnent les mineurs ne puissent pas
être placé dans ces lieux il il convi il
convient de clarifier la rédaction de la
mesure afin de tenir compte de
l'ensemble des personnes présentant des
facteurs de vulnérabilité incompatibles
avec le placement en rétention
administrative on sait en plus d'autant
plus que le le les les G qui sont placés
dans ces CRAT aujourd'hui on assiste
quand même à une modification
substantielle c'est-à-dire qu'on trouve
essentiellement des gens qui sont
eux-mêmes déjà euh dans des parcours on
va dire judiciaires et donc c'est encore
plus euh malsin d'y placer des mineurs
entre 16 et 18 ans ou des femmes ancêes
euh il convient d'éviter que ces mineurs
et ces femmes et ces femmes ccêes il
convient de les préserver de la pque de
l'enfermement dans des centres dans ses
cras et dans ses aleras afin notamment
de leur éviter des ruptures dans leur
suivi périnatal par exemple pour les
femmes inses les conditions de détention
dans ces centres étant très détérioré et
matérialisé par une surveillance
policière constante ce qui se comprend
vu l'objet de ces lieux de
rétention merci Monsieur benaroche
amendement 7 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur
grosallet merci madame la
Présidente il est
d'usage dans les entreprises aujourd'hui
même dans nos collectivités de de
demander aux nouveaux agents au nouveaux
salariés un rapport d'étonnement alors
permettez-moi de m'étonner un peu en
tant que nouveau
sénateur que dans une enceinte aussi
prestigieuse il faille
rappeler des principes fondamentaux
élémentaires auxquels la France a
l'honneur de de se référer par exemple
la Convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant qui euh fait prévaloir
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant première
règle et puis la deuxième évidemment
j'avais cru comprendre puisque j'en ai
bénéficié quand j'étais jeune que l'âge
de la majorité était de 18 ans et donc
je suppose toujours que l'âge de la
minorité c'est 18 ans moins 1 jour voilà
tout cela pour dire que ça me paraît
totalement infondé et surtout en dehors
des grands principes de la France et de
la publi que de considérer qu'un jeune
de 16 à 18 ans ne serait plus un mineur
voilà tout simplement donc référons-nous
au principes de la République et nous
pourrons légiférer dans de bonnes
conditions merci merci Monsieur groval
l'avis de la commission sur ces quatre
amendements merci Madame le présidence
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
parce que nous estimons que dans
l'article 12 qui a été adopté par la
commission un équilibre a été trouvé
alors il a été trouvé sûrement d'une
façon qui qui vous tes déplaisante mais
l'équilibre est suivant aujourd'hui
encin je parle sous le contrôle de
Monsieur le Ministre car après tout cui
qui pilote cette politique nous trouvons
plus que des personnes qui créent un
trouble à l'ordre publ et qui en réalité
sont plus près de la délinquence que de
l'absence de titre de séjour et de ce
fait et bien on n'y met pas de jeunes
enfants
effectivement pour autant il convient
que le fait d'être dans une situation
irrégulière avec un mineur ne soit pas
un prétexte si je puux dire pour ne pas
pouvoir être éloigné du
territoire et de ce fait ces familles
sont placées dans des lieux de rétention
des LRA c'est un équilibre qui a été
trouvé de façon à faire respecter la loi
et nous souhaitons qu'il soit conservé
aVIS
défavorablefavorable Avis du
gouvernement merci je donneré un avis
favorable aux amendements de
l'ensemble de 182 à s rectifier Mme même
s'ils sont pas tous
identiques cependant dire quand même
deux choses c'est le gouvernement qui du
d'Emmanuel Macron qui vous propose le
fait qu'il n'y ait plus de mineurs dans
les centres de rétention administratif
donc moi j'entends les engagements pour
dire c'est c'est affreux tout le monde
l'a toujours dit la Convention
européenne mais c'est 1989 la Convention
européenne c'est un peu dommage que des
gouvernements non mais je je non mais je
remarque simplement que c'est un peu
dommage que les gouvernements lorsqu en
responsabilité neavaient jamais proposé
donc je je propose j'avais proposé 16
ans parce que évidemment je me doutais
que les parlementaires all 18 voilà
sinon c'est un sujet les LRA sont
aujourd'hui dans des commissariats pour
la plupart d'entre eux ils sont
effectivement dans un lieu qu'on
pourrait qualifier qui se rapproche du
carcéral et je pense que l'envie c'est
de pas le laisser ça dépend des LRA mais
c'est c'est en effet plutôt en moyenne
des choses qui se rapprochent du centre
de rétention administratif ils ont ce
site différent que dans les centres de
rétention administratif même si c'est
pas écrit dans la loi aujourd'hui je n
met je n y fais maître que des personnes
qui sont radicalisées ou qui sont des
personnes dangereuses donc ils ont
changé de typologie mais j'entends bien
l'argument j'ai une légère préférence
sur le set rectifieré bis de Monsieur
carer mais je veux bien qu'il y ait une
discussion sur l'ensemble des lieux de
rétention je veux
simplement madame carrière pardon
excusez-moi excusez-moi madame pardon je
commence un peu à fatiguer je vous prie
m'excuser je vous prie de m'excuser
madame la sénatrice euh oui oui oui mais
je je je j'étis en nu d'erreur comme
dirait voilà mon petit cousin euh juste
préciser que dans si vous adoptez ces
amendements quand vous dites pas de
mineurs de - 18 ans en rétention ça ne
veut pas dire les assignations à
résidence il y aura évidemment des
assignations à résidence avec des
mineurs que ce soit à leur domicile que
ce soit dans un hôtel sinon on on oublie
tout éloignement bon donc je qu'on soit
qu'on soit précis parce que je pense que
l'Assemblée nationale le sera que qu'il
n'y ait pas de difficulté entre nous il
faut évidemment qu'il y ait des
assignations à résidence dans dans un
hôtel dans un domicile pour pouvoir
éloigner les personnes puisque ce que
nous cherchons ici j'imagine dans chacun
de nos amendements ce n'est pas refuser
l'éloignement c'est ne pas le faire dans
un but traumatisant pour les enfants ou
les personnes qui ont moins de 18 ans
donc dans il compris l'amendement de
Madame de la Contrie qui est le plus je
crois extensif avec celui de Monsieur
brossa tous les mineurs de moins de 18
ans dans tous les lieux de Résid de
rétention ne concerne pas la signation à
résidence voilà jeis qu'on qu'on le soit
qu'on soit clair entre nous donc le
gouvernement soutient ces ces
amendements et si je voudrais dire ici
que s'il n'était pas adopté il proposera
sans doute avec la majorité
parlementaire de les établir à
l'Assemblée nationale merci Monsieur le
Ministre donc monsieur Durin a demandé
la parole oui non mais pour établir un
peu le la chronologie des faits
effectivement euh la gauche n'a pas mis
cette disposition en place lorsqu'elle
était au au pouvoir mais ici au Sénat on
a une position constante parce qu'on
pense que ce sujet est très important ma
collègue audrineel l'a très bien défendu
et dès le débat
avec la loi colon nous avions cette
position et quelques précurseur l'avait
défendu dès 2015 donc c'est une très
bonne nouvelle que cette défense très
bien monsieur
brossa merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre cela fait
maintenant des années que des
associations à très juste titre se
battent pour qu'il n'y ait plus
d'enfants en centre de rétention
administrative j'ai bien noté les
engagements que vous avez pris monsieur
le ministre et je veux dire que nous
sommes heureux qu'enfin on puisse en
finir avec la rétention d'enfants et en
CRRA et en LRA et je pense que ce serait
une bonne nouvelle et en tout cas ce
serait digne de notre
pays très bien plus d'intervention je
vais donc mettre au voix ces amendements
amendement 182 avec un avis défavorable
de la commission un avis favorable du
Gouvernement je suis saisie d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
les républicains le scrutin le scrutin
est
[Musique]
ouvert
et voilà vous le voyez une nouvelle
demande de scrutin public de la part du
groupe LR qui multiplie les demandes de
scrutin public actuellement nous sommes
sur l'article 12 qui porte sur
l'interdiction du placement en cras en
centre de réation de rétention
administrative des mineurs de 16 ans 16
ans c'est l'âge sur lequel et bien la
droite et le Centre ont réussi à trouver
un accord on a entendu la gauche hein
qui demandait et bien que cela soit les
mineurs ur de 18 ans moins un jour
également et bien on a entendu les
écologistes qui demandaient et bien que
les femmes enceintes soient également
concerné on va tout de suite voir le
résultat de ce scrutin public pour 138
contre 203 l'amendement est rejeté je
mets au voix l'amendement
39 je demande je mets au voix
l'amendement 39 rectifié avec un avis
défavorable de la
[Musique]
commission MP les demandes de scrutin
public c'est à cause de ce qui vient de
se passer à l'instant il y a quelques
minutes sur l'article 11 bis en effet
que s'est-il passé sur cet article 11
bis qui prévoyait et bien d'accroître
les sanctions en cas de refus de
décliner son identité ou de se soumettre
à une prise d'empreinte on a vu et bien
la gauche avait porté des amendements de
suppression ces amendements n'ont pas
été adoptés mais finalement contre toute
attente l' article a tout de même été
rejeté et bien oui parce que et bien la
gauche était quand même plus nombreuse
dans l'hémicycle je suis avec Karine
Daniel pour parler et bien de ce qui
s'est passé tout à l'heure c'était un
peu surprenant une victoire de la gauche
assez inattendue dans cette séquence
alors il faut d'abord apprécier chaque
petite victoire dans ce contexte et dans
la la dureté de de ce projet de loi qui
nous est proposé cette semaine
effectivement l'article en question a a
été rejeté même si les les amendements
de de suppression ne ne l'avaient pas
été ça montre que il y a aussi une
certaine un certain inconfort de la
droite sur ces sujets qui touchent aux
droits les plus fondamentaux pour les
mineurs pour les enfants pour toutes les
personnes au-delà de de de des
considérations strictement sécuritaires
oui on a entendu notamment le pldoyer
tout à l'heure de Patrick caner pour
dire qu'il fallait considérer ces
mineurs comme des enfants et pas comme
simplement des délinquants ou des
délinquants potentiels notamment et bien
lorsqu' a été acté ensuite la création
d'un fichier relatif aux personnes se
déclarant mineur et impliqué dans des
infractions à la loi pénale euh mais
vous sentez que cette voix tout de même
elle est peu entendue aujourd'hui par la
majorité sénatoriale bien sûr mais il
faut retrouver une forme de rationalité
on parle d'un fichier qui est hors de
propos par rapport à ce projet de loi ce
fichier il mélangerait des mineurs
étrangers et des mineurs français des
mineurs qui sont de nationalité
française non pas sur des commis sur des
crimes ou des délits commis mais sur des
parfois des présomptions donc là on est
dans une dérive qui va au-delà du
raisonnable qui flatte probablement une
dérive à droite et à l'extrême droite
dans l'examen de ce texte mais il faut
et nous on a à cœur de ramener un peu de
de raison de rationalité et d'humanité
dans ce texte parce que c'est c'est la
voix qu'on comporte dans dans ce moment
politique de cet examen de de projet de
loi vous estimez qu'il y a une dérive à
l'extrême droite dans ce texte on voit
pourtant les amendements et bien des
sénateurs RN ou reconquête qui sont
rejetés les uns après les autres et
plutôt des accords entre le gouvernement
et la majorité de la droite et du centre
oui mais ces accords se font sur un
baricentre qui penche de plus en plus
vers la droite là on attaque sur la
question des mineurs on on remet où on
discute des questions fondamentales
autour du droit du sol on a quand même
eu la séquence de de remise en cause de
l'aide médical d'État qui pour nous est
un transformé en aide médicale d'urgence
on rappelle avec un panier de soin plus
rest où on sait qu'il faut il vaut mieux
faire de la prévention pour soigner les
malades ça coûte moins cher au régime
d'assurance sociale que de traiter les
maladies quand elles arrivent de manière
plus dégradée et plus plus difficile
pour les gens et et c'est pas du tout
tout et c'est aussi un enjeu de santé
publique puisque pour les maladies
contagieuses si on laisse les gens dans
la circu en circulation qui ne sont pas
soignés il y aura des principes de
contagion qui coûteront de faites plus
au système de sécurité sociale vous avez
entendu ellisabeth born notamment hier
lors de la séance de question au
gouvernement elle a été interpellée sur
le sujet elle dit attendre le rapport
evvin stéphanini mais qui a déjà fuité
dans la presse et qui dit qu'il faut
garder l'aide médicale d'État il y a
quand même peu de chance pour ça reste
au final dans le texte vous en bien sûr
et heureusement et heureusement mais
heureusement et ça montrait bien
l'inconfort du gouvernement cette
réponse qui était sur le fil de de
Madame la première- Ministre à la
question au gouvernement de de Patrick
canner ça montrait bien cet inconfort et
le caractère ubesque de cette
suppression qui va et et je tiens à
souligner la mobilisation des
association de solidarité des médecins
qui sont nombreux à dire que supprimer
cette aide médicale d'État est une
erreur fondamentale un mot également sur
l'adoption de deux articles importants
cet après-midi les articles 9 et 10 qui
ont été présenté comme des formes de
réponse he par gerérald Darmanin après
l'attentat d'aras puisque il lève un
certain nombre de protections contre des
mesures administratives d'expulsion le
prononcer de d'interdiction de du
territoire français ou encore
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français lorsque le comportement de la
personne constitue une menace grave pour
l'ordre public est-ce que vous inspire
ces mesures sont-elles des mesures qui
permettent de protéger les Français
aujourd'hui et bien face à cette menace
que peuvent représenter les étrangers
c'est ainsi que c'est présenté par le
gouvernement tout d'abord il faut avoir
un peu de modestie puisque ce texte
était présenté avant les événements
d'aras donc
l'utilisation de cette de cet événement
malheureux et et et est un peu
anachronique et et déplacé mais on
comprend
l'opportunitéentalisation en T les cas
on peut on peut s'interroger et et nous
là encore on dit utilisons les
dispositifs qui existent déjà donnons
les moyens aux forces de police et de
justice d'appliquer ce qui existe déjà
et et nous aurons déjà fait des progrès
dans ce domaine et bien merci merci
beaucoup karineal d'avoir répondu à mes
questions on va tout de suite reprendre
et bien la direction de l'hémicycle où
les débat se poursuivre et c'est gu
benaroche sénateur écologiste qui est
actuellement en train de s'exprimer ferm
des mineurs au cours des procédures de
reconduite à la frontière la France a
été condamnée pour la 9e fois par le
cadh dans un arrêt du 31 mars 2022 qui a
condamné l'administration française pour
sa politique d'enfermement des
enfants merci Monsieur benaroch avis de
la commission défavorable madame le
Président avis du
gouvernement favorable très bien pas de
oui monsieur
Baroche j' pas terminé madame la
Présidente commmoi non mais si j'avais
terminé mais 2 minutes mais j'avais pas
fini de parler donc je prends
l'explication de vot pour terminer si
vous le permettez ma démonstration la
présente mesure circonscrit
l'interdiction au mineurs de mois de 16
ans sans que cela soit justifié pour
Rael et la Convention relative au droit
de l'enfant de New York ratifié par la
France ratifié par la France s'applique
pour les mineurs jusqu'à leur 18 ans
quel que soit son âge un enfant ou un
adolescent subit les conséquences
dramatiques de l'enfermement sur sa
santé
repli sur soi refus de s'alimenter
insomni angoisse à cela s'ajoutent des
facteurs de vulnérabilité tels que la
situation familial les parcours
migratoires chaotiques et le stress
post-traumatique il est donc impératif
nous
semble-t-il que nous soyons tous
d'accord et je ne comprendrai pas que
certains d'entre nous ne l'approuvent
pas pour l'interdiction du placement en
CR pour l'ensemble des mineurs de 0 à 18
ans très bien monsieur benaroch plus
d'autres explication de
vote donc avis défavorable de la
commission avis favorable du
Gouvernement je mets au voix cet
amendement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté deux amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 183 présenté
par Madame conou
Mor
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
c'est un amendement de
repli puisqueà défaut d'interdire le
placement en en rétention pardon des
mineurs de 18 ans nous proposons que
l'interdiction en rétention des mineurs
de 16 ans s'applique pour les centres de
rétention administrative mais également
pour les locaux de rétention
administrative si nous interdisons le
placement en cras des mineurs de 16 ans
sans interdire également le placement à
LRA nous nous serons donn bon bonne
conscience mais nous nous serons prêtés
à un jeu de dupe en pratique le
placement LRA se substituera au
placement encra non seulement nous
n'aurons pas progressé mais sans doute
même reculé puisque les LRA sont
nettement moins encadré et présentent
des garanties nettement inférieures à
celles des cras à titre d'exemple dans
les locaux de rétention administrative
il n'est notamment pas prévu qu'une
association pour l'aide à l'exercice
effectif des droits puisse intervenir il
n'y a pas non plus d'unité médicale ce
qui est particulièrement problématique
au regard de la vulnérabilité des
familles avec des enfants enfermés merci
Madame la Ministre amendement 299
présenté par Monsieur Baroche merci
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
similaire à celui qui vient être défendu
puisque l'article 10 ne concerne que
l'interdiction de placement en centre de
rétention administrative et exclus donc
explicitement les locaux de rétention
administrative aux abords des frontières
et dans les zones d'attente LRA dans les
LRA les associations d'aide à l'accès au
droit et le personnel médical ne sont
même pas présents contrairement au cras
lorsqu'ils font l'objet d'un refus
d'entré aux frontières françaises les
enfants les familles avec enfants ainsi
que les mineurs non accompagnés peuvent
être placés dans des zones d'attente
pour des durées allant jusqu'à 20 jours
zone d'attente de l'océan de Viking zone
d'attente à or zone d'attente à Marignan
j'en ai visité plusieurs personnellement
en 2021 d'après les statistiques de la
police aux frontières au moins 372
enfants ont été placés en zone d'attente
les conditions de maintien dans ces
zones d'attente ne sont pas plus
favorables qu'on CR l'enfant n est pas
correctement pris en charge ni en
sécurité au quotidien dans ces lieu
d'enfermement les enfants sont
confrontés à des événements
traumatisants et évoluent dans un
environnement d'une extrême violence j'y
rajouterai après mon expérience
personnel à Nice dans un lieu de mise à
l'abri à la frontière italienne qu'il en
est de même dans ces lieux qui sont de
véritable lieu de rétention également le
placement des mineurs non accompagnés
particulièrement visé par le comité des
droits de l'enfant ce dernier recommande
à la France d'adopter les mesures
nécessaires pour éviter le placement
d'enfants en rétention dans les zones
d'attente en redoublant d'effort pour
trouver des solutions adéquates de
substitution à la privation de liberté
et pour assurer aux enfants un
hébergement adapté et respecter
pleinement les obligations de
nonreoulement il est ainsi impératif que
le gouvernement prenne des mesures
alternatives à l'égard des familles
accompagnant de mineurs ainsi qu'à
l'écart des mineurs non
accompagnés monsieur bénaroch avis de la
commission pour les motifs évoqués
précédemment avis défavorable avis de la
commission euh pardon du gouvernement
pardonnez-moi jeis je veux bienvenir à
la commission des Lois du Sénat madame
la
Présidente euh non inf favorable pour
celui de Madame de La Gonterie en
cohérence de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure un défavorable sur monsieur
benardoch non pas par principe mais
parce que vous y rajoutez les zones
d'attente c'est pas les mêmes types de
rétention puisqu'il faut bien des
endroits pour qu'on vérifie les
identités pour qu'on passe un certain
nombre d'examens je pense au zone
d'attente imaginons qu'un qu'un bateau
d'une ONG arrive sur une côte
méditerranéenne il faut bien que l'on
crée un endroit où on puisse en effet
garder mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un
centre de rétention administratif ce qui
gêne dans le centre de rétention
administratif c'est pas le fait qu'on
vérifie l'identité qu'on puisse éloigner
les gens c'est que c'est carcérale c'est
pas le cas de la zone d'attente en
moyenne même si effectivement il peut y
avoir des endroits où on vérifie euh on
peut avoir une amélioration notamment
dans des vieilles structures
aéroportuaires ou ou portuaires je je ne
dis conviens pas mais c'est pas la même
chose que le CR du mini namel de Vincen
je pour pas pas le comparer donc voilà
c'est un avis
défavorable non on on est d'accord donc
donc donc on voilà donc c'est un avis
défavorable non pas sur le principe vous
avez compris que j'étais favorable à ces
dispositif puisque je les propose mais
je peux pas donner un avis favorable sur
le vôre en tout cas il faudrait qu'on le
travaille bien plus et
euh voilà puisque j'ai le 596 c'est
après VO c'est ça c'est après très bien
je vais mettre au vote ces amendements
amendement
1883 avec un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis favorable du
Gouvernement demande de scrutin public
par le groupe les républicain le scrutin
est
ouvert et vous le voyez et bien les
scrutins public se succèd euh autour et
bien de ce projet de immigration que
nous suivons en direct dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat les sénateurs sont en train de
débattre de l'interdiction du placement
en centre de rétention de mineurs il y a
eu des débats déjà pour savoir et bien
qu'est-ce que l'on pouvait considérer
comme un mineur puisque la Commission
s'est mise d'accord pour interdire la
présence en centre de rétention de
mineurs de 16 ans tout de suite le
scrutin public est clos on va écouter
342 pour 138 contre 204 l'amendement
n'est pas adopté amendement 280 avis
défavorable du gouvernement et de la
Commission demande de scrutin public par
le groupe les républicains le scrutin
est
ouvert et voilà encore une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement de la
gauche alors qu'est-ce qui explique ces
recours frénétiques au scrutin public à
la demande du groupe LR c'est que tout à
l'heure il y a eu une surprise puisque
sur l'article 11 bis qui pourtant avait
vu ces deux amendements de suppression
rejetés par le Sénat et bien l'article
en lui-même a tout de même été rejeté et
bien parce que les voix de droite et du
centre n'étaient pas assez importantes
le scrutin est clos on va aller écouter
tout de suite le résultat de résultat du
vote sur cet amendement votant 341
exprimé 341 pour 137 contre 204
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous avons
ensuite quatre amendements en discussion
commune le 596 du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
c'est un amendement important pour le
fonctionnement des des centres de
rétention administratif pourquoi parce
que vous aurez compris que en tout cas
depuis que j'ai l'honneur d'être
ministre de l'intérieur j'ai décidé de
ne plus mettre de mineur dans les
centres de rétention administratif je
mets maot mis à part ça correspond
évidemment à un autre fonctionnement
parce que nous y mettons désormais c'est
la politique que je mne au ministère de
l'Intérieur les personnes qui sont soit
radicalisées fichers
soit qui ce qu'on appelle dans notre
langage des top des personnes qui sont
dangereuses soit parce qu'elles ont été
condamnées à des peine de prison très
lourde soit parce qu'elles sont accusées
de fait par la police elle-même donc on
a changé la sociologie des personnes qui
sont dans les centres de rétention
administratif nous n'y avons plus
désormais d'enfants je l'ai dit très
très peu de femmes moins de 3 % et
désormais la quasi intégralité de ces
personnes sont des personnes dans ere
d'ailleurs ça fonctionne dans les
chiffres de la délinquence puisque je
viens de recevoir justement dans les 10
premiers mois de l'année sur la part des
étrangers mis en cause dans les faits
délictuels et criminels sur les 10
derniers mois de l'année désormais cette
part est à 37 56 % soit quasiment 4
points de moins par rapport à la période
de 2022 puisqueà l'époque elle s'élevait
à 41,43 % et cette baisse est
particulièrement vrai à Paris où le
recul est de 7 points pour atteindre 41
% contre 48 % en 2022 il faut savoir que
que Paris et l'île-de-fance c'est
quasiment 50 % de la délinquance de
l'ensemble du territoire national donc
le fait de concentrer notre action
contre les délinquants étrangers et de
les placer systématiquement dans les
centres de rétention administratif
fonctionne fonctionne parce que ça
permet d'avoir une sociologie différente
dans les cras et fonctionne parce que ça
baisse en effet les chiffres de la
délinquence puisque sontvent souvent les
mêmes récidivistes chacun le sait une
fois que je vous ai dit ça je ne suis
pas tout à fait je suis sûr que la Haute
Assemblée m'écoute au moment où je parle
mais en tout cas je l'aurais dit pour
sans
doute une thèse une thèse d'histoire
parlementaire dans 45 ans euh une fois
que j'ai une fois que j'ai cependant dit
ça je j'attire l'attention donc de non
seulement donc j'ai essayé de vous
prouver de l'efficacité et l'humanisme
l'action du gouvernementale dans la
baisse de la délinquance mais par
ailleurs de mettre désormais dans les
critères de l'autorisation faite par
l'action administrative de mettre
quelqu'un dans un CRAL le fait qu'il est
particulièrement dangereux puisque c'est
désormais les personnes que nous mettons
dans les cras afin qu'effectivement on
puisse prendre en considération cela
lorsqu'il y a d'éventuels recours
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de critère de
dangerosité des personnes qu'on met dans
les centres de rétention administratif
ce qui pose évidemment des difficultés
lorsqu'ils sont relâchés parce
qu'évidemment c'est pas la même chose
quand quelqu'un est relâché parce qu'on
peut pas l'éloigner ou quelqu'un qui est
très dangereux qu'on a relâché parce
qu'on a des difficultés à l'éloigner
chacun je crois le comprend et c'est
assez équilibré par rapport à la
proposition que je vous ai faite que
d'interdiction des mineurs dans lescas
la contrepartie qui est pas de mineur
dans les cras c'est qu'on y met des gens
dangereux la contrepartie d'y mettre des
gens dangereux c'est évidemment qu'on
prenne le critère de dangerosité pour
les mettre dans les cras donc c'est un
amement très important et je voudrais
ici madame la Présidente penser aux
policiers de la police aux frontières
qui font un travail difficile puisque
quand on change la sociologie des
personnes qui sont dans les cras ils ont
évidemment plus de difficultés à tenir
évidemment ces personnes dans un endroit
qui n'est pas drôle c'est vrai mais
c'est pas drôle non plus pour les
fonctionnaires de police merci Monsieur
le Ministre avis de la commission sur
l'AM du
gouvernement ah pardon ils sont en
discussion commune excusez-moi
pardonnez-moi 333 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur Dosu merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre bon j'étais
attentif à ce que vous venez de raconter
et je ne partage pas votre vos
raccourcis sur la baisse de la
délinquence les délinquentss étrangers
c'est je je je vous les
laisse enfin il y a pas c'est pas parce
que la délinquence baisse et que à côté
vous enfermez des étrangers qu'il y a un
lien évident entre les
deux très bien mais là on va parler
rétention administrative
et je pense que ce régime de de
privation de liberté mériterait
peut-être une réforme plus globale que
ce que vous êtes en train de faire un
peu à la hussard en changeant de
sociologie à l'intérieur de ces centres
de rétention et en changeant
effectivement l'ambiance puisqu'on voit
une montée de violence dans les centres
de rétention avec parfois des agents
vous l'avez dit de la police aux
frontières qui ne sont pas forcément
formés comme les agents de la
pénitentiaire et donc peut-être pas apte
à gérer les populations qui sont
enfermées et privées de liberté et et
donc on a dans les des centres de
rétention qui change de physionomie mais
moi je voulais revenir sur cette
politique de rétention administrative et
la l'allongement de la durée de
rétention qu'on a eu qu'on a observé
pendant la suite à la loi colon et qu'on
a jamais vraiment évalué alors que le
taux de de d'éloignement est toujours en
dessous des 50 % dans les centres de
rétention et le niveau de violence a
monté les rapports de la CGLPL de donc
de la contrôleuse des lieux de privation
liberté s'accumule pour dire que c'est
de plus en plus indigne les conditions
de vie dans les centres de rétention y
compris dans les nouveaux qui même le
nouveau centre de Lyon qui doit servir
de modèle au fut au futur site de de de
au futur place et au futur centre de
rétention et là-dessus pointé dans le
dernier rapport pour être
particulièrement indigne et donc nous je
vous propose ose donc de revenir à à une
un régime de rétention qui prévalait
avant la loi colon c'est-à-dire 30 jours
de supprimer la 2è période de 30 jours
et et donc de de porter la durée
maximale de rétention à 60 au lieu de 90
aujourd'hui merci Monsieur Dosu
amendement 187 présenté par Monsieur
Durin merci madame la Présidente la loi
du 10 septembre 2018 apporter le délai
maximal de rétention de 45 à 90 jours
l'argument qui soutendait cette mesure
était de dire que cela laisser serait le
temps nécessaire pour obtenir les
laisser passer consulaires et donc
permettrait d'éloigner en proportion un
plus grand nombre d'étrangers retenus
bilan 2016-207 le taux moyen de qtf
exécuté 14 %. 2019 le taux chute à 12,2
%. suivent 2 année covid où le taux
chute à 5 6 %. s'agissant du taux
d'éloignement à l'issue d'un placement
encra il est également en baisse depuis
2019 donc depuis que la durée de
rétention à 90 jours est possible de 50
% en 2019 il est passé à 43,2 % en 2022
si 43,2 % des étrangers qui sont retenus
sont au final effectivement éloignés à
l'issue de leur placement en CRRA cela
signifie que plus de la moitié des
étrangers qui sont retenus en cras ne
sont pas éloignés et sont finalement
libéré c'est-à-dire que des individus
ont été enfermés par pure perte puisque
la seule raison qui pouvait motiver leur
enfermement à savoir l'éloignement n'a
pas été accompli le rapport du président
buffet lui-même de mai 2022 sur la
question migratoire admettez que dans la
pratique les effets de cette
prolongation sur les éements sont réels
mais
modestes ainsi sur l'année 2019 dernière
année de référence avant la pandémie 826
étrangers en situations irrégulièr ont
été éloigné au-delà du 45e jour de
rétention ce qui représente une
proportion de 8,28 % des éloignés si le
gouvernement avait remis au Parlement le
rapport annuel sur l'immigration comme
la loi lui fait obligation nous
disposerions sans doute de chiffre
actualisé en tout état de cause le délai
maximal de rétention serait utile
puisqu'il permettrait d'éloigner des
étrangers au-delà de 45 jours qu'est-ce
qui permet d'affirmer que c'est la
rétention qui a permis l'éloignement de
ces étrangers si 800 étrangers ont été
éloignés au-delà de 45 jours quelle part
représente-t-il parmi les étrangers qui
ont été retenus audelà de 45 jours il y
a donc plus de 70 % des étrangers
retenus entre 45 et 90 jours qui
l'auront été pour rien puisqu'ils
n'auront pas été éloignés merci Monsieur
Durin l' amendement 547 n'est pas
défendu je vais donc demander l'avis
cette fois-ci de la commission madame la
rapporteur merci madame le Président la
commission est favorable à l'amendement
du Gouvernement et défavorable aux deux
amendements suivants qui tentent à
réduire le délai de rétention nous
estimons que le délai actuel de 90 jours
est un équilibre qui d'ailleurs é
approuvé par le Conseil constitutionnel
merci Madame la rapporteur avis du
gouvernement sur le 333 et le
187 moi je je voudrais dire que j'ai du
mal à comprendre le raisonnement de
Monsieur Dosu sauf à être absolument
mais il est parti j'imagine maintenant
sauf à être bon je vais lui répondre
mais de là où il est il va m'entendre
sauf à être particulièrement opposé par
principe au contrôle d'identité au fait
que les étrangers doivent quitter le
territoire quand ils sont irréguliers
même lorsqu'ils sont très dangereux et
donc à ne pas les enfermer dans dans
centre de rétention je suis en train de
vous expliquer que nous avons changé de
fonctionnement pour la rétention nous
mettons dans dans les centres de
rétention aujourd'hui les 1300 places il
y en avait 900 quand je suis arrivé au
ministère d' l'intérieur il y en a 1300
aujourd'hui il y en aura 3000 grâce à la
loi de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur en 2027 nous sommes en train
de changer la sociologie des personnes
qui sont les centes de rétention parce
que justement comme le dit Monsieur
Durin c'est effectivement une privation
de liberté personne n'en dis qu'bien qui
correspond à des critères particuliers
et qu'on doit faire ça avec une main
tremblante parce que nous y mettons les
personnes dangereuses pour l'ordre
public voilà donc aujourd'hui les
personnes qui sont dans les cras hors
maotte pour des raisons qu'on connaît
sont des personnes soit radicalisées
soit dangereuses il n'y a plus d'enfants
avant même que la loi ne soit votée et
il y a moins de 2 % de femmes bien et
quand elles le sont ce sont des femmes
qui ont commis des actes de grande
dangerosité ou qui sont elles-mêmes
radicalisées donc quand nous les mettons
en centre de rétention c'est que nous
concentrons les les le travail de la
police et du ministère des Affaires
étrangères pour identifier les personnes
parce que vous vous mettez des gens dans
un centre de rétention pour dire cette
personne a déclaré par exemple qu' était
de telle nationalité elle dit qu'elle ne
l'est pas vous demandez à une mission de
reconnaissance de tel ou tel pays de
venir rencontrer cette personne pour
voir si l'accent est le bon si les coup
de fil qu'il a passé sont dans tel ou
tel pays il lui pose des questions de
savoir s'il est vraiment de ce pays pour
qu'on essayent d'identifier les
personnes évidemment essayent de tricher
pour ne pas repartir dans leur pays et
je ne peux pas renvoyer dans un pays x
un ressentissant d'un pays y chacun le
comprend parce qu'évidemment sinon je
n'ai pas le laissé passer consulaire on
considère que les services français ne
sont pas capable de faire ce travail
donc il est très important de mettre
dans les centres de rétention
administratif des gens qui en effet
doivent être sous la main du ministère
de l'Intérieur pour pouvoir pouvoir
contrôler leur identité expressis verbis
pour pouvoir vérifier celle-ci pour
obtenir le laisser passer consulaire
donct je rappelle au parlementaires
qu'il est délivré que pour quelques
jours un laisser passer consulaire que
vous obtenez d'un pays c'est pour
quelques jours c'est pas aDVITAM et si
vous n'avez pas quelqu'un sous la main
et ben vous ne pouvez pas le renvoyer et
parfois on dit bah voilà le tel pays
nous a donné la passé consulaire on l'a
pas renvoyé bah oui parce qu'on l'
trouvé 35 jours après laisser passer
consulaire et que le laisser passer
consulaire était aujourd'hui de 30 jours
bref tout ça pour vous dire que ces
centres de rétention ils sont normales
classiques et ils permettent l'action de
la police c'est pour ça qu'on imet des
gens dangereux aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
bien compris comme dirait monsieur Durin
que oui nous les privons de liberté et
donc quand nous voyons qu'il y a une
part très importante de délinquants
étrangers
multirécidivistes qui commettent des
actes de délinquence qui atte entre 30
et 50 % des crimes et déles sur certains
territoires et que nous avons placé
depuis 1 an que des personnes
dangereuses donc nous les empêchons
évidemment de commettre C récidif
pendant qu'ils sont dans les centres de
rétention et nous obtenons leur
explulion parce que je veux dire à
Monsieur Durin que oui bien sûr c'est
pas 100 % des personnes qui sont expulsé
ou loigné qui sont dans les cras mais
c'est quand même 40 % de plus que ceux
qui ne sont pas dans les cras ce qui
montre l'efficacité malgré tout Descas
et je suis d'accord qu'il faut encore
améliorer les choses je reviendrai sur
votre amendement monsieur Durin il est
évident que cette mesure correspond à ce
que vous devriez défendre collectivement
l'étranger qui est certes irrégulier
mais qui ne connaît aucun acte de
délinquence doit pouvoir être
raccompagné dans son pays mais sans
passer par un centre de rétention et
puis l'étranger qui commet des actes de
délinquence lui il doit aller dans le
centre de rétention parce que c'est lui
qu'on doit éloigner en premier sinon je
vais faire ce qu'on fait tous les
ministres de l'intérieur avant moi vous
mettez des personnes dans centre de
rétention administratif qui ne pose pas
de problème pour l'ordre public c'est
plus facile à éloigner parce que pour un
pays c'est plus facile d'obtenir un
irrégulier qui ne pose pas de problème
que quand je leur envoie des gens qui
posent des problèmes parce qu'il posent
évidemment des questions c'est comme
quand les États étrangers me disent on
va vous renvoyer un Français qui est
tueur je prends du temps avant de dire
oui je vérifie qu'il est bien français
c'est normal j'essaie de protéger mon
pays donc je comprends pas cette ce
raisonnement de monsieur dosus qui me
paraît en fait être contre tout et qui
ne comprend pas me semble-t-il la
volonté du gouvernement de protéger nos
compatriotes ça à vouloir pas protéger
nos compatriotes et à régulariser les
étrang les étrangers délinquants qui ont
commis des crimes ou qui sont
radicalisés pour la la l'intervention de
Monsieur Durin qui évidemment comme à
son habitude et à la fois plus
raisonnable évidemment est se comprend
dans dans son argumentation je ne peux
pas être d'accord pourquoi parce que les
chiffres que vous prenez de libération
avant la date fatidique si jeose dire
d'abord prend les chiffres du covid bon
donc évidemment c'est pas très
raisonnable monsieur Durin et
deuxièmement vous faites semblant de
croire pas voir Monsieur Durin qu'il a
pendant ce temps-là une crise des visas
que nous avons eu avec la plupart des
États qui avec lequel nous avions des
personnes qui étaient dans les centres
de rétention administrative les trois
pays du Maghreb c'est 70 % des gens qui
sont dans l'écas donc quand il y a plus
de laisser passer consulaire du tout en
Algérie au Maroc ou en Tunisie du fait
du rapport de force qu' a installé le
président de la République et voilà un
an et demi bah il est évident que le
juge des liberté de la détention
qu'est-ce qu'il regarde il regarde pas
la dangerosité ça c'est l'amendement que
je je vais vous faire adopter je
l'espère en 596 il regarde si un il y a
pas nulité de la procédure s'il y a pas
quelqu'un qui a oublié un tampon et deux
surtout si cette personne peut être
raisonnablement renvoyé dans son pays
quand il n'y a plus laissé passer
consulaire comme aujourd'hui c'est le
cas des cit citoyens russes que nous
avons mis dans les cras il les libère
qu'importe la dangerosité parce que il
dit vous n'avez pas le droit d'enfermer
quelqu'un si vous n'avez pas une chance
sérieuseenvoyer dans son pays donc les
chiffres les pourcentages que Don
monsieur Durin je suis désolé de vous
dire qui sont très amoindris par un la
crise du covid de la crise des visas et
aujourd'hui nous avons repris mais c'est
vrai on aurait dû vous fnir ce rapport
donc maxima et akoupa et on a repris
effectivement des taux de reconduite qui
sont tout à fait acceptables qui dépasse
même de celle de 2019 qui était le top
de ce qu'on a réussi à faire pendant
tout ministère de l'Intérieur C cette
année on en parlera lors des chiffres
l'immigration jeespère l'année prochaine
juste pour dire que à Monsieur ravier
enfin non il n pas été défendu nous
n'avons pas étendu en revanche le délai
de réension je rappelle qu' la directive
européenne c'est jusqu'à 18 mois en
Grèce par exemple c'est 18 mois de
rétention donc quand la France propose
quelques mois elle est très en de ça de
ce qu'elle pourrait faire dans la loi
européenne le ministre monsieur
benaroche a demandé la parole vous aviez
levé la main avant moi je fais comme
vous voulez monsieur ben
e allez on y va
monsieursieur président Gontard pardon
merci Madame madame la Présidente non je
voulais répondrece que Monsieur le le
ministre a a beaucoup parlé de mon
collègue Thomas Dosu qui a dû qui a dû
s'absenter donc je vais à la fois je lui
raconterai tout ce que vous avez pu dire
mais je voulais quand même aussi vous
vous répondre déjà vous dire qu'il est
quelqu'un de plutôt raisonnable de la
même manière que Monsieur Durin
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on est tous à peu
près raisonnable tous à peu près
raisonnable ici en fait qu'est-ce qu'il
propose dans son amendement th dessus
quelque choseassez simple en fait hein
c'est juste de revenir avant 2018 et
c'est donc juste la la suppression de la
2uxème période de 30 jours et de et
d'avoir une durée maximum de de 60 jours
c'est tout simplement ce qui demande
donc on est très loin monsieur le
ministre je comme je vous répond de ce
que de ce que vous pouviez de ce que
vous pouviez dire et puis j'ai bien
écouté tout votre propos mais vous
parlez absolument à chaque fois sur
l'cas de délinquants de dangereux
récidivistes et cetera ça ça me pose en
fait quelques probl problème centre de
rétention administrative la centre de
rétention administrative ce n'est pas
justement un centre pénitentiaire ce
n'est pas une prison c'est bien défini
sur ce que c'est et des personnes qui
sont en
OQTF qui n'ont comme seul je dirais
délit sien est un c'est d'être sur le
territoire français point ils n'ont rien
commis mais comme ils sont sur le
territoire français effectivement en
situation illégal on les met dans un
centre de rétention administrative ce ne
sont pas des délinquants en tout cas
rien ne dit ce sont des dangereux
délinquants donc vous êtes en train de
transformer mais on le sait puisque ça
fait partie de vos directives de
totalement transformer les centres de
rétention administrative dans des
centres pénitentiaires dit concentrer
effectivement des droits communs et là
ça devient terriblement dangereux parce
que le centre de réntion administratif
n'est pas défini de telle sorte et donc
ça veut dire queil faudrait revoir ce
que c'est réellement qu'un centre de
rétention administrative parce que en
même temps vous mettez aussi des agents
en difficulté et on en a rencontré un
certain nombre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur benaroche si vous
voulez bien maintenant prendre la parole
ben j'ai bien fait de laisser parler
monsieur gotard avant puisqu'il a dit
sûrement mieux que moi une partie de ce
que j'allais dire donc voilà donc
j'aborde et je continue donc je
comprends très bien votre amendement et
j'ai très bien compris monsieur le
ministre quelle est la vocation que vous
souhaitez donner au CRRA et quels sont
les gens que vous souhaitez imettre je
comprends très bien cela mais je suis
très acqué en fait dans la réalité pour
une chose très claire c'est que les cras
sont pas des centres pénitentiires ils
sont pas organisé comme des centres
pénitentiaires le personnel qui est
n'est pas formé comme pour un centre
pénitentiaire et donc je je me fais mais
vous devez sûrement le savoir le
l'interprète le le le transmetteur de de
parole d'un certain nombre d'agents qui
sont dans ses CR aujourd'hui encore une
fois j'en rencontre aussi beaucoup et je
peux vous dire aujourd'hui qu'il y a une
grande inquiétude parce que ils ont bien
senti la
différence voilà nous interrompons les
débats sur cet article 12 article qui
porte sur interdiction du placement
centre de rétention administrative des
mineurs de 16 ans nous sommes en plein
dans les explications de vote de la
gauche et c'est l'occasion de rejoindre
Mathias Arz qui se trouve dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat Mathias alors que
dire des discussions de ces dernières
heures on peut dire que ça s'est
sacrément accéléré au niveau du rythme
déjà absolument Tamin les sénateurs ont
longuement travaillé cet après-midi plus
de H articles ont été examinés depuis le
début de la séance à 14h30 certains très
scrutés vous le savez je pense aux
articles 9 et 10 notamment visant à
faciliter la levée des protection contre
les expulsions ou les missions de
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français à l'encontre d'étranger en
situation irrégulière et présentant
représentant une menace pour l'ordre
publici ce n'est évidemment pas les
seuls cas concerné par la levée de ces
obligations ces deux articles ont été t
le fruit d'un accord politique entre le
gouvernement et la majorité sénatoriale
qui se sont accordé et bien ici
supprimer un amendement en contreparti
la majorité soutenait les amendements du
Gouvernement voilà beaucoup de travail
cet après-midi les sénateurs ont ensuite
adopté un volet concernant le relevé
d'empreinte digitale de prise de photos
d'un étranger sans son consentement
ainsi que la création d'un fichier de
mineurs étrangers impliqués dans des
infractions pénales dernière avancée
vous l'avez évoqué qui est en lancement
de ce de ce papier les sénateurs sont en
train de s'accorder ils sont d'accord
pour interdire le placement en centre de
de rétention administrative pour les
mineurs de 16 ans et cela alors que les
sénateurs multiplient les demandes de
scrutin public car et bien la droite
semblerait être moins nombreuse en
nombre que la gauche actuellement he ce
qui explique donc la multiplication de
ce type de scrutin et bien on va vous
laisser d'ici quelques instants mais
notez qu'on va se retrouver à 22h pour
continuer à suivre l'examen du projet de
loi immigration et noter qu'il y aura
notamment des articles très intéressants
sur et bien notamment la restriction de
délivrance de visa la conditionnalité de
l'aide au développement envers les États
qui ne sont pas assez coopératifs en
matière migratoire c'est-à-dire qui
n'accepent pas le retour de leur
ressortissants on se retrouve donc tout
à
[Musique]
l'heure
les nouvelles de l'attentat dans le
grand magasin Tati tro personnes
auraient été tuées par le commando il
est 17h5 hier place Charles de Gaulle
une bombe explose lorsque il y a eu les
attentats de Charlie et aussi ceux sur
l'hypercachère et aussi sur la policière
de Montrouge il y a eu un soulèvement
j'ordne que tous les moyens soient
employés par ils ne passont pas en ce
qui concerne le terroristme la réponse
c'est l'unité nationale vous avez une
rage c'est l'inhumanité la barbarie le
terrorisme ne détruira pas la République
car c'est la République qui le détruira
président le prix à payer face au
terrorisme un documentaire inédit écrit
par Michel cota et Patrice duamel
réalisé par Pauline Pier samedi à 21h
sur Public Sénat et dès à présent sur
[Musique]
publicsena.fr oh
ils ont tiré wesh ces images
sidèent la France le 27 juin 2023 na 17
ans est tué par un policier à Nanterre
après un refus d'obtempéré le quartier
Pablo Picasso d'où est originaire
l'adolescence
[Musique]
enbras le moment de rage la colère en
fait elle se trouve ici un point d'appui
une justification en fait que nul ne
peut véritablement
contester la cité francilienne entraîne
le pays dans une spirale de violence
jours d'émeut et de pillage d'une
intensité jamais connue dans notre
histoire
l'exécutif est plongé dans la tourmente
les dernières heures ont été marqué par
des scènes de violence contre
commissariat mais aussi des écoles des
mairies les professionnels du désordre
doivent rentrer chez eux plus de 500
communes sont touchées presque aucun
département n'est épargné les émeutes se
propagent notamment à des territoires
peu habitués aux violences urbaines
comme la Loire c'était quand même un
moment assezz angoissant fait les villes
moyennes du département connaissent des
dégrades tion sans précédent à Ran rive
de giier ou la ricaamarie les dommages
se chiffrent en millions d'euros je
pense que nous avons des mes qui qui ont
pris une claque ce qu'on espère de la
justice c'est que la ville de rive deg
que les RIP algériens soit reconnu comme
des victimes pourquoi ces villes de la
France périphériqu se sont-elles embrasé
qui sont les émetiers quelle réponse
politique pour éviter une nouvelle
flambée de violence il faut montrer que
nous nous laissons pas intimider que
nous avons les moyens de pouvoir
empêcher cela il y a des ruptures il
nous faut du service public tous attend
d' un geste fort de l'État je pense que
les la politique de la ville maintenant
évidemment aura un autre visage dans la
Loire le traumatisme persiste et les
questions demeurent 4 mois après les
fait nous retournons dans les villes
moyennes les plus touchées du
département pour comprendre l'autre
visage des
[Musique]
émeutes
dans sa boutique du centre-ville de rive
de giier Sandra pulara s'efforce de
retrouver un quotidien normal ça je
pense que ça va plaire à pas mal de de
garçons en juin dernier la gérante de 57
ans a vécu plusieurs nuits de cauchemar
des hémetiers ont saccagé et pillé son
commerce ça c'était le premier soir donc
le 30
juin donc en fait on m'a appelé ENF mon
alarme s'est déclenché on m'a appelé
pour me dire que on était en train de me
cambrioler je vous dis franchement quand
j'ai vu toutes ces personnes dans ma
boutique parce qu'ils étaient des
dizaines qui a goulé d'autres pas du
tout il y en avait qui avait des gants
et franchement ça vous avez le cœur qui
bat et vous ça fait un grand ch au total
25000 € de marchandise dérobé et 17000 €
de vit brisée la commerçante a failli
baisser les bras et quitter la ville et
aujourd'hui c'est hors de question pour
vous de vous dire voilà ma boutique je
vais la je vais la déplacer on va aller
ailleurs alors ça j'ai une réflexion de
de quelques jours où j'étais
complètement perdu et comment vous dire
ça c'est une question fallit pas me
poser
pardon j'y arrive pas c'est trop dur si
ça a été compliqué très compliqué h se
poser la question d'arrêter parce
que ça fait quand même 3 mois et demi
maintenant et cétait pas la première
fois en fait il avait déjà eu un
cambriolage ouis donc désolé hein euh
compliqué c'est compliqué mais après on
a décidé de se battre et et finalement
bah voilà on a réussi à tout remettre en
ordre à l'image de Sandra rive de Giet
ville populaire de 15000 habitants a été
très marqué par des émeutes d'une rare
violence en plein centre-ville la mairie
a même été la principale cible des
exactions comme chaque vendredi le maire
Vincent Bonny fait un tour sur le marché
au pied de l'édifice communal ça va fait
frais les matins maintenant hein
oui on a la moitié du bâtiment qui a
refer à
l'intérieur c'est dingue hein c'est
dingue ouais ouais on a une époque mais
cette violence je comprends alors ça va
les r on étent particulièrement touchés
ému et scandalisé devant l'attaque de de
leur mairie puceque c'est un beau
bâtiment patrimonial c'est toute
l'histoire de la commune qui est résumée
par ce bâtiment hein l'histoire
industrielle et développement économique
de la
ville la mairie symbole du passé minier
de la ville a été incendiée par des
dizaines de jeunes dans la nuit du 30
juin Vincent bonis était sur les lieux
le soir de
l'attaque les hmetiers on ont forcé la
la porte on cassé la porte pour rentrer
et on mis le feu en mettant de l'essence
dans les containur pouBell et on mis le
feu ici donc ici tout tout a pris feu
les flammes sont montées le long des des
murs et puis ces fumées noires épaisses
se sont accumulé ici au deè étage et la
chaleur a dégondé les portes ça pollué
l'ensemble des locaux de l'hôtel de
ville ça fait fondre tout le câblage
électrique toute
l'informatique ça été un vrai désastre
et quand on est rentré là-dedans on le
sentiment de d'être dans une scène de
film c'était incroyable paysage ciné
quoi voilà les dégâts estimés à 3
million d'euros font partie des plus
importants au niveau national àrive de
jier la moitié de l'hôtel de ville est
aujourd'hui
impraticable j'ai pas les mots j'ai pas
les
mots c'est comme si était passé je sais
pas je sais pas comment expliquer puis
on est on est face à ce déferlement qui
n'a aucun rapport avec la vie commune
ici avec la vie de la commune
et on doit subir ça et on doit faire
face qui voilà tout simplement on doit
faire face donc c'est c'est dur à
encaisser mais on encaisse et puis on
finalement on est encore plus déterminé
dans le projet municipal qu'on a à
mettre en
œuvre mais c'est une galère de plus
c'est une galère de plus
voilà
[Musique]
CCIL Kerman est sénatrice de la Loire
depuis l'été cette parlementaire
communiste se tient au chevet de ses
mères dont le mandat a été bouleversé je
pense que ce sont des élus oui
inévitablement déboussolés parce que
vous savez c'est toujours désastreux de
voir une mairie brûlée une mairie
attaquée je crois qu'il y a d'abord
besoin de les accompagner d'être
présente à leur côté de les aider de
faciliter et puis au-delà de cela je
crois d'entendre et d'écouter les
problèmes qui qui demeurent la sénatrice
se rent à Rive degier l'élu veut faire
un point sur la reconstruction mais
aussi comprendre comment la municipalité
s'est remise en marche ça va
merci de ta présence de rien malgré
l'incendie la mairie n'a jamais cessé
d'assurer son service à la population
même s'il fonctionne depuis des mois en
service très dégradé
bonjour voilà ça c'est le service
informatique la direction de service
informatique vous aviez combien de
bureau avant on
avit vous avez regroupé dans un on a
100% des effectifs dans 4% des locaux
donc forcément les collègues sont
obligés de de faire contre mauvaise
fortune bon cœur et donc de d'être à
plusieurs dans un même bureau c'est
c'est bien difficile pour pour les
collègues oui ça démontre la volonté
jusqu'au bout des agents municipaux et
des élus de de ne pas fermer
définitivement bien évidemment le
service public local et de continuer de
le rendre opérant en revanche bien
évidemment on est dans des situations
qui doivent demeurer
temporaires la commune a entrepris les
démarches auprès de de l'État et des
assurances pour rénover le bâtiment mais
il faudra un an de travaux avant
d'espérer un retour à la normale la
vraie question et la vraie question que
que nous nous allons poser dans les dans
les jours dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est maintenant qu'est-ce que l'on fait
pour pour ces villeslà celles qui ont
connu leses mais tant d'autres qui ne
les ont pas connu et qui auraient pu les
connaître malheureusement c'est aussi ça
la réalité pour que les populations qui
vivent il vivent bien au-delà des dégâts
Vincent bony espère surtout une
réparation symbolique du préjudice subi
ce qu'on espère de la justice c'est que
la ville de rivedeg que les RIP
algériens soi reconnus comme des
victimes et que les auteurs qui ont été
appréhendés qui ont reconnu leur
participation et leur culpabilité
puissent mesurer la gravité de leurs
actes et de ces conséquences qui vont
s'étaler sur plusieurs années sur pour
notre commune Riv de giier s'est
constitué partie civile en vue du procès
de trois émetiers une audience très
attendue
[Musique]
Julien Ray est avocat depuis 13 ans à
Saint-Étienne ce jour-là il paaufine sa
pldoirie en vue du procès des émetiers
de rive degier et le dossier lui paraît
bien
léger mon client sur ces images
n'apparaît nulle part et de toute façon
les la qualité des images fait que de
toute façon on ne reconnaîtra on ne
reconnaît personne sur ces sur ces
images défend Enzo un jeune
manutentionnaire au casier judiciaire
vierge enzo a 20 ans une
enfance particulièrement difficile qui a
été victime de harcèlement scolaire qui
a été déscolarisé tôt qui s'en est sorti
par le travail invité sur une boucle du
réseau social snapchat Enzo rejoint
d'autres jeunes sur le parvis de la
mairie de rive de GI c'est là qu'il
reconnaît avoir aspergé d'essence une
poubelle mais pas de l'avoir incendié
lui néta pas présent au moment de
l'incendie il était rentré chez lui
parce que sa mère l'avait appelé et que
il a
simplement lui mis de l'essence dans une
poubelle qui était tout à côté de de la
mairie
[Musique]
parti et ben on part tout
droit la résistance magnifique rue de
Saint-Étienne
le procès pourrait bouleverser la vie de
son client Enzo en cours jusqu'à 10 ans
de prison et 100 € d'amende est-ce qu'il
y a de l'enjeu
aujourd'hui oui il y a de l'enjeu
aujourd'hui quand même l'enjeu c'est
c'est la poursuite d'une vie un peu
particulière
ou le changement de vie
[Musique]
d'Enzo les motivations des tro prévenus
dont Enzo demeure flou et jamais le
prénom de Na ne sera cité à l'issue de 4
heur d'un procès confus les réquisitions
du procureur
tombent le procureur a proposé au
tribunal une peine de 2 ans
d'emprisonnement dont un an sur 6
probatoir voilà c'est desquisitions
extrêmement lourdes qui ont été demandé
par le procureur de la République
quelques semaines plus tard les trois
prévenus seront condamnés à 18 mois de
prison dont un enferme je pense que le
parquet n'a pas regardé le contexte il a
regardé simplement l'infraction on est
on brûle pas une poubelle là on brûle
une mairie et c'est tout symbole et je
pense c'est la raison pour laquelle la
la réponse est aussi aussi rapide et
aussi forte pourquoi ces jeunes sans
passer judiciaire ont-ils
dérapé au-delà de l'adrénaline il y
a-t-il eu une dimension plus politique
dans l'attaque des 242 bâtiments publics
à échelle nationale je suis persuadé que
cette colère est effectivement
extrêmement politique c'est sûr que
c'est ça a été étonnant en fait le
nombre de de dégradation de
d'institution publique je pense que ça
ça dit assez clairement en fait de cette
relation au monde cette relation
dégradée à ce qui est emblématique d'un
pouvoir étatique de l'État et cetera de
ces administrations en fait qui bah qui
sont jugés comme étant aussi
précisément les responsables de la
situation que qu'ils sont en train de
vivre partie d'une bavure policière les
émeutes interrogent avant tout tout
autre chose le rapport entre la police
et la population un lien fortement
dégradé dans certains quartiers mais sur
lequel les élus locaux pensent avoir un
levier je crois que dans la crise de
l'autorité il y a inévitablement la
crise avec la police et l'institution
police au sens large alors bien
évidemment il y a les réponses qui
datent aujourd'hui depuis un certain nom
d'année des polices municipales parce
que les effectifs de police nationale
ont fortement reculé dans un certain
nombre de commune direction ran
Sous-Préfecture de la Loire dans cette
ville de 35000 habitants le maire Yve
Nicolin a fait de la police municipale
la pierre angulaire de sa réponse post
émeute bonjour mesdame bonjour monsieur
mais c'est féminin ce matin 26 agents
armés et bien équipés une police de
proximité amené à compenser le recul des
forces de sécurité régalienne sur le
terrain grand ulté de la police
nationale c'est queelle a beaucoup
d'effectifs notamment à roa nous avons
plus de 140 fonctionnaires sur le
commissariat mais une grande partie de
ces effectif est consacré à une tâche
d'enquête une tâche administrative donc
nos effectifs sont plus présents sur le
terrain que ne peut l'être la police
nationale avec les moyens dont elle
dispose si l'on veut notamment dans
certains quartiers avoir davantage de
sérénité il faut qu'on ait aussi
davantage de présence policière et ça
c'est une question
d'effectif bonjour
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
équipement là toujours pareil monsie le
ma c'est quoi ça c'est c'est ce qui nous
a sauvé la semaine dernière gaz ah oui
gaz vous en êtes F monsieur le ma de
votre police municipale ah oui oui ça
c'est sûr que on a une belle équipe ils
nous ont bien aidé pendant les pu nous
aide au quotidien parce qu'il se passe
toujours quelque
chose pierre le chef de brigade et ses
collègues ont été sur tous les fronts
pendant les émeutes notamment dans le
quartier sensible de la ville
c'est un direction Parc des Sports pour
info le Parc des Sports a été le
quartier le plus touché par les
violences urbaine avec plusieurs
magasins détruits notamment cette
enseigne de décoration donc on arrive
toujours dans le quartier Parc des
Sports donc sur la route de Charlieu sur
le centre accord donc magasin qui a été
la cible des émetiers HE et qui a qui a
complètement été incendié il nous reste
que les murs porteurs comme on peut le
peut le constater
plus loin ce centre de formation pour
apprentis du BTP a été incendié lui
aussi 8 million d'euros de dégâts au
total plusieurs jours durant ces hommes
ont d sécuriser les lieux vérif que il y
a pas de nouvelles intrusions on essay
de canaliser l'avenue des populations
sur sur le site qui était dangereux comm
cétait tout ouvert il des BR ver et
c'était pas sécuris pendant et après les
émeuteses policiers municipaux sont en
force derrière policiers nationaux et
gendarmes on complète les les effectifs
on a toujours notre Pier à apporter hein
on est équipé je sais de lanceur de
balle de défense tous les agents sont en
dotation individuelle des casques des
casques pour leur protection chaque
véhicule a un bouclier euh donc on peut
intervenir à l'instant T en renfort des
des équipages police en effet
ouais donc on quitte le quartier du Parc
des Sports on regagne le centr-eville
les émeutes ont poussé Yve Nicolin à
réagir ran va recruter 12 nouveaux
policiers municipaux début 2024 c'est
environ 500000 € supplémentaires sur
notre budget pour lequel nous ne sommes
pas aidés ni par l'État ni par personne
mais que nous avons décider donc de de
mettre parce que c'est l'urgence du
moment et qu'il faut pouvoir faire en
sorte d'apporter le maximum de sécurité
à une immense majorité de gens qui
veulent vivre tranquille dans leur
quartier parallèlement l'État a annoncé
un renforcement des effectifs de de
police et de gendarmerie dans la Loire
mais pour Cécile cuckerman la réponse
sécuritaire aux émeutes ne peut se
suffire à elle-même je n'ppose pas la
présence de la sécurité des bleus sur le
terrain au travail éducatif et des
associations je pense qu'il est
foncièrement et fondamentalement
complémentaire dans la Loire le milieu
associatif est déjà à pied d'œuvre pour
penser les blessures liés aux émeutes à
la ricarie 8000 habitants en banlieu de
Saint-Étienne Salima BO préside depuis
20 ans vivre ensemble une association
qui crée du lien entre les mamans de la
commune c'est une ville où il y a
beaucoup de solidarité beaucoup de
partage beaucoup d'associations
bénévoles aussi et ça crée un peu un
mélange de
nationalité de religion aussi et c'est
super important cette ancienne ville
minière la plus pauvre du département a
vécu un traumatisme sa mairie
flambanneuve a été incendié lors des
événements
c'était quand même un
moment assez assez angoissant en fait
Salima retrouve les membres de son
association à un café des parents oui
c'est à côté en
fait un espace de libre parole dont le
thème n'est pas sans lien avec les
émeutes si c'est là j'entends du monde
l'idée d'aujourd'hui c'est de prendre
soin de nous en tant que parents donc
d'abord de se faire du bien pour pouvoir
bien dans notre quotidien dans notre
rôle de paren et avec nos enfants la
séance est guidée par une art thérapeute
autour de la créativité l'idée est de se
questionner sur sa
parentalité en lien avec le fait d'être
par et pu on
ici super
important les temps de REP parce que
trouve que dans une famille c'est voilà
c'est la
convivialité c'est le moment café c'est
le plus beau moment de ma journée le
café c'est ce qui va dans ma vie ou
ouais après les enfants et
tout des sujets plus lourds s'invitent
dans les échanges si ces femmes restent
évasives sur la participation de leurs
enfants aux émeutes toutes font part de
leurs inquiétudes quant aux effets des
réseaux sociaux allez tu prends le
portable tu veux la télé tu fais ce que
tu veux non c'est une facilité de de
laisser ton enfant avec son portable je
te garantis que quand ton gamin il a 7
ans bien sûr tu peux lui le prendre des
mains mais quand il a 16 17 ans il va
trouver tous les subterfuges possibles
et imaginables pour pouvoir l'avir tout
le temps aucun père n'est présent à
l'atelier autour de la table des mèr
souvent seul et précaire qui ont eu le
sentiment d'avoir été pointé du doigt
par le gouvernement les parents ont une
obligation morale ce n'est pas plus
compliqué que ça à l'égard de leurs
enfants est-ce que vous vous êtes senti
peut-être un peu un peu stigmatisé bah
en tant que parent oui c'est sûr c'est
jamais bien plaisant de s'entendre dire
que les mamans ne font pas leur travail
alors qu'en fait elles font comme elles
peuvent faudrait qu'ils viennent vivre
chez certaines familles pour se rendre
compte de comme c'est difficile dans le
quotidien moi ce qui m'a plus gêné c'est
le lien entre ces aspects
sociologiques le le défavoriser le
monoparental le CECI le cela et la
mauvaise parce que des parents qui qui
quient pas ça existe c'est bien mais il
y en a de partout en tout cas moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé travailler avec vous je
vous remercie
vous AZ t super joué le jeu tout super
joué le jeu c'est dommage qu'on avait
pas de papa avec des moyens modestes
6000 € de subvention par an Salima sait
que son association jouera un rôle
déterminant dans la prévention d'une
nouvelle flambée de violence faut être
deux fois plus vigilant et je pense
qu'avec tous les acteurs possibles qu'on
a dans dans notre ville je pense que
c'est possible c'est possible d'y
arriver c'est possible d'avoir des
discussions c'est possible de tisser du
lien avec des personnes avec qui on a
pas l'habitude et voilà pas rester dans
son coin et essayer de essayer de
trouver des solutions seules de toute
façon on n'y arrive pas donc c'est des
solutions pour améliorer le vivre
ensemble laricamarie ne cesse de s'y
employer pour l'équipe municipale l'une
des urgences est de rénover un
centre-ville à bout de souffle donc ce
chantier un chantier qui a bien avancé
et qui a été donc qui a commencé par une
démolition puisque la police n'arrivait
pas à reprendre l'espace on s'est donné
comme ambition de le reprendre par un
mécanisme d'urbanisme le cœur deeville
classé quartier prioritaire concentre
toutes les difficultés 32 % des
habitants vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté les services publics ont
déserté et le trafic de drogue à pignon
sur rue non mais ça il y a pas de police
pas de police he ils font ce qu'ils
veulent ils ont pris le marché ils ont
ils ont pris la place
quoi le trafic de drogue c'est la source
de toutes les nuisances ça altère
l'image de la ville ça abîme la
perception des gens de l'extérieur con
de la ville du coup ça freine
l'apparition d'investisseur qui pourra
être intéressé par un espace qui est
stratégique les travaux vont permettre
de chasser un point de Deal et de le
remplacer par un espace vert ainsi que
des logements neufs l'idée du ma est
d'enclencher un cercle vertueux
l'amélioration urbaine un petit peu plus
de mixité sociale et avec un logement
bien évidment de qualité qui structurera
la chaussée de manière un peu
harmonieuse quoi mais cette rénovation
urbaine pèse lourdement sur les finances
locales 00000 € pour ce projet sans
aucune aide de l'État quand on sait que
dans la politique de la ville c'est 1 %
des budget de l'État et que il y a 8 %
de la population qui habite les
quartiers politiques de la ville donc il
y a une forme d'hypocrisie sociale à
tout ça donc il y a une vraie dynamique
a une vraie réentation de l'argent à
donner dans des espaces parce que il y a
un intérêt commun laricaarie est
l'illustration d'une réalité cruelle
selon un rapport parlementair l'État
accorde au quartiers prioritair quatre
fois moins de moyens qu'ailleurs rappor
au nombre d'habitants je crois que notre
pays aujourd'hui il souffre de deux
choses l'accroissement des fractures
territoriales l'accroissement des
fractures sociales nous sommes ici à la
commune de lararie sur une ville qui
cumule les deux fractures donc faisons-y
très attention parce que quand ça
explose dans une commune c'est c'est un
bout de la République qui explose tous
les regards se tournent vers l'état et
sa réponse poste émeute une réponse jugé
tardive par de nombreux élus et acteurs
de
terrain
allez
je regarde là pour le gouvernement au
contraire le temps pris a été celui de
la concertation et du diagnostic tout ce
temp pris que les médias disent oh là là
on recule non on discute prendre le
temps de discuter à priori permet de
gagner du temps à postériori c'est ça la
réalité décider dans l'émotion c'est une
forcément une mauvaise décision la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement c'est
pas de vendre du rêve
3 semaines plus tard à Paris nous
retrouvons le maire de Riv degier sur le
parvis de la gare de Lyon
bonjour aller à
laonne les ma particulièrement touchés
par les émeutes urbaines sont invités
par la première ministre dans le grand
amphithéâre de la Sorbonne pour entendre
donc les annonces que le gouvernement
souhaite faire maintenant sur des
mesures pour répondre à cette
problématique c'est pas un peu tard 4
mois
en tout cas on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement a travaillé dans son coin
tout seul c'est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire la question c'est est-ce que
les les réponses
seront à la hauteur en tout cas de de
bonne nature parfait merci
[Musique]
beaucoup face à ces enjeux nous devons
agir collectivement donner la
possibilité aux police municipal
d'accomplir certains actes de police
judiciaire nous allons multiplier par 5
l'amende pour non respect du couvre-feu
nous pouvons envisager un encadrement de
jeunes délinquants par des militaires il
faut aussi davantage responsabiliser les
parents à la Sorbonne la première
ministre égraine le volet sécuritaire
des mesures Vincent Boni sort de
l'amphithéâtre
mitigé il y a des mesures qui sont
peut-être un peu trop incantatoires à
mon goût sur apprendre ce que c'est que
la République au plus jeune et cetera
oui mais si on la vit pas réellement
cette république au quotidien je pense
que on risque de renforcer
en fait un sentiment de frustration et
un sentiment de mise à l'écart de d'une
promesse qui est affichée la promesse
elle est affichée mais la réalité est-ce
qu'elle est là un sentiment de
frustration face à l'urgence certaines
pistes du gouvernement devront être
discuté au Parlement et mettront des
mois avant d'aboutir en attendant la vie
doit reprendre à Rive de giier même si
la page des émeutes semble encore loin
d'être
[Applaudissements]
tourné
[Musique]
il a publié plus de 150 albums il a
révolutionné le genre de la BD son chat
du Rabin a fait le tour du monde et la
série continue il en publie le 12e il
sort aussi Youngman carnet rassemblant
c'estes croquis d'étudiants Johann SAR
est notre invité dans un monde un regard
les entretiens de public SNA un monde un
regard demain à 19h sur Public
Sénat le 8 mai
1945 l'Allemagne nazie capitule
enfin à Moscou New York Paris Londres
Amsterdam Prague
par tous les peuples
jubil sincère mais
émère car l'Allemagne naz a beau être
battu l'Europe est
anéantie les survivant ple le Mor mais
il le poid des
ruins lesats-unis la GrandeBretagne et
la France on gagné la guerre mais
parviendrontil à gagner la
PAI
après Hitler demain à 22h sur public
sat les nouvelles de l'attentat dans le
grand magasin Tati TR personnes aurai
été tué par le commando il est 17h5 hier
Charles de Gaulle une bombe explose lors
il y a eu les attentats de Charlie et
aussi sur l'hy cach aussi sur la
policière de Montrouge il y a eu un
soulèvement tous les moyens soi employés
partout ils ne passeront pas en ce qui
concerne le terroriste la réponse c'est
l'unité nationale vous avez une rage
c'est l'inhumanité la barbarie le
terrorisme ne détruira pas la République
car c'est la République qui le détruira
président le prix à payer face au
terrorisme un documentaire inédit écrit
par Michel cota et Patrice duamel
réalisé par Pauline per samedi à 21h sur
Public Sénat et dès à présent sur
publicsenat.fr
oui je suis un enfant
d'immigré oui je suis le fils d'un
hongroi et le Petitfils d'un Grec je me
demande si j'ai pas fait une grosse
connerie en mettant à l'intérieur
j'aurais dû l'écraser du pied gauche
encore ça naurapporté chance vous madame
vous gagnez combien le SMIC pour gagner
plus il faut travailler plus c'est c'est
Nicolas ça fait beaucoup de connerie
alors laissez-moi faire quelquesunes je
me fous des patrons il voteront pour moi
je dois cibler les ouvriers tu comprends
rien la politique tu es vraiment une
cogne je vous propose de faire la paix
arrêtez votre CIRC Dominique on est en
guerre vous et moi vous voulez la place
de Chirac mais moi aussi je la veux un
de mes informateurs a pénétré le circuit
informatique de la banque stream voilà
puis qui chante en bas en train de
marcher sur mes plat
bandes la conquête un film de Xavier
Duringer avec Denis podalides Bernard
leco et Florence Pernel dans le ciné
club de public sénna samedi 22h30 sur
Public
[Musique]
Sénat retrouvez manger
svutés avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires bonjour les amis petite
promenade matinale dans les rues
tranquille de rivir on est sur la route
des vins dans le haut rein vous l'avez
compris manger s beuté est en Alsace et
on va à la rencontre contre du sénateur
Ludovic e du groupe RDPI le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle il nous attend
pas très loin d'ici dans les belles
collines de
rixide
il m'avit dit je vous retrouverai à la
croisée des chemins il ne m'avit pas
menti bonjour monsieur le sénateur ben
voilà nous sommes à la borne bonjour
Vincent comment ça va bah écoutez ça
sera dur de pas aller aujourd'hui
bienvenue en Alsace merci beaucoup sous
ce soleil radieu mais il fait toujours
ce tempsl je le dis toujours c'est vrai
je me disais peut-être c'est parce que
vous en êtes au début de votre vie de
sénateur que vous êtes à la croisée des
chemins encore oui il y a pas mal de
chemins effectivement qui se croisent ça
reste aujourd'hui mon mon point fixe
c'est un un lieu dans lequel j'aime me
retrouver et puis ben on est à l'entrée
presque ce qu'on appelle la région des
trois frontières avec la Suisse à
proximité à une une quinzaine de
kilomètres l'Allemagne a une dizaine de
kilomètres juste au dessus et puis ben
nous on est sur cette terre alsacienne
on appelle ça le point triple la zone
des trois frontières aujourd'hui nous
passer la douane changer de langue pour
aller échanger avec nos voisin c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait quotidiennement
c'est vrai que quand des fois on se fait
un monde de l'Europe en disant estce que
l'Europe elle existe nous si vous voulez
on la vit quotidiennement être sénateur
c'est un engagement mais c'est pas un
métier vous êtes ingénieur en
cybersécurité progressivement je me suis
occupé de la sûreté des gros système
industriel puis de la sûreté c'est passé
progressivement à la cyber sécurité
voilà et on comprend pas où vient se
loger l'engagement politique là-dedans
c'est aussi un état d'esprit j'ai
toujours voulu que les autres soient
bien avant de savoir si moi-même j'étais
bien c'est un peu ma philosophie euh
vous venez quand même du monde agricole
euh de de votre région Lauren tout à
fait tout à fait hein donc vous avez
quand même cette fibre ce pied dans la
terre ah je dis jure j'ai eu une enfance
euh extrêmement heureuse dans dans les
fermes mon grand-père était agriculteur
ouais ouis et je crois que c'est
essentiel parce que ça vous donne une un
enracinement extrêmement fort sur le
terroir je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
pas parler du terroir comme d'un effet
de mode euh on découvre pas le terroir
on y né on s'y attache et euh on le
défend en arrivant ici en fait vous êtes
retrouvé dans ce village de Rixheim euh
dont vous avez été d'abord conseiller
municipal et puis euh vous avez pris euh
la charge de de M oui tout à fait alors
bon je dois beaucoup à à Olivier beschte
qui est désormais ministre du Commerce
extérieur et de l'attractivité j'ai
rejoint son équipe en 2008 avec le Fran
parl qui est le mien je lui dit moi je
veux bien te rejoindre sur la liste
électorale si j'ai quelque chose à faire
et il m'a dit ben écoute avec tes
connaissances en numérique et ce qu'il y
a à faire au niveau de la ville Ville
Internet le numérique dans les écoles et
et après tout s un petit peu enchaîné
olivier est devenu député euh du coup
moi je suis devenu maire et puis les
sénatoriales qui là étent peut-être un
petit peu moins c'est pas prévu au
program alors vous dites que de votre
groupe le mot le plus important c'est
indépendant mon mon positionnement
politique s'il faut en parler derrière
il est construit c'est de l'arithmétique
je suis un scientifique voilà je suis
centriste parce que derrière j'estime
qu'une idée qu'elle soit de droite ou de
gauche si elle est bonne pour les pays
il faut l'appliquer c'est ça qui fait
avancer le pays c'est ça qui fait
avancer les choses ça nécessite une
proximité ça nécessite beaucoup d'échang
avec les gens je vais beaucoup dans les
associations des fois il me disent mais
on s'attendait pas à ce que le sénateur
vienneent à à notre assemblée générale
je dis si parce que derrière moi je
comprends vos besoins voir comment ça
fonctionne et puis bah s'il y a une
catégorie en France qu'il faut quand
même bien mettre en avant ce sont les
bénévoles les bénévoles aujourd'hui
tiennent le pays par leur engagement
c'est énorme ce qu'ils font c'est aussi
des personnes qui souhaitent s'investir
au-delà de leur travail ils raccrochent
leur vestes et ils en décrochent une
autre Ludovic et vous savez que dans
manger svoté on s'intéresse avant tout
aux producteurs et aux grands produits
des régions je sais que ici en Alsace
c'est plutôt riche vous m'avez préparé
un programme alors moi j'ai envie de
dire l'alsas c'est le pays de lois du
foie doit on va aller voir Marcel
Metzler qui est producteur de foie gras
très attaché au bien-être animal et son
foie gras est juste excellent ah ben moi
pour démarrer la journée c'est
parfait allez on prend la route pour
rendre visite à Marcel à gebergevir et
son fameux foie Doig avant d'aller faire
la cuisine chez Isabelle l'école
s'appelle épic puis nous découvrirons
les asperges blanches d'Alsace chez
Claris le Minster fermier de Matis pour
terminer avec les viges du côté du
benollenberg dans le domaine jelin avec
son ris
[Musique]
bonjour Marcel bonjour monsur enchanté
de vous recevoir ici monsieur le
sénateur Marcel pourquoi vous nous
accueillez ici vous voulez nous montrer
votre petite piscine oui c'est une
piscine mais pas pour moi c'est une
piscine des oil je vous ai amené à cet
endroit l'endroit il s'appelle gensbun
ça veut dire fontaine de lois ça veut
dire c'est les champs communaux dans le
temps qu'on mettait à disposition des
paysans d'accord pour faire ptre les
animaux ici y avait des o et c'est une
sorte d'abreevoir pour les animaux
domestiques les animaux de la ferme
c'est une sorte d'abevoir et vous pouvez
voir il coule tout doucement mais été
comme hiver sécheress ou pas ça coule
toujours ici donc on est un petit peu au
démarrage du foie gradois en France ici
on y retraace l'histoire depuis l'an 750
identifié comme étant vraiment un des
berceaux du du fois Gradis enfin de du
du travail de loi en Alsace du travail
de lois et pourquoi du travail de loi
parce qu'ici à à l'époque comme on est
un canton Royal il y avait obligation
d'avoir 3 O grâce à l'époque à
disposition des seigneurs ah c'est un
peu l'impôt qu'on payait la taxe qu'on
payit au Seigneur P des joies
effectivement avec des joies et pourquoi
puisque à l'époque médiévale tout ce qui
volait était béni et manger le foie des
volailles était béni je trouve que cet
endroit est est très émouvant comme
étant une sorte de point de départ qui
va nous mener peut-être en ville parce
que pas beaucoup de fois ici moi je joue
très bien on y va il y a pas de souci
vous dites foie doie vous ne dites
jamais foie gras doit pourquoi oui parce
que c'est c'est c'est dans le
traditionnel c'est du fois gras doigt
effectivement mais c'est du fois grass
en gavage quoi ça veut dire que en
quelque sorte elle se gaveave elle-même
sans qu' est forçage alors c'est donc
l'interprétation du mot qui est
importante ouais puisque a l'action de
gaver ce qu'on fait normalement et
l'action de ce GAV c'est pas quelque
chose contre mais c'est quelque chose de
plus un texte de loi qui a été déposé
par un député qui s'appelle monsieur
nbreval qui est sur le bureau de
l'Assemblée et nous nous aimerons bien
mettre le fois gras avec ou s gavage
puisque'au niveau européen nous sommes
les seuls à ne pas avoir mis un adjectif
au m gavage nous avons nous attachons un
vrai soutien à nos à nos producteurs à
nos transformateurs de manière à ce
qu'il puisse produire un produit qui
soit reconnu en tant que tel il y a une
vraie attente de la société sur le
bien-être animal et donc si on peut
déguster d'excellents produits comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui tout en
respectant l'animal on poussera
évidemment j'ai eu l24 qui est venu me
voir et le process les intéresse
beaucoup la seule question il m'ont
piégé c'est de me dire vous les tuerz
comment c'est effectivement une grosse
question l'abattage je oui on se doute
bien que vous n'attendez pas qu'il
meurent de leur belle non on a quelques
photos ici on y est attaché après à ces
volailles et ainsi de suite on en mange
moins oui je dirais moins mais mieux
c'est c'est à peu près la question voilà
alors sans trahir le secret du process
comment est-ce qu'on donne de l'appétit
au zoies pour qu'elle se game elle-même
alors je vous donne un exemple est-ce
que par exemple on leur montre le billet
d'avion en leur disant vous allez migrer
bientôt il faut vous nourrir non c'est
pas ça est-ce qu'on fait comme les bœfs
de cobé ou les bœfs de chalos où on leur
donne par ex exemple de l'encilage de
maïs qui a de l'alcool et qui va leur
donner de la pétence on est un petit peu
dans l'idée al c'est vrai que le bœuf de
cobé c'est à peu près là où je voudrais
placer mon foir gras doigt sans gavage
ils font comme moi quand il y a des
bonnes choses on mange quoi donc voilà
et les oies vous leur mettez 5 si fois
et des choses différentes on leur amené
des couloupf à un moment donné mais
elles adorent ça je leur amené des chet
on en fait d'ailleurs avec mon Petitfils
mais je vous dirai pas toutes les
recettes mais il y en a un paquet et au
résultat le foie gras parce que çaen est
il est moins gras ils font autant de grâ
ce qui les protège d'ailleurs dans le
fond allez-y déguster je vais goûter
hein ah bah oui il est très bon mais moi
je ne saurais pas faire la différence
avec un un foi gavé quoi si le produit
est le même sur le plan gustatif
j'imagine que par ce process il est un
peu plus cher plus de main d'œuvre le
produit sera plus cher de l'ordre de 20
% par rapport
àcord la gamme conventionnelle ouais
puis Marcel on va pouvoir dire à ceux
qui sont vraiment des tenants absolus du
bien-être
animal là vous allez payer un petit peu
plus cher mais vous êtes certain qu'on
les choix au
oies et on les choix effectivement c'est
vrai et mes papill aussi merci
[Musique]
beaucoup alors là Vincent c'est
difficilement croyable nous nous situons
en plein cœur du centrreeville 2012 dans
un potag un verger un jardin de plantes
aromatiques nous sommes dans le jardin
potager d'Isabelle et Berlin et Berlin
un grand nom de la gastronomie alcienne
éid et ce n'est pas un hasard parce que
Isabelle l'épouse de marque a souhaité
fonder cette école de cuisine ici nous
avons dans les cuisines pas mal de
personnes qui ont connu un accident de
la vie et qui souhaitent se réinsérer
dans le marché d'emploi et puis des
produits toujours aussi goûteux et
excellents on va voir ça avec
Isabelle qu'est-ce que vous préparez
alors on prépare une salade de carottes
une recette alaienne ouais avec de l'œuf
dur avec de l'œuf dur comme faisaient
les grand-mères mulouse a cette
réputation d'être
multiculturel beaucoup de populations
venu d'origine extrêmement diverse c'est
peut-être le meilleur moyen de cuisiner
ensemble que de réunir tout le monde
bien sûr on pense souvent en moyen
d'intégration la première valeur qui
nous vient à l'idée c'est effectivement
d'apprendre la langue mais al utiliser
la cuisine comme moyen d'intégration on
a affaire à une vraie école de vie on
accueille différentes générations on
accueille par exemple ensemble des
publics de personnes âgées avec des
jeunes des bénéficièr du RSA avec
d'autres publics et du coup il y a des
transmissions des savoirs des à travers
la nourriture mais à travers les
rencontres
aussi qui qui sont favorisé et vous
savez bien que dans la cuisine il faut
aussi respecter des règles c'est c'est
une base de la cuisine on peut pas faire
n'importe comment la pâtisserie là bien
sûr mais il y a généralement un rapport
très hiérarchisé dans une brigade de
cuisine ici vous faites passer le
message différemment oui oui c'est
vraiment volontaire par exemple quand on
demande à des jeunes qu'est-ce que tu as
réussi aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu as
fait au départ ils ne savent ils ont
l'impression de n'avoir rien réussi ils
ne savent pas ce qui manque d'estime de
soi souvent manque d'estime de soi or
quand on a réalisé quelque chose et
qu'on va le servir à des personnes on a
un retour direct enfin il y a une
valorisation quoi c'est bon gagn et du
coup l'insertion souvent est est un peu
hors sol et et et l'insertion a besoin
d'être ancré dans dans la terre et dans
le voilà c'est comme ça qu'on va amener
les gens à à travailler les structures
de formation ont besoin d'être en lien
avec les employeurs avec les voilà et
puis ben même j'ai j'ai même utilisé
services de d'épic he pas plus tard
qu'hier soir voilà je recevais quelques
mères et voilà quand on a la chance
d'avoir une école telle que celle de
d'épice et celle d'Isabelle on essae
tant bien que mal d'aider au niveau qui
est le notutre est-ce qu'on peut
goûter moi je fais pas d'habitude de
mettre mes ur dans les carottes mais
maintenantens c'est les recettes
vraimentcien c'est
vrai j'ai le sentiment que Ludovique
voulait un petit cours de cuisine
particulier moi je vais aller voir
Claris pendant ce temps elle est
productrice d'asperge dans la plaine
d'Alsace ah oui parce que la plaine
d'Alsace ce n'est pas pour
lche
bonjour Claris B bah dites dos je vous
trouve un petit peu seul dans ce champ
d'asper vous nêtes pas seul à récolter
quand même ben non on est quand même un
peu de monde le matin mais on récolte à
la fraîche ah voilà mais je vous ai
gardé quelques asperges pour vous oh
c'est pour moi c'est pour vous que c'est
gentil des asperges blanches en plus
lche ouais tout à fait d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'il y a une bâche opaque sur
le dessus hein pour éviter qu'elle ne
voit la lumière dès qu'elle voit la
lumière elle prend un petit peu de
couleur et elle devient un peu verte
d'abord VI violette puis après elle
passe au vert ah d'accord c'est ça donc
en fait la vie de l'asperge blanche
c'est buté quoi c'est buté l'asperge
blanche c'est buté voir ah oui celle-là
a commencé à celle-ci elle a commencé à
avoir la lumière elle a une petite
journée de soleil c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'assimilation chlorophylienne
exactement hein alors voici une gouge hm
hm voilà une asperge on la voit on
l'allonge et on la craque claque elle n
fait un petit claque et on la sort
allez-y vous la sortez délicatement ou
là je je suis pas dessus voilà voilà là
j'ai senti voilà non mais alors
fantastique là c'est vraiment la chance
du débutant ouais franchement ah tout de
suite sortir une asperche comme ça du
premier coup c'est extraordinaire mais
dit donc Laris je viens de comprendre un
truc là on vient de passer un petit peu
de temps pour en sortir une ou bon je
suis pas non plus très doué mais ça veut
dire que il y a pas de machine tout se
fait à la main alors les machines sont
en en cours de d'élaboration mais mais
on n pas encore trouvé de technique
aussi tis satisfaisante que la récolte
manuelle et c'est vrai que chaque asper
j'ai sorti à la main qu'elle soit belle
qu'elle soit grosse qu'elle soit fine
c'est un véritable travail de
[Musique]
titan bonjour bonjour Pauline ça va
écoutez oui ça va je suis assez fasciné
parce que c'est ration de de ce qu'on a
vu làhaut dans le champ il y a combien
de calibres différents ici tout le monde
ne trie pas comme nous on le fait si on
devait compter je pense qu'il y en a au
moins une trentaine oua c'est ça c'est
dingue et du coup même si la saison ne
dure que 3
mois vous le magasin il dure toute
l'année on essaie de garder notre
clientèle toute l'année quoi qu'elle
vienne toute l'année même après après la
saison des asperges et po transforme
énormément de choses dont les asperges
justement qu' ouais c'est ça ouais quand
on cite euh les asperges en premier
c'est toujours la Ballée de la Durance
euh souvent la Sologne souvent le Blayet
en région aquitain et l'Alsace elle pas
de temp connaîre elle pas tellement
connue au niveau national tout
simplement parce que l'Alsacien mange
l'asperge local ah ouais en vous voulez
dire que rien ne part d'ici tout est
mangé sur place en fait on va dire moi
je pense que 90 % des asperges produites
en Alsace sont mangés par les Alsaciens
et c'est c'est ce qui fait la force ici
ouais ah oui l'Alsacien il mange de
l'asperge alsacienne als
attention ça dit donc quand on quitte la
plain d'sace ça monte hein tout de suite
ah bah là on se trouve àprès de 1000 m
d'altitude on est sur une ferme le
montagne euh la ferme les pensées
sauvages qui est tenue par Mathis beuman
et ses frères et sœurs également un
jeune agriculteur qui s'est lancé il y a
6 ans donc quand on parle de succession
d'entreprise ou d'exploitation bah c'est
important de voir que les jeunes se
réengagent et ça spécialité bah c'est la
production de Minster fermier au les cru
issu de la fameuse racebienne bonjour
bonjour bonjour bonjour on a été attiré
par les Vau par mon et par
vous c'est vraiment le territoire du
fromage de Minster ici ben oui on a le
grand ballon qui est juste là-bas qui
est le plus haut au sommet des vuges
donc normalement on est dans les haut de
vuges après le territoire de Minster est
très vaste on a juste la ville de
masterer qui est de l'autre côté l'autre
vallée d'où le nom et bah chez nous ça
comprend que on est des paysan qui
créent des paysages paysimportant pour
vous essenti paysan paysage je suis plus
paysan qu'Agriculture nos paysans ici
sont vraiment des ils façonnent le
paysage en montagne c'est extrêmement
important on n pense pas mais quand on
voit la forê a tendance à se refermer et
si notre Naim pas les prairies comme ils
le font actuellement prairies de qualité
pour avoir un élevage de qualité et du
lait de qualité c'est toute une chaîne
qui se met en place donc vraiment moi je
je les félicite toujours pour ça bah
c'est surtout une lutte de sauvegarde de
nos valeurs et aussi des soutiens à nos
collègues
ouais même ceux qui font moins bien que
vous agriculteur qui sera moins
respectueux de la nature bah pour moi
c'est de
pas défoncer les agriculteurs parce que
tout le
monde mais c'est de les accompagner
c'est là on espère sur que tous les
sénateurs se boug parce que c'est pas
tout à fait le cas encore il faut
accompagner les agriculteurs tout le
monde tout le monde est capable de faire
ce que moi je fais en agricole peut-être
pas en montagne mais en bas c'est et
c'est possible et on arrive à faire
vivre du monde on fait du pain du
fromage de chair du fromage de de vache
des yaourts des fromages blancs la
chacuterie on propose même des séjours
ludiques s'il faut ici on fait du social
on fait voilà et pour moi c'est ça aussi
à la Confédération paysane on n'est pas
là pour casser de l'agriculteur mais on
est là pour accompagner des agriculteurs
et les amener à changer de pratique
peut-être un peu à s'éveiller c'est
possible un peu de proséti quand même
voilà on peut aller à la fromagerie B
vis on va passer par les tables bien sûr
en plus il fait plus
frais un petit Monceau pour toi h sent
bon super excellent excellent mais la
planche d'picéa qui est là c'est une
planche qu'on change parfois ou elle
retient des ferments sur des années bah
elle est elle peut durer une dizaine
d'années elles sont lavées à chaque fois
qu'elles sont qu'elles on fait elles
sonavé lavé avec quoi à l'E de source et
à
l'ileile rincé en fait non frottter nous
on frotte avec une brosse d'accord
dessus mais après pas de détergent
évidemment ah non ah non si on vient
tuer et là on peut avoir les problèmes
d'ailleurs on a moins souvent des
problèmes en fermier que les cru qu les
pasturisé la bonne flore elle prend
c'est comme une bouteille pleine elle
prend toute la place et si on enlève
tout cette place on peut très bien avir
la bonne flore qui s'installe comme la
mauvaise mauvaises bérieso c'est un
travail méticuleux sur comprendre la
[Musique]
flore alors là je vousi amené dans les
vignes de marieelin ouis qui travaille
en biodynamie c'est un peu leur
spécificité depuis plus de près de 30
maintenant et Marie va nous expliquer en
grande partie en quoi ça consiste et
quels sont les spages qu'il cultive sur
ces magnifiques cotaux d'alsas bonjour
Marie Monsieur Merci de nous accueillir
bonjour Marie alors je comprends que
même en vivant ici en travaillant ici en
étant né ici vous regardez encore cette
beauté ah oui on ne sent lasse pas on
regarde le paysage et en tant que
vigneron paysan on se pose toujours la
question savoir si c'est cohérent donc
la monoculture chez nous c'est pas
cohérent et pu alors on voit partout
dans vosg des nichoirs oui nous avons
plus de 300 nichoirs positionnés à des
endroits stratégiques en plus des arbres
et de la forêt nous avons la chance
d'avoir une belle couronne de forêt
c'est pour avoir un insecticide naturel
alors nous avons plus de 13 sépages ici
au domaine et nous avons la chance
d'avoir une des plus vieilles parcelles
d'Alsace de 1938 qui est une vraie
complantation de de l'époque h il se
trouve que la complantation c'est le
système traditionnel de des de l'ancien
temps en Alsace c'est-à-dire qu'on
mettait sur les mêmes parcell des spages
différents Sylvaner wrling Pino gris
voilà et donc on faisait un vin avec
tous ces raisins mélangés aujourd'hui on
a sérié par ces pages pour une meilleure
compréhension du consommateur final qui
va rechercher plutôt un rling plutôt un
un Stram ma grand-mère me disait
toujours tu vois le musc on l'a mis là
parce que justement il il est sensible
au froid donc faire attention ici le
savoir-faire qui est vraiment la base de
de l'appellation aussi d'origine
protégée ou contrôlé he pouvez nous dire
la différence entre bio euh et
biodynamie alors la la biodynamie est un
est une culture de du soin soin de la
terre soin soin de la plante on va
utiliser un calendrier qui s'appelle
calendrier lunaire des semis suiv de la
lune quoi on suit la lune hm hm en
grande majorité on donc on sait qu'elle
influence les marais mais pas seulement
voilà il y a pas que que les Mar tout à
fait et on le voit en cave c'est pour
les gens qui sont sceptiques il peuvent
venir voir ce qui se passe en cave dans
une cuve quand il y a les coefficients
de Maré très haut les lits qui sont au
bas normalement dans le fond de la cuve
sont en suspension quand on est en marée
haute h et en marée basse donc tout est
tout va vers le vers le sol tout se juge
au résultat dans la bouteille puis dans
le verre voilà tout à
[Musique]
fait ce qu'on aime dans le Wrestling
c'est que c'est un spage qui viment une
éponge à sous-sol il restitue son
terroir ce côté très minéral éponge à
sous-sol tout à fait ça alors moi ce que
j'aime avant tout c'est que ça sente pas
le wracling mais ça sente justement le
terroir surtout en biodynamie encore
plus effectivement on a plus d'influence
donc le climat le
microclimat les vents l'exposition au
soleil et bien sûr notre travail le
travail du du et la végétation
entourante bien sû le paysage paysage
environnant ou combien de générations de
viignnerons ici alors là nous sommes à
la 13e mon frère jeanpul 13 générations
numéro 13 numéro 13 pour l'instant on
touche du gré on touche du gris on est
entouré de bois en tout cas 13 ou on
souhaite pour les 13 générations
suivantes de continuer à faire ce
travail que vous faites chaque jour et
qui porte ses fruits et faireon produit
prend du
temps à moi de vous emmener au
restaurant pour cette dernière étape
alors on va à la maison Kenny
une maison emblématique et je pense que
marial doit être à l'intérieur très bien
allons-y bonjour bonjour marial bonjour
Vinc comment allez-vous bonjour Chef
bonjour bonjour manuel bonjour c'est
votre nouveau chef et ben c'est notre
nouveau chef Emmanuel V voilà mon ch qui
a pris possession de la cuisine
Ludovic je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais vous allez bosser ah non on
l'avz pas dit non voilà j'ai senti chez
vous cette volonté de cuisiner cette
fibre voilà vous montrez chef on sinst
[Musique]
suivez-moi qu'est-ce qu'on va demander à
Ludovic de faire pour la couper en deux
comme ça sur la longueur sens de la
fibre et après on la poser et couper des
biseaux comme ceci on va regarder le
sénateur découper les asperges attention
j'ai la pression attention là je me sens
observé une petite coupe longitudinale
voilà là on sent le l'esprit chirurgien
tout de suite hein et ensuite en bisau
voilà faites attention à vos doigts l ça
m'ennuierait que vous puissiez plus
écrire au mer Vincent je sans vous
important chef on va vous laisser
travailler je reconnais pas ce morceau
de cochon de lait c'est quoi alors en
fait on a la poitrine de cochon de lait
qu'on est venu farcir et rouler comme ça
avec les les abats les oreilles part du
cochon d'accord dites on est quand même
mieux ici que derrière devant le fond ah
vous avez pensé à nous av un petit peu
chaud et c'est quand même mieux avec un
petit vert merci beaucoup ça voilà à
l'alsacienne merci Mar on a toujours une
solution en Alsace gr vu couleur
incroyable cette robe ici c'est un peu
une vitrine pour l'Europe de l'Est vous
avez ce sentiment d'être la terre
accueillante une terre accueillante sans
aucun doute he les Alsaciens on portent
ça dans leur cœur l'hospitalité je crois
que c'est quelque chose chez nous qui
est extrêmement important c'est aussi
nous qui nous ouvrons je crois qu'on
prend pas beaucoup de décisions sans
consulter nos voisins allemands nos
voisins suisses en disant voilà quand on
prend telle décision quelle est chez
vous la conséquence comment vous voulez
envisager voilà ici dans le Hain quels
sont les points clés qu'il faut
surveiller les points clés ils sont
multiples aujourd'hui on est mieux LTI
qu'ailleurs en France c'est la question
de l'eau de la préservation de l'eau on
a une nappe la grande plus grande nappe
burin la plus grande nae d'Europe sous
nos pieds 35 milliards de mè CB donc
pour le coup on n pas ce problème que
peuvent connaître les Pyrénées
actuellement je crois que c'est
extrêmement important pour autant pour
autant on a des agriculteurs qui sont
très consciencieux et qui essayent
toujours d'arroser au minimum ce n'est
pas parce qu'on en a sous les pieds
qu'on l'utilise à tout voir c'est
extrêmement important où est-ce qu'on en
est chef voilà c'est fini ah bah c'est
fini c'est génial on a faim voilà je
vous emmène le petit cochon farci là à
l'sacienne oh
là la sauce à la menthe waouh chacun son
côté hein piquez pas mon cochon he non
mais la réciproque est
vrai c'est très malin chef quand vous
goûte ça vous êtes fier d'être du ha
rein bien sûr je suis fier tout le temps
et nous aussi on est fier de vous
présenter le meilleur de nos
départements avec nos ambassadeurs que
sont les sénatrices et les sénateurs
dans manger ses botes sur publicenna et
vous pouvez retrouver nos émissions sur
la plateforme
[Musique]
publicsena.fr c'était manger S vautés
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
le 8 ma
1945 l'Allemagne naz capitule
enfin à Moscou New York Paris Londres
Amsterdam Prague partout les peuples
jubil sincère
maisre car l'Allemagne naz a be être
battu l'Europe est
anéantie les survivants ple le Mor mais
il porte aussi le poids des ruines
l'URSS les États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne
et la France ont gagné la guerre mais
parviendront-ils à gagner la
paix après Hitler demain à 22h sur
Public
[Musique]
Sénat c'est l'article qui cristallisait
le plus de tension dans le projet de loi
asile et immigration l'article 3 qui
prévoyait la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers dont les
métiers en tension étaient examinés hier
au Sénat la droite n'en voulait pas elle
en a fait une ligne rouge et elle l'a
donc supprimé c'est une séance à revivre
tout de suite dans 100 % Sénat quelques
observations au moment où nous abordons
le fameux article
3 euh chacun a bien compris que euh il y
avait des divergences de vue sur cet
article en particulier sur sa portée on
peut l'appeler desésaccords c'est pas
une question de pointêre clair là-dessus
en particulier sur sa portée l'article 3
d'origine euh du texte nous n'y ét pas
favorbl en tous les cas pour ce qui
concerne euh le groupe les
républicains considérant que il pouvait
enjendrait une régularisation
importante pour ne pas dire massive et
que nous n'étions pas sur cette cette
ligne là pour faire très clair nos
collègues d'autres collègues étaient
plutôt nos collègues centristes
d'ailleurs étaient plutôt sur une une
autre approche ce qui fait que nous
avions décidé en commission des lois de
venir en séance pour mener le débat les
choses ont évolué chacun le sait
maintenant puisque nous les rapporteurs
déposeront ont déposé un amendement
additionnel après l'article 4 cet
amendement additionnel après l'article 4
renvoie au pouvoir réglementaire je
reste dans les des grandes lignes la
possibilité de régulariser des étrangers
en situation irrégulière présent sur le
territoire avec ayant un contrat de
travail et souhaitant rentrer dans la
procédure d'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour il y a évidemment un certain
nombre de conditions supplémentaires
dans cet amendement je le présente mais
les rapporteurs le diront des conditions
de présence sur le territoire des
conditions de durée des conditions liées
au respect des valeurs de la République
au sens large du terme et la possibilité
et la demande qui est faite fa au préfet
dans le cadre de la procédure
d'admission exceptionnelle au séjour de
saisir l'employeur qui est le cignataire
évidemment du contrat de travail afin
que soit vérifié la réalité de ce
travail la conséquence de cet amendement
qui est déposé c'est évidemment la
suppression de l'article 3 d'origine
dans le texte la procédure va donc nous
amener à à cela mais je veux dire que
c'est un ensemble qui est bien clair
nous avons souhaité cette suppression et
nous voterons la suppression de
l'article 3 qui qui été présenté par le
gouvernement et qui est en discussion
maintenant et nous proposerons un
amendement qui est l'amendement
additionnel après l'article 4 qui remet
en place le met en place plutôt le
dispositif que je viens d'évoquer
j'indique également à la Haute Assemblée
même si nous ne sommes pas encore à
l'article 4 que également l'article 4
sera également supprimé les choses sont
parfaitement très claires voilà comment
les choses se présentent maintenant je
regarde le temps qu'il me reste
évidemment le débat va peut-être vous
apparaître un peu compliqué parce que
nous avons des
amendements amendements additionnels
pardon des articles additionnels qui
seront en discussion mais qui seront
supprimé bien sûr mais la discussion
aura lieu c'est la règle il n'empêche
que sur le fond c'est
l'amendement 657 qui viendra remplacer
purement et simplement la suppression de
l'article
3 merci
monsieurci monsieur le Président avant
de don don la parole au ministre je vais
donner la parole au président canner
pour un rappel au règlement oui madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
madame la ministre euh nous souhaitons
faire un rappel au Règlement sur la base
de l'article 33 alinéa 2 euh qui vous
autorise madame la Présidente à
suspendre la séance à la demande donc
d'un membre du de la Haute Assemblée
c'est ce que nous vous demandons pour
une raison simple et j'espère que
Monsieur Darmanin ne voudra pas me taxer
cette fois-ci d'indélicatesse sur le
fait que je souhaite que sur ces débats
qui nous attendent nous souhaitons nous
puissions avoir le ministre au banc ah
bah
oui et je n'oublie pas qu'il y a
quelques mois je recevais dans mon
bureau et j'ai les témoins monsieur dus
sopt et Monsieur daranin pour nous
présenter le grand équilibre j'ai pas
dit le grand écart le grand équilibre de
cette de ce projet de loi entre la
partie intégratrice et la partie gestion
des flux migratoires donc euh je vous me
direz nous avons la chance d'avoir le
ministre de l'Intérieur donc
éventuellement il pourrait lancer un
avis de recherche pour ministre disparus
euh ce serait intéressant mais là
Monsieur dus sopt n'est pas devant une
autre instance juridictionnelle si vous
voyez à quoi je peux faire allusion
monsieur Darmanin donc il peut venir au
banc et donc madame la Présidente je
sollicite
un une suspension de séance d'un temps
nécessaire un quart d'heure ou 20
minutes pour que le ministre Olivier dus
sopt puisse venir au ban défendre
l'article 3 et l'article 4 dont il est
l'initiateur au nom du gouvernement très
bien monsieur le Président canner cette
décision relevant effectivement de la
présidence je ne donnerai pas suite comp
tenu des nombreuses prises de parole
qu'il y a avant le commencement de
l'examen dans le fond de cet article
monsieur le
ministre merci mad Présidente je
regrette que je ne vous suffise pas
monsieur monsieur monsieur monsieur
monsieur le Président d'autant plus que
très largement et médiatiquement vous
avez pris l'occasion de dire la loi
d'armanin ou Géral d'armanin donc d'
seul coup vous cherchez vous-même
l'équilibre mais c'est évidemment une
démarche qui ne trompe personne pour
éviter de de parler sans doute de de de
ce sujet moi je remercie la présentation
du président de de la commission des
lois et l'acceptation par la séance
d'une discussion commune finalement
entre le 3 et puis le 4 bis si j'ai bien
compris qui est l'amendement que a fait
naître madame la
rapporteur tout à l'heure et qui
discutera sur le remplacement du 3 en 4
bit enfin qu'importe le numéro quelle a
été la volonté du gouvernement et
finalement quel est ce qu'on nous
propose la volonté du gouvernement a été
de régler un double problème
qu'aujourd'hui le règlement ne peut pas
régler vous ne pouvez pas régulariser
une personne qui est dans l'irrégular
et qui travaille et qui parfois
travaille dans des conditions
extrêmement diverses on l'a vu dans les
premiers articles de ce texte de loi n
reviendra pas les statuts sont très
divers si son employeur ne veut pas le
régulariser donc les régularisations qui
se font aujourd'hui notamment au nom de
la circulaire Vals je rappelle qu'elles
se font d'ailleurs essentiellement sur
le volet famille 23000 personnes plutôt
que sur le volet travail 7000 personnes
par an vous ne pouvez pas régulariser
une personne dit le code du travail
si l'employeur ne permet pas la
régularisation s'il ne signe pas le
SERFA qui permet la régularisation voilà
pourquoi des gens sont parfois devant
les préfectures parfois soutenus par des
élus parfois soutenus par des syndicat
par des associations pour être
régularisé il n'y a pas de
régularisation malgré une volonté
politique ou préfectorale parce que la
loi est au-dessus évidemment de la
volonté préfectorale ou ministérielle
donc la première volonté du gouvernement
était de mettre fin à à ce ce ce servage
d'un temps moderne que
l'employeur pouvait s'opposer à la
régularisation de son employé qui
pourtant demandait la régularisation et
pourquoi il s'y opposait il s'y opposait
pas pour des raisons évidemment de
respect absolu du de la lutte contre
l'irrégularité puisque sinon il aurait
pas embauché son son employé sinon il
l'aurait s'en serait séparé rapidement
bien sûr il le fait parce qu'il ne veut
pas qu'on découvre sans doute qu'il
emploie lui-même des personnes
irrégulières et qu' en a pas qu'une et
qu'il faut faire le contrôle et que
l'inspection du travail et d'autres font
ce travail de contrôle et effectivement
c'est très cohérent avec l'un article
qui va arriver que malheureusement la
commission des lois supprimé on en
reparlera plus tard ce soir ou demain
qui est la sanction administrative
extrêmement forte contre l'entreprise
qui embauche des irréguliers de façon
évidente et sans avoir été trompé par
ses salariés donc donc notre dispositif
gouvernemental est en premier lieu c'est
ça en premier lieu l'article 3 la
possibilité législative de faire sauter
si je dire ce verrou du Code du travail
régulariser quelqu'un sans son employeur
deuxièmement il
avait comme objectif et il a toujours
comme objectif le fait de régulariser
des personnes dans certaines conditions
qui souvent sont dans ce qu'on appelle
les Ninis ni expulsa ni
régularisable
pas expulsable parce que évidemment leur
vie privée familiale est désormais en
France ça fait de très longues années
qu'ils sont venus en France la grande
moitié des personnes que nous avons à
constater sont là depuis plus de 10 ans
du territoire national ça date pas du
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron ni du second
ni du premier mais pas régularisable
parce queils sont dans les régularités
et que aucun texte de loi ne permet de
le faire parfois un peu la circulaire
Vals mais pas totalement notamment sur
les questions que j'ai évoqué et comme
ils sont souvent employés dans des
métiers dit en tension où là le chômage
qui n'est pas le refuge en se disant il
y a des réguliers qui sont au chômage où
il y a des Français qui sont au chômage
formons-les pour les mettre évidemment
c'est une bonne réflexion que partage le
gouvernement dans les métiers d'ention
dans certaines zones géographiques dit
l'article 3 c'est métiers en tension et
zone géographique tendu donc ce n'est
pas partout sur le territoire national
c'est pas dans un endroit où il y a
beaucoup de chômage répondons à certains
critères depuis plus de 3 ans sur le
territoire national nous pouvions
imaginer le régularisation avec en effet
une prescription le préfet doit alors
régulariser un titre de séjour d'un an
d'un an qui n'ouvre pas droit auement
familial c'est exprimé expressis verbis
et par ailleurs une clause de cette loi
s'arrêtait en 2026 ce qui évitait tout
appel d' même si j'ai eu du mal
évidemment dans le débat médiatique à le
démontrer parce que la caricature était
plus facile puisque c'était évidemment
une clause de 3 ans sur le territoire
national qui s'arrêtait en 26 puisque
nous étions à la fin de l'année 23 il
était évident que que ces personnes
n'étaient pas concernées personne
pouvait venir en France en imaginant
trouver cette régularisation ceci dit
l'important comme je me suis déjà
exprimé c'est l'esprit de compromis que
veut le gouvernement pour avoir
l'essentiel de ce qu'il demande une
mesure de régularisation de personnes
qui travaillent dans notre pays sur
notre pays depuis très longtemps et dont
les patrons ne veulent pas les
régulariser parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
signer surf pour pas qu'on découvre le
poteorose nous avons entendu le
compromis qui a trouvé la majorité
sénatorial que nous appelions de nos
vœux nous l'avons eu un amendement hier
soir il est celui qui va faire naître le
4 bis il est évidemment bien sûr
acceptable pour le gouvernement il y a
un certain nombre de dispositions qu'il
faudra sans doute il y a sans doute des
dispositions qu'il faudra modifier soit
parce qu'elles ont été me semble-t-il
écrites un peu à la hâte soit parce que
parfois elles sont plus larges que les
volontés gouvernementales je fais
remarquer avec un plaisir non non fin à
Monsieur rillot que il il il régularise
plus de monde que que nous l'aurions
fait puisque il il il évite que
certaines périodes de séjour réguli des
durées prises en compte pour apprécier
la satisaction de conditions de séjour
ne soit pas concerné par exemple nous on
avait dit que la qualité de demandeur
d'asile ne rentrait pas ou que le titre
de séjour étudiant ou travailleurs
saisonniers ne rentrait pas mais ceci
étant dit je suis sûr que vous voterz
sous amendement du Gouvernement qui
complétera l'amendement l'amendement qu'
tout ça pour dire que le gouvernement
tout ça pour dire si si Monsieur
président de la commission des lois je
vous l'assure mais on en reparlera tout
ça pour dire que le gouvernement donnera
un avis un avis de
sagesse sur
l'amendement sur l'amendement du 4 du 4
bis parce qu'évidemment il faudra que
nous le retravaillons sans doute à
l'Assemblée nationale continuera à dire
qu'évidemment il tient à son article 3
et donc un avis évidemment qui
permettrait de garder l'article 3 tout
en comprenant qu'il y a un compromis
politique à obtenir ici au Sénat et donc
demain évidemment à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est l'engagement que je
prend avec les parlementaires mais sont
évidment libres de modifier les choses
je vrais ici dire évidemment que c'est
la position entière monsieur canner du
gouvernement d'Olivier dusop qui
s'exprimait publiquement cet après-midi
mais je peux peut-être vous envoyer la
capture vidéo de son intervention si
vous n'avez pas eu le loisir d'avoir des
moyens de communication modernes dont
pourtant notre département du Nord Est
est pourvu et vous dire qu'évidemment je
je remercie de cet état d'esprit
remercier tous les groupes qui ont
participé et singulièrement le président
Marseille qui a porté des modification
qui auraient pu être également
intéressantes et qui sont repris je
crois dans l'amendement proposé voilà
cet article 3 comme cet article 4 bis
n'est pas l'essentiel du texte de loi il
est un article sur 48 il concerne en
moyenne dans la version gouvernementale
7000 personnes par an et il était un
article qui se terminait de lui-même en
2026 je crois qu'il ne méritait pas ni
les bravos ni les aissements de ceux qui
considéraient que c'était affreux ou de
ceux qui
considérai de ceux qui considéraent de
ceux qui considéraent que c'était l'Alp
leoméga du texte c'est évidemment une
mesure qui avant tout permet de régler
des problèmes individuels qui sont
aujourd'hui insolubles surtout féminins
des problèmes qui sont concernés ici
c'est surtout des femmes qui son sont
concerné par cet article 3 et 4 bis et
surtout il nous permet de lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière de ceux qui
embauchent des personnes de façon
irrégulière et j'espère que nous
mettrons ainsi fin un écosystème
irrégulier avec deux dispositions du
texte donc voilà madame la Présidente
parce que j'imagine qu'il a beaucoup de
prise de parole la la la clarté que
voudrait avancer le gouvernement sur les
propositions on fait pas le Sénat très
bien merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est désormais à Monsieur à à
Madame Audrey
linkeld merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le
ministre il n'est pas simple de
s'exprimer sur cet article 3 quand je me
suis inscrite c'était probablement pas
tout à fait le même article 3 c'était en
tout cas celui que vient au départ de
son propos euh de présenter monsieur le
ministre depuis euh nous avons connu le
moment où l'article 3 et l'article 4 ont
été réservés puis le moment où ils ont
été déréservés puis le moment où ils
sont amendés pour se transformer en un
article 4 bis donc plutôt que de
d'essayer de commenter finalement un
article dont on ne sait plus très bien
lequel il est et ce qui le contient
précisément je vais plutôt dire ce qui
nous euh sur les bans des du groupe
socialiste nous paraissait intéressant
dans cet article puisqu'il fait partie
des des rares sujets sur lesquels on
pouvait considérer qu'il y avait des
avancées positives dans ce projet de loi
immigration et et intégration ce ce
qu'il nous semble à nous c'est que en
effet des travailleurs sans papi mais en
France depuis au moins 3 ans travaillant
depuis plusieurs mois déjà exerçant des
métiers dont nous avons tous besoin dans
notre
société aucilire de vie gardien agent de
de
nettoyage cuisiners plongeur voilà que
ces travailleurs là pouvit avoir droit à
une carte de séjour temporaire sans
avoir à en passer par l'analyse
individuelle d'un préfet mais de plein
droit parce que la loi reconnaît la
contribution qui est àure à notre
économie et à notre société voilà ce que
nous défendons voilà ce que nous allons
continuer à défendre y compris avec des
amendements qui permettront peut-être
d'aller encore plus loin que ce que
prévoyait l'article 3 et ce que prévoira
l'article 4 bis merci Madame madame
ponmonge merci madame la Présidente
alors depuis des semaines des
travailleurs sans papiers sont en grève
dans une trentaine de sites d'Île-de-
France dont ceux des JO il manifeste
devant les agences d'intérim les
entreprises de nettoyage il demande à ce
que la raison et la justice voudrai que
nous demandions à savoir la
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
sans papier l'article 3 qui reçoit tant
de critiques sur les bands de la droite
réduit pourtant toujours ces
travailleurs dont une grande partie ça a
été dit sont employés sur des métiers
difficiles et dangereux à une partie une
immigration toujours choisie comme
entériné après les grandes grèves des S
papiers de 2008 par Nicolas Sarkozi et
dont la liste des 30 métiers a ensuite
été formalisé par la circulaire Vals
bris sortefeu disait la loi que j'ai
fait voter prévoit de régulariser au cas
par cas dans des secteurs connaissant de
graves pénuries de main d'œuvre donc
rien de nouveau mais c'est encore trop
il faut durcir durcir et surtout laisser
les régularisations à la main des
employeurs même à postériori cette
politique d'immigration jetable est à
l'œuvre et est à l'œuvre depuis 15 ans
et la droite trouve encore trop laxiste
l'article 3 qui voulait effectivement
l'adoucir c'est une politique inadaptée
en plus de son coup humain comme le
constate Emeline zukbéé sociologue au
CNRS la liste des métiers en tenstion
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui ne
correspond pas du tout au postees
qu'occupent les sans papiers problème
que faites-vous des travailleurs sans
papiers qui ne sont pas donc dans les
soi-disant métiers en tension et que
ferez-vous de ceux qui ne le SER qui le
saont puis qui ne le seront plus de ceux
qui travaillent depuis des années et
font tenir les entreprises et des
secteurs entiers et participent ainsi à
l'effort collectif ce que nous devrions
défendre ce que les écologistes
défendent la position raisonnable et
humaniste c'est la régularisation de
tous les travailleurs sans papier de
plein droit avec un titre de séjour
durable nous en sommes loin et même
limités aux emplois vacants la droite
trouve que c'est encore trop par pure
idéologieci merci madame pensong
monsieur le Président canner merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la
ministre j'ai dans les mains le projet
de loi initial
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration et j'ai pris l'exposé des
motifs que vous avez donc validé avec
Monsieur lopte monsieur le
ministre concernant l'article 3 la carte
de séjour temporaire mention travail
dans des métiers en tension relévverit
de la seule initiative du travailleur
étranger elle serait délivrée de plein
droit sous réserve de la preuve apportée
par tout moyen d'une ancienneté de
résidence sur le territoire et cetera et
cetera c'était l'esprit de l'article 3
qui manifestement est aujourd'hui
dénaturé bien je tiens à vous dire que
nous nous opposerons à la dénaturation
de l'article 3 et aussi de l'article 4
au passage dénaturation qui est résumé
dans le l'amendement créant un article 4
bis dans ce projet de loi chers
collègues régulariser une personne qui
vit en France qui travaille B c'est tout
simplement reconnaître sa participation
à la vie de notre société et euh
monsieur Darmanin a évoqué notre point
commun il y en a quand même euh à savoir
d'être du Nord combien de patrons que
j'ai pu rencontrer dans ma campagne
électorale comme d'autres ici pendant 5
semaines 6 semaines au mois d'août et de
septembre me disait mais donnez-nous
finalement l'encadrement juridique qui
nous permet de donner une vie correcte à
celles et ceux qui enrichissent notre
notre pays je ne suis pas dans le Patos
je suis dans la réalité économique et
même sur les bande droite ici vous savez
qu'il y a cette demande qui qui existe
alors c'est vrai que nous nous voulons
une société un vivre ensemble dans une
république inclusive et tout ce qui ira
contre les principes finalement généreux
du projet de loi initial et bien nous
nous y opposerons avec force avec
vigueur nous voulons des personnes
autonomes intégrées dans notre
République et même si elles sont
étrangères elles méritent notre
considération et encore une fois notre
bienveillance voilà l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous porterons nos amendements à
vos différentes propositions merci
monsieur le président madame
Floren merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames madames et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous l'avons affirmé dès la
discussion générale nous n'avons jamais
été des fétichistes de l'article 3 notre
démarche est pragmatique guidé par la
volonté de parvenir à un compromis
satisfaisant savoir si le dispositif est
à l'article 3 après l'article 3 le 4 ou
le 13 nous importe peu encore une fois
nous ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscité par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
fallait-il créer un nouveau titre de
séjour avec des critères ouvrant un
droit à régularisation dans les métiers
en tension non et ce n'est pas nouveau
c'est ce que nous répétons depuis des
mois notre ligne sur le sujet est
parfaitement claire et n'a pas bougé le
plus efficace nous l'avions déjà dit est
de conserver comme aujourd'hui le
pouvoir d'apprè tion des préfets dans
une gestion des dossiers au cas par cas
y compris dans les métiers en tenstion
c'est ce que prévoit l'amendement que
nous avions déposé à l'article 3 que
nous avons déposé à l'article 3
l'article 3 en tant que tel pose un
problème un problème symbolique pas de
problème mettons cette disposition
ailleurs dans le texte s'appuyons
clairement sur le dispositif de notre
amendement la commission nous propose
aujourd'hui une disposition en
additionnel à l'article 4 et bien mes
chers collègues sans surprise cela nous
convient parfaitement nous sommes
attachés au fond de cet article pas à la
forme comme nous le souhaitons le
dispositif proposé prévoit bien de
modifier le régime applicable en matière
d'autorisation de travail cela a été
rappelé un salarié sans papier qui
souhaite régulariser sa situation doit
recueillir l'accord de son employeur à
travers la signature d'un formulaire
SERFA et de pouvoir afin de pouvoir
proposer son demander son titre de
séjour nous souhaitons pas que cette
disposition soit maintenue c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut prévoir sa
suppression et la suppression de
l'accord préalable donc dans la solution
retenu extrémist excusez-moi madame la
Présidente par la
commission d'appair ni de dénis de
réalité merci Madame Floren monsieur
Bross merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Ministre
je voudrais exprimer ici les les les
regrets de notre groupe nous n'avons
jamais considéré que l'article 3 était
était une panacée nous avions plein de
propositions à faire pour pour en
améliorer la rédaction pour en pour en
étendre
l'application mais tout le monde a bien
compris le sort qui sera réservé à cet
article 3 par la majorité sénatoriale je
dis des regrets parce que cet article 3
permettait au moins de commencer à
sortir d'une forme d'hypocrite
qui fait que des milliers de personnes
qui travaillent en France qui se lèvent
tôt qui se coucheent tard qui bossent
dans des métiers
pénibles le font aujourd'hui sans papier
et donc sans droit des personnes qui
bossent dans le ménage qui travaillent
comme
hboueur qui travaillent dans les travaux
publics et qui bien souvent payent des
impôts et payent des cotisations sociale
et de fait la circulaire Vals avait des
éléments qui à nos yeux étaient quand
même un peu absurdes que pour
régulariser un travailleur sans papier
on ait besoin de l'autorisation de
l'employeur c'est-à-dire de celui qui
bien souvent siamment a fait le choix
d'embaucher un travailleur sans papier
on se retrouve avec un travailleur sans
papier qui doit demmander auprès de son
employeur une
autorisation remplir un SERFA qui lui
permette d'être régularisé tout cela
avac quelque chose d'absurde
cet article 3 nous permettait d'avancer
et je regrette que la majorité
sénatoriale ait fait le choix de
sacrifier cet élément et de sortir de
cette manière là de de l'hypocrisie un
regret donc mais une satisfaction malgré
tout c'est que toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion le prouvent la majorité des
Français qui pourtant sont dures sur les
questions d'immigration sont favorables
à la régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier et je pense que cela
témoigne que cel
mais c'est la réalité un moment donné il
faut être capable de regarder la réit la
parole est à Monsieur Yannick
jade merci merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues on arrive à un point clé de ce
débat c'est
évident monsieur le ministre quand vous
avez présenté ce projet de loi avec une
formule un peu infantilisante mais on va
la reprendre ce projet de ce projet de
loi c'est pour être méchant avec les
méchants et gentil avec les gentils le
résultat c'est que ce projet de loi
c'est simplement être méchant avec les
gentils quand on regarde vous n'avez pas
arrêté ce ce projet de loi et ce débat
n'est construit que sur des mensonges et
des
contevérités le mot clé le mot clé que
vous avez incontestablement réussi à
faire passer dans l'opinion publique
c'est appel d'air pas une étude pas un
expert pas un chef d'entreprise pas un
syndicaliste ne confirme l'appel d'air
l'immigration serait incontrôlable c'est
faux aucune statistique ne le valide il
faudrait revenir sur la dignité des
personnes attaquer les étudiants refuser
de soigner les immigrés il faudrait
limiter les mariages mixtes et le
regroupement familial et c'est comme ça
qu'on répondrait à un enjeu de
société vous êtes à côté ce débat est un
débat parallèle est un un monde
parallèle par rapport à la réalité les
Françaises et les Français les
entreprises les citoyens attendent mux
du Sénat ils attendent que nous
répondions sur le fond à la question de
l'immigration et aujourd'hui c'est un
projet de loi du désordre et du mensonge
parce que laisser des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans l'illégalité
dans l'indignité dans la précarité alors
qu'ils construisent la France avec
nous la parole est à Monsieur
[Musique]
benaroche la parole est à Monsieur
benaroche monsieur
benaroch
le
silence monsieur benaroche et à lui seul
merci beaucoup je vous remercie madame
la
Présidente je voulais faire une petite
jeunèse de cette histoire de ce projet
de loi en fait monsieur le
ministre je vous rappelle quand même le
titre premier s'appelle assurer une
meilleure intégration des étrangers par
le travail nous sommes rencontrés
d'ailleurs au tout début début comme
vous avez rencontré tous les présidents
de groupe du Sénat à accompagné d'un
certain nombre de sénateurs j'étais donc
avec le président Guillaume gottard
lorsque vous nous avez reçu avec Olivier
du sopte qui à ce moment-là était
souvent
présent on l'attend peut-être je ne sais
pas euh et vous nous avez expliqué
quelle était quelles étaient vos
intentions monsieur le ministre et nous
vous avons dit avec Guillaume Gard que
nous les comprenions nous pouvions même
envisager que euh nous pourrions
apporter un certain nombre d'idées
supplémentaires à cell que vous aviez
déjà évoqué qui on été rappelé tout à
l'heure pour une meilleure intégration
par le travail euh en France des
immigrés après cette après ce début
monsieur Darmanin cette loi est arrivée
au Sénat elle a été profondément
modifiée par la commission des Lois du
Sénat puis elle a été stoppée net dans
son élan par le gouvernement euh on a
entendu qu'il en aurait finalement deux
et puis après on a dit qu' en aurait
zéro et puis peut-être qu' en aurait une
et puis peut-être qu' j' en aurais une à
un moment donné on ne sait pas quand et
nous sommes retrouvés devant le retour
au projet de loi voté par le Sénat à la
version
sénatoriale maintenant et la principale
différence c'est que maintenant la
négociation qui avait lieu avant a eu
lieu en direct live au Sénat et que donc
en fait vous l'avez dit vous-même d'un
projet qui était fait pour favoriser
l'intégration par le travail en France
il il en est ressorti un projet qui a
pour seul intérêt pour vous d'arriver à
un us parce que ce qui compte pour vous
c'est l'esprit de compromis c'est-à-dire
le consensus politicien voilà ce qui est
devenu le projet de loi travail et
intégration par par le travail monsieur
le ministre et Monsieur les sénateur
monsieur benénaroche la parole est
maintenant à Madame
Vogel merci madame la Présidente alors
en effet on arrive au moment de la
discussion de l'article qui au fond
était là pour servir les éléments de
langage du gouvernement nous avons un
projet équilibré il marche sur deux
jambes la jambre des horreurs et la
chambre des douceurs alors les horreurs
on a vu hein depuis lundi suppression de
la me durcissement du regroupement
familial décalage des allocations
familiales et cetera et cetera et puis
là on devait arriver à la jambe des
douceurs très faible il s'agissait de
donner un peu de dignité à un peu de
personnes pendant un peu de temps
c'était ça l'article 3 et là il est
question de l'amputer cette jambe alors
de la part des républicains et de la
majorité sénatoriale ça surprendra
personne la véritable information de ce
soir c'est celle qui vient du
gouvernement en réalité quand vous nous
dites que vous êtes prêt à donner un
avis de sagesse sur la suppression de
l'article 3 qui était l'article que vous
vendiez partout dans la presse pour
expliquer vous avez donné un avis de
sagesse sur l'amendement 655 qui est un
amendement de de l'article 3 monsieur le
ministre ou alors j'ai mal compris
j'espère vous le corrigerez la véritable
information de ce soir c'est que le
gouvernement préfère perdre l'honneur
pour garder une loi que de perdre un
vote pour garder la
face merci Madame Vogel le président
retaillot bien oui merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre bien sûr
que c'est un moment clé de la discussion
de ce texte et depuis le départ nous
avons dit notre opposition à l'article 3
et à l'article 4 et ce soir j'espère
bien qu'ils seront
supprimés alors c'est extraordinaire
monsieur le ministre vous manquez pas
d'air je sais qu'en politique le culot
c'est souvent une qualité je le
reconnais et vous voulez faire croire
que le dispositif proposé par la
majorité sénatoriale c'est l'équivalent
finalement de du dispositif que vous
proposiez mais queeneni ou alors les
groupes de gauche se trompent pourquoi
est-ce que tous les groupes de gauche
montent au créneau parce que eux voient
bien la comparaison et il savent bien
que la proposition qu'on fait c'est pas
du tout la proposition initiale qui
était le sommet le paroxisme de la
macronie en même temps pourquoi on
s'opposait et pourquoi c'est beaucoup
plus restrictif parce que vous l'article
3 notamment c'est un droit automatique
vous fraudez et plus longtemps vous
fraudez plus la fraude est dissimulée et
plus ça vous génère et plus la fraude
est créatrice de droit d'un droit
opposable d'un droit automatique que
même l'administration ne pourra pas
stopper B nous on voulait pas et c'est
pour ça qu'on va le supprimer et qu'on
le remplace par un durcissement de la
circulaire et votre dispositif n'est pas
quantifiable mais c'était des dizaines
de milliers sans doute de régularisation
le nôtre est beaucoup beaucoup plus
quantifiable et surtout il est tenable
il est tenable parce qu'il ne crée pas
un droit automatique et nous allons
durcir ce qu'on on appelle la circulaire
Vals mais ça sera pour les médeins
ention et si d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre si d'ailleurs il y avait un
sous-amendement pour le restreindre
encore plus moi j'invite les collègues
de gauche et de droite à le voter même
si ça vient de vous
voyez merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Dosu merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais dire que je suis d'accord avec
le ministre quand il a justifié la
désertion ou la capitulation du du
gouvernement en race campagne
d'aujourd'hui pas quand il a dit cet
article 3 ne méritait pas grand-chose
c'est la réalité nous aussi nous pension
qu'il méritait pas grand-chose puisque
nous les écologistes nous sommes
attachés à la valeur du travail à
l'égalité des droits et donc à la
régularisation des travailleurs ce qui
travaillent ici ceux qui parfois payent
des cotisations ici ont droit au même
droit que les autres travailleurs ici la
droite préfère les clandestins et le
travail au noir comme ça vient d'être
dit par le président
retaillot et donc